Der Missil weiß, wo er ist, auf alle Fälle. Er weiß dies, weil er weiß, wo er nicht ist.
Wenn man, wo er ist, von wo er nicht ist, oder wo er nicht ist,
von wo er nicht ist, erhält man eine Veränderung oder eine Veränderung.
Das Guidance-Subsystem benutzt Veränderungen, um korrekte Anforderungen zu generieren,
um den Missil von einer Position, wo er ist, zu einer Position,
wo er nicht ist, und an einer Position, wo er nicht war, zu kommen. Er ist es jetzt.
Folgendermaßen ist die Position, wo er ist, jetzt die Position,
wo er nicht war. dass es folgt, dass die Position, in der es war,
jetzt die Position ist, in der es nicht ist.
In dem Fall, dass die Position, in der es ist, nicht die Position ist,
in der es nicht war, hat das System eine Variation erhalten.
Die Variation ist die Veränderung zwischen dem Ort, wo das Missile ist,
und dem Ort, wo es nicht war. Wenn die Variation ein wichtiger Faktor ist,
kann sie auch von der GEA korrigiert werden. Trotzdem muss das Missile auch
wissen, wo es war. Der Missile-Gesetz-Computer-Szenario funktioniert so.
Weil eine Variante einige der Informationen, die das Missil enthält,
verändert hat, ist es nicht sicher, wo es ist. Trotzdem ist es sicher,
wo es nicht ist. Innerhalb von Gründen. Und es weiß, wo es war.
Es subtrakt nun, wo es sein sollte, von wo es nicht war. Oder vice versa.
Und indem man dies von der algebraischen Summe von wo es nicht sein sollte und wo es war.
Kann es die Veränderung und ihre Variante entfalten, dies nennt sich So hallo, da sind wir wieder.
Hallo.
Moin. So Ralf, sag mal was.
Ich teste mal.
Ah, ich wusste nicht, ob ich mein Audio-Setup entschuldige.
Ja, also auch Podcaster müssen irgendwie wissen, wo sie sind,
weil wenn sie nicht wissen, wo sie sind, dann sind sie auch nicht,
wo sie nicht sind und dann...
Sieht sich jetzt noch ein bisschen wie die Rumsfeld Unowns an.
Ich stäuber wäre auch mal wieder am Start.
Also Rumsfeld ist ja sehr gescholten worden für diesen Kommentar,
aber das ist ja tatsächlich wirklich extrem philosophisch was er da von sich
gegeben hat und durchaus auch
jetzt nichts neues was er sich ausgedacht hat, sondern das ist a Thing.
Was hat er denn gesagt?
Naja, er meinte, es gibt halt so die vier Annons, also der Hintergrund erst
mal Irakkrieg und es ging um die Beweislage,
ob denn nun Irak Massenvernichtungswaffen welcher Art wo auch immer hat und
dann hat Donald Rumsfeld dieses klassische Vier-Quadranten-Modell aufgemacht.
Es gibt die Dinge, die wir wissen und von denen wir wissen, dass wir sie wissen
und es gibt Dinge, die wir nicht wissen, von denen wir aber wissen,
dass es sie gibt, aber wir wissen sie halt nicht.
Das sind dann die known unknowns und der spannende Quadrant ist aber dann die
unknown unknowns, wo also Dinge da draußen sind, von denen wir keine Ahnung
haben und wo wir auch noch niemals ahnen, dass es sie nicht gibt.
Genau und das ist, also ich finde nicht, dass er gescholten worden ist.
Also von allen Leuten, die irgendwie so ein bisschen intellektueller,
philosophischer angehaucht haben,
die haben das sehr gefeiert, dass so eine Birne in einem in der Tat verwerflichen
Kontext dann aber doch endlich mal was brauchbares rausgegeben hat,
weil dieses Vier-Quadranten-Modell benutze ich in der Tat erstaunlich häufig. Also es funktioniert.
Wahrscheinlich von vielen einfach nur als schlechte Ausrede interpretiert worden.
Was es in dem Fall auch war. Das kann man glaube ich schon so sagen.
Das mit dem Missile ist auf jeden Fall aus so einem Air Force Dokument und ist total ernst gemeint,
allerdings extrem komplizierte Beschreibung des Algorithmuses,
wie diese ganze Missile, wie weiß ich, wo ich bin und kriege ich das unter Umständen
dadurch raus, dass ich vor allem erstmal weiß, wo ich nicht bin.
So im Prinzip funktioniert aber es ist halt so ein dermaßer Gedankendreher,
dass man da nicht so richtig mitkommt. Aber so ist das, wie bei Podcasts.
Ich sag erstmal hallo hier ist die Freakshow, wir sind's,
es ist die Ausgabe 267 und wir senden am 14 Juli 2023 mal locker 10 Tage später
als wir das ursprünglich vorhatten,
aber mir ist da etwas dazwischen gekommen und es war unmöglich den Termin zu halten.
Und es wäre fast auch dieser Termin noch geplatzt, wenn ich nicht gestern wie
durch ein Wunder wieder von den Toten auferstanden wäre, aber die letzten zwei
Wochen waren echt wirklich der totale Terror und ich wäre zu nix zu gebrauchen gewesen.
Genau, so und begrüßen wir erstmal die Runde und ich fange mal zu meiner rechten
Hand, da ist nämlich der Beamer und da begrüße ich Dom.
Ja hallo.
Moin Moin, wir probieren das jetzt mal aus, weil es wurde ja immer gefordert,
Freakshow muss auch mal remote können und so und das haben wir ja auch gemacht.
Und idealerweise fällt jetzt das Bild aus, während du mich vorstellst.
Ist nicht dein Ernst?
Doch, dein Bild ist jetzt weg. Da steht jetzt Tim Pritlow. Jemand hat entweder
den Videoknopf gedrückt oder ich weiß nicht.
Wir sehen dich aber noch und die Kamera sieht dich auch noch.
Tim hat mit der Remote auf den Tisch gehauen.
Wunderbar. Ihr seht mich super. In irgendeiner Form ist einfach kein Videosignal
mehr da. Aber ich bin da heute als Remote-Gast und eigentlich haben wir hier
ein tolles Setup, wo ich auf dem Video den Tisch so sehe, als würde ich da sitzen.
Das haben wir sehr gut vorbereitet. Guck mal Tim, da unten links Video starten.
Was denn?
Zweiter Button von links.
Wieso ist das aus?
Keine Ahnung, aber es ist.
Video starten.
Jetzt habe ich den Tim etwas näher an mir dran als ich gerne hätte.
Okay. Naja komm, so schlimm ist das jetzt auch nicht. Mit anderen Worten jetzt siehst du mich wieder.
Genau und das Geile ist, ich habe natürlich auch ein Echo jetzt,
aber es ist ja so ist es wohl.
Achso, weil auch noch.
Nee, laut ist es ja nicht.
Ich weiß nicht woher ich das Echo habe, aber ich habe jetzt ein bisschen ein
Echo von mir selber auch noch.
Dom siehst du das alte Kamera Video oder siehst du jetzt das Macbook Kamera?
Ich sehe das Macbook Kamera, ich sehe Tims Ohr.
Tim, du musst die Source vom Video umschalten. Du hast das zwar jetzt in Video
übertragen, aber du überträgst das von deiner Kamera.
Sie sind leicht dabei und warten ihre Hände drinnen, meine Damen und Herren.
Ich weiß auch warum, weil die Webcam nicht mehr da ist. Das funktioniert ja
total super hier als neues System.
Warum eigentlich?
GoPro, hurra.
Also die GoPro ist aber noch verbunden mit dem Computer, nur das blöde Zoom.
Jetzt sagt sie irgendwas mit USB.
Und das geile ist, die Beleuchtung ist halt auch, ihr müsst euch das so vorstellen,
die Beleuchtung ist so ausgelegt, dass die gut beleuchtet sind,
aber für die GoPro und jetzt das Laptop Video schaut direkt in so eine mehr
oder weniger eine fette Lampe rein und jetzt habe ich eher so einen Eindruck
von so einem FBI Interview.
Sprechen Sie.
Also aus irgendwelchen blöden Gründen kennt Zoom diese Webcam gerade nicht,
obwohl sie läuft und die Software meint sie läuft, ich kann sie mal starten,
also die Kamera selber sagt jetzt USB verbinden, siehst du?
Ja, ja, weil ich jetzt gerade die Software hier neu starte, um erstmal zu gucken, ob es daran liegt.
Ist ja immer so mit diesen ganzen dynamischen Dingern, aber Zoom sieht das nicht.
Übrigens das mit dem nicht durcheinander reden klappt schon total super.
Jetzt seh ich euch ja natürlich auch nicht, jetzt kann ich nicht mal irgendwie das.
Ich werd mal kurz hier, wir machen das hier gleich mal mit dem,
wir machen das mal mit dem Zoom mal neu, Sekunde.
Aber das Gute ist wir hören uns ja noch und das ist alles worauf es ankommt
und ich kann ja erstmal mit der Vorstellung weitermachen und Roddy begrüßen, hallo Roddy.
Ja, guten Abend.
Da muss ein R rein in das Wort.
Ja, das ist dir gelungen da eins einzubauen.
Ich weiß auch nicht wieso.
Willst du noch irgendwas anderes schönes sagen an unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer gerichtet?
Sehr gerne, aber vielleicht nicht in der Vorstellungsrunde.
Okay, gut. Dann leite ich gleich zu Ralf weiter, der ist nämlich auch da. Hallo Ralf.
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend.
Jetzt auch noch ein paar salbungsvolle Worte bitte.
Ich freue mich sehr auf die heutige Sendung und ich glaube es ist eher ein Vorteil,
dass wir sie ein bisschen später machen und nicht ein zwei Tage nach der WWDC.
Später als, achso.
Weil wir schon so viel jetzt an reflektierenden Gedanken und Beiträgen verarbeiten konnten.
Theoretisch zumindest.
Kann der Sendung nur gut tun.
Ja okay, verstehe. Gucken wir mal, jetzt haben wir hier auf jeden Fall diese
Webcam ist jetzt sozusagen da.
Und jetzt müssen wir nur noch den Dom hier auch wieder bildtechnisch wieder reinholen.
Ist das nicht schön, wie so Sachen, die eigentlich jetzt niemanden wirklich interessieren.
Wäre ja so viel einfacher, wenn Studio Link auch schon das Video hätte.
Es gibt ja ein Prototyp seit Dezember, aber ich hatte Sebastian extra nochmal
gefragt im Vorfeld, das ist wirklich noch Alpha und noch nicht stabil genug
für Produktion, aber Kein Druck.
Kommt bestimmt. Mach mal hin.
So, jetzt siehst du uns richtig, Tom?
Jetzt sehe ich euch wieder und muss wirklich jetzt aufpassen,
weil ich muss ja die Zoom-Anwendung korrekt bedienen und die richtigen Knöpfe
drücken, dass nicht auf einmal Audio über Zoom kommt und wir alle keine Ohren mehr haben.
Weil das Joint Audio ist der Default-Knopf.
Alles noch im Problem. Also unser Versuch ist,
dich hier sozusagen so echt es geht hier in die Situation zu bekommen und eigentlich
müssten wir wahrscheinlich jetzt alle schon mit einer Vision Pro hier sitzen,
um sozusagen das richtige Podcast Gefühl im Cyberspace zu haben.
Hilfe. Auf das Thema kommen wir gleich noch zurück.
Tim hat sich ja eigentlich vorgenommen für diese Season jetzt endlich mal,
dass wir uns vorbereiten und die Themen in irgendeiner Form hier aufschreiben
und eine Reihenfolge haben und jetzt macht er einfach, spring da ans Ende,
weil er kann ja, ist ja deine Sendung ne.
Es gehört ja auch zum Trademarkt der Sendung, latent chaotisch zu sein,
wenn wir jetzt so viel Struktur haben ist ja auch nicht gut, ne?
Beschweren sich dann auch wieder alle.
Ja, was ist passiert? Also wir hatten unsere letzte Sendung veröffentlicht am
um, wann war das? Schon eine Weile her, 26. Mai.
Oh Gott, das tut mir so leid.
Aber genau und wir hatten uns ja auch ganz bewusst so ein bisschen mit dieser
drohenden Veröffentlichung von Vision Pro beschäftigt,
wer das noch nicht gehört hat kann jetzt hier auch mal Pause machen und sich
anhören wie wir uns da um den Kopf um den Kragen reden, also ich zumindest.
Ich kenn dieses Gespräch ja, ich hab ja in jeder Sendung, in der ich Gast war
versucht dieses Thema irgendwie anzuschneiden und du hast es so abgesäbelt jedes Mal,
dass es überhaupt keinen Spaß gemacht hat, darüber nachzudenken,
was denn cooles dabei passieren könnte und du hast das letzte Mal wieder so
gemacht gefühlt, also ich hab das vorher auch nochmal gehört.
Spoiler, ich werde nicht 100% von meinen Thesen zurücktreten heute,
aber mal gucken, was daraus kommt.
Vielleicht bewegt sich der alte graue Herr ja noch ein bisschen.
So, wollen wir gleich loslegen mit WWDC oder wollen wir erstmal irgendwelche
anderen Sachen reinschmeißen? Vielleicht haben wir da noch ein paar Kleinigkeiten,
die wir vorwegwerfen können.
Ja ich weiß was, 50 Jahre Ethernet. Ich muss mal ein Loblied auf Ethernet anstimmen.
Oh Ethernet, du schöne. Ich finde Ethernet ist einfach der geilste Standard,
den die Computerindustrie wahrscheinlich je hervorgebracht hat.
Da muss ich gleich mal rein grätschen. Sprichst du jetzt von dem was man heutzutage kennt,
diese RJ irgendwas Stecker die man so klick irgendwo reinsteckt oder sprichst
du auch von Fick Ethernet mit seinen Anschlüssen die man da so reinschrauben
musste oder Fin Ethernet wo einem immer die Terminatoren abhanden gekommen sind.
Internet war zu jedem Zeitpunkt immer die beste Lösung.
Und was echt bemerkenswert ist, dieser Standard ist 50 Jahre alt,
50 Jahre alt, aber so wie er gespeckt ist und wie er gedacht wurde,
funktioniert der immer noch tadellos und man würde heute nichts anderes machen.
Also ich finde die Vision von Isarnet, die war einfach so scharfkantig genial, richtig.
Dass es einfach gepasst hat, ich meine sogar das mit den MAC-Adressen reicht noch,
also man war vor 50 Jahren da sozusagen,
also ich weiß nicht ganz genau wann jetzt die MAC-Adressen konkret in der Form dazu kamen,
aber im Prinzip war das ja von Anfang an so mitgedacht,
aber es reicht immer noch um irgendwie Millionen an Mini-Routern,
IOT-Devices, Pipapo und noch Bluetooth und so weiter, alles funktioniert nach
diesem selben Schema, die Namensräume funktionieren noch, es mag da irgendwann
noch mal Probleme geben, aber
Es ist nicht so wie IPv4 was nach 20 Jahren schon gefühlt so ein bisschen sein
Leben ausgehaucht hatte und jetzt so die ganze Zeit auf Live-Support noch irgendwie
gehalten wird, weil viele Leute immer noch nicht bereit sind irgendwie mal Administratoren
einzustellen, die irgendwie ihre Sache auch gelernt haben.
Und Ethernet funktioniert super. Und dass natürlich damals die Hardware limitiert
war ist klar, aber die Idee war großartig.
Man macht einen Bus und alle schreien da drauf rum.
Und auch Finn Ethernet war gut, also wer vielleicht nicht weiß wovon wir reden,
weil ihr ja alle natürlich wieder, wie so spät geboren seid,
also ich war ja auch nicht dabei, doch warte mal halt.
Finn Ethernet hast du doch bestimmt erlebt.
Sag mal, es fällt in meinen Alterszeitraum, aber es ist jetzt nicht das erste
Moment, wie ich mich beschäftigt habe mit der Grundschule.
Ich kann mich ganz gut an die Finn Ethernet Probleme erinnern.
Ja. Fick Ethernet hab ich tatsächlich auch nicht mehr erlebt.
Wir müssen das kurz erläutern.
Erklärt es doch mal die beiden.
Also Thin Ethernet ist das BNC Kabel, wo man diese komischen T-Stecker hatte
und dann hat man ein langes Kabel mithilfe von diesen T-Steckern an Netzwerkkarten
hinten an PCs irgendwie rangeklemmt und dann hat man an beiden Enden einen sogenannten
Terminator Widerstand gemacht,
damit das Signal am Ende nicht reflektiert.
Ohne jetzt weiter auf die Elektrotechnik einzugehen. Das war Thin Ethernet,
aber es gab, bevor es Thin Ethernet gab, gab es noch Thick Ethernet.
Das war im Prinzip auch ein Koaxalkabel, das war nur deutlich dicker.
Ich kann jetzt nicht genau sagen wie dick, aber ich glaube es war mindestens
zwei Zentimeter dick. Wenn nicht noch dicker.
Und dort hat man also gleiches Prinzip, ein Kabel, alle senden auf das Kabel.
Also Daumen, Zeigefinger hast du gerade gemacht, das trifft es in etwa,
ne? Also so ein dickes Teil.
So und da hat man, um etwas anzuschließen, gab es dann so eine Klammer mit so einem Dorn.
Man hat also irgendwie die Klammer um das Kabel drum gemacht und den Dorn reingeschraubt,
sodass der Dorn innen in den inneren Leiter des Koaxaldingens hatte und außen
die Schelle irgendwie an den äußeren umwickelten Leiter ging.
Und das nannte sich Fick Ethernet.
Aber wie gesagt, das hab ich, genau, Vampirklemme, da steht's.
Ja, die hab ich nochmal gesehen, auch in so alten Pfunden von alten Geräten.
BNC selber hab ich noch, so hab ich mit Netzwerk begonnen und interessanterweise
auf meinem Akkorn, und da war es glaub ich auch schon gleich Ethernet, wir hatten nix eigenes.
Hat jemand von euch irgendwie mit Apple Talk und den Alternativen,
die es denn gab damals wirklich zu tun gehabt? Und warum waren die doof?
Also was war da schlecht? Apple Talk war da auch cool oder?
Die waren auch super.
Apple Talk war cool, aber langsam.
Also erstmal, Apple Talk ist ja das Protokoll. Die Hardware war Local Talk, das war langsam.
Es gab auch Ether Talk, das ist dann Apple Talk über Ethernet,
das war auch okay, nicht so performant wie IP, aber anderes Ding.
Vielleicht nochmal kurz zu diesen Kabeln, also mit diesem Vampirklemmen.
Ich kannte diesen Begriff noch nicht. 50 Jahre Internet, aber ich habe den Begriff
Vampirklemmen. Nein, wie geil ist das denn bitte? Ich sauge hier die Daten raus.
Für alle diese Art von Anschlüssen, wo du halt das Ding einfach reinhämmerst.
Selbst die Dinger, wenn man jetzt so ein Ding krimmt an so einer Box,
nennt man das noch teilweise so.
Deswegen also wenn man einfach das einfach so rein tischt und dann hat es halt
einmal zusammen quetschen und dann geht's, wenn du es richtig getroffen hast,
so Krimpen ist der Soft Porno Begriff für die Vampirklemme.
Das interessante an Thin Ethernet das mit dem mit dem üblichen Koaxalkabel was
man wahrscheinlich so kennt, ist dass die Kabel, die Thin Ethernet Kabel hatten
50 Ohm Wellenwiderstand, während normale,
Fernseh- oder Radioanschlusskabel 75, ohm Wellenwiderstand und wenn man das
andere Kabel benutzt hat, dann ging's nicht.
Das war auch eine sehr beliebte Fehlerquelle von Leuten, die nicht wussten, was sie tun.
Wir sind uns schon eilig, dass der RJ45 Stecker schon auch Mist ist, oder?
Also ich hab irgendwie kein Kabel wo nicht nach zwei Jahren da der Schnupsi, also dieser Nase ab ist.
Also ich wollt grad sagen, also es gibt.
Aber woran erkennt man die richtigen Kabel?
Die haben da so einen Schnupsi Schutz aus Gummi obendrauf.
Auch die über dem Schnupsi.
Die gehen kaputt, also.
Ja auch die gehen kaputt.
Das ist nicht perfekt, aber ich würd sagen es ist, ich hab da etwas gelernt.
Lass uns das mal kurz, wenn wir schon diese 50 Jahre ESA und jetzt aktuell diese Stecker haben.
Diese Stecker sind ja so, dass man die nicht einfach rausziehen kann und man
kann die oben so drücken,
damit man diesen Umkehrschutz drücken kann, um die rauszuziehen und was ich
bis vor kurzem echt nicht gewusst habe, man muss die ein bisschen reinschieben
dabei, weil die haben nochmal einen kleinen Widerhaken da oben,
der davor bewahrt, dass man den aus Versehen runterdrückt.
Das heißt man muss die ein bisschen reinschubsen, dann zusammendrücken und dann
rausziehen und dann geht es ganz easy, da muss man sich nicht die Finger brechen
dabei und ich bin so froh, dass ich es gelernt habe inzwischen.
Und ich glaube Clemens beißt schon in die Tischkante.
Er beißt in zig Ethernet. Er möchte seine Glasfasersplasie. Clemens ist die
Vampirklemme des Podcasts.
Ja, also nochmal zum Sinn. Ethernet, also 10BASE2 heißt das ja offiziell.
Ich weiß noch, 1992, ich erzähl jetzt wieder vom Krieg, gab's,
Entschuldigung, 93, gab's ja das erste Hackercamp.
Also das erste richtige Hackercamp und zwar jetzt nicht das Chaos Communication
Camp, das kam dann erst später, sondern das wurde ja in Holland erfunden.
Und das war At the End of the Universe und was willst du mir gerade sagen, Rudi?
Dom hat schon wieder kein Video.
Okay, alles klar. Das scheint ja gut zu funktionieren hier mit der GoPro.
Naja, ich erzähl mal kurz noch zu Ende, wie ich das fixe.
Und 1993 gab es natürlich noch nicht so viel Internet. Und das CAMP hatte aber
tatsächlich eine Verbindung zum Internet in Form von zwei 19.200,
Bit pro Sekunde US Robotics Modems, die irgendwie zusammengeschaltet waren.
Und wahrscheinlich auch nicht legal damals.
Ach in Holland.
Achso in Holland ja.
Also in Holland haben die drauf geschissen, verboten war immer alles nur in
Deutschland, in Holland sind die ja irgendwie mit der Zukunft immer schon ein
bisschen näher dran gewesen.
Auf jeden Fall hatten sie da quasi Internetverbindung und dann gab es da eben
so dieses Campinggelände wo so ungefähr so 50 Zelte rumstanden und der Hauptsport
auf dieser Veranstaltung stand da drin ein Thin Ethernet Kabel auf dem Campingacker
von Zelt zu Zelt rennen zu lassen,
also einen großen Ring herzustellen, Atmen ist schon schwer ne,
Um dann irgendwie da ein Tröpfchen Bit aus dieser Modemverbindung zu entnehmen.
Und es ist auch ab und zu mal gelungen und war dann immer ein großes Hallo.
Ja, soviel nochmal zu Zen Internet. Aber heutzutage ist es schon besser geworden.
Mittlerweile gibt es ja auch Internet über alles. Man kann das ja auch über
Thunderbolt Stecker, USB-C rüberjagen, dann wird es auch richtig fix und dann
hat man auch bessere Stecker.
Also ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass wir so in Zukunft vielleicht auch
mal das RJ45 Gedöns loswerden und durch andere Sachen machen,
aber dann müssen diese USB-C Kabel echt nochmal viel billiger werden.
Ich wollt grad sagen, glaub ich nicht.
Im Chat schreibt noch jemand Token Ring, muss man vielleicht an der Stelle auch nochmal erwähnen.
Token Ring hatte natürlich immer das Problem, wenn der Ring unterbrochen war, ging gar nichts mehr.
Und das ist wohl auch relativ häufig passiert, während Thin Ethernet zwar zu
der damaligen Zeit jetzt auch nicht viel robuster war, aber,
wie du bereits sagtest, robuster als alles andere.
Insofern hat sich Token Ring glaube ich auch nicht so richtig durchgesetzt.
Vor allen Dingen, das war auch so ein Rechenzentrum-Ding, glaube ich.
Das wurde in der freien Wildbahn eher nicht verwendet.
Es tut mir total leid aber diese GoPro Webcam Software stellt irgendwie,
ich weiß nicht ob die ihren Dienst einstellt, also eigentlich meint sie sie
funktioniert noch aber der Zoom schüttelt diese Kamera ab,
dann ist es irgendwie nach einer Weile wieder weg und zeigt mir das nicht an
und jetzt müsste ich jedes mal wieder irgendwie das neu starten,
das ist wirklich zum kotzen ey.
Kann nicht einfach mal irgendwas einfach mal funktionieren ich meine alles was
ich gebraucht habe ist eine webcam mit 120 grad die einen nicht arm macht und
sowas scheint der mark kaum herzugeben dachte ich mir nimmst du so eine gopro
was kann schon schief gehen wenn die ein webcam modus hat ist doch alles super naja.
Er hat ja vor allem auch schon länger funktioniert als jetzt nicht funktioniert
also wir hatten ja die sendung praktisch so in vorbereitung hat es halbwegs funktioniert.
Naja was machen wir denn da jetzt?
Naja nochmal neu starten nochmal gucken ob sich irgendwas verändert.
Kannst nicht anders machen jetzt.
Hast du einen Sleep-Timer in der Software wo du irgendwas drehen kannst?
Da gibt's überhaupt nichts das einzige was ich einstellen kann ist 1080p und 27p und das war's. So.
Ja und du stellst 1080p ein oder?
Ja.
Ich kann dir auch weniger geben aber das bringt er jetzt nicht.
Du kannst mal versuchen das parallel im Quicktime-Player aufzumachen oder so.
So ein Mist, dass es irgendeinen zweiten Klienten gibt von dem selben Videostream,
vielleicht ist es dann stabiler oder ist es schlimmer, man weiß es nicht so
genau. Du bist ja gerade auf Ventura gegangen oder? Vor Ventura wäre das natürlich nicht passiert.
Mit Sicherheit.
Daran liegt es bestimmt.
Wir feiern Ethernet und wir, wann feiern wir denn USB? Oder? Was?
USB wird nicht gefeiert.
Also USB feier ich erst, wenn die tatsächlich es hinkriegen,
dem Standard beizubringen, dass Tastaturen auch eine Marke dafür haben,
welche Belegung draufliegt.
Das ist eine Tastatur an Klemme, die relativ viel Intelligenz hat,
aber nicht weiß, wie sie belegt ist. Das geht halt einfach nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wer da nicht auf die richtige Idee gekommen ist, aber ne.
Gut, ich mach mal einen kleinen Teaser, würde ich gerne mal loswerden und zwar,
ich weiß nicht, hat sich vielleicht ein bisschen herumgesprochen,
dass ich in dem Ladefuchs...
Team, Projekt, Mitarbeiter. Und zwar Ladefuchs ist eine App für Elektro-Auto-Fahrer,
die auch gerne mal unterwegs laden.
Diese App mit dem Rules-Icon meinst du, oder?
Das Icon ist tatsächlich von den gleichen Leuten designt, die auch die Rules-Tiere
designt haben. Aber das war auch so gewollt.
Ja, das ist auch abgesegnet, das ist auch alles gut. Passt.
Das wollte Malik so haben.
Die kleine Welt so klein.
Genau, das wollte Malik so haben. Gibt viele Grüße von Malik an alle.
Ich nehme an, das betrifft auch die Hörer. So, und wir sind jetzt kurz davor,
die Version 2.0 rauszubringen. Die Version 2.0. Und zwar muss man vielleicht
noch mal kurz erklären, was der Ladefuchs macht.
Und zwar, es gibt Ladesäulenbetreiber, auch CPO oder Chargepoint Operator genannt.
Und es gibt dann die Leute, die einem den Strom tatsächlich verkaufen.
Die werden, glaube ich, Charging Service Provider genannt oder so.
Keine Ahnung. Ist ja auch nicht so wichtig. Aber es ergibt sich dann eine Matrix
aus den Leuten, die einem den Strom verkaufen und den Leuten,
die die Säulen aufgestellt haben.
Und an dieser Matrix steht gerne an jeder Stelle dieser Matrix ein anderer Preis.
Und um das so ein bisschen, um es möglich zu machen, dass man schnell nachgucken
kann, welchen Preis hat man denn zu erwarten, haben ein paar Wahnsinnige vor
einiger Zeit eben diese Ladefuchs-App angefangen.
Und der Markt an Chargepoint Operators und den eigentlichen Service Providern
ist so dermaßen volatil, dass wir da nochmal ein paar Sachen hinzugefügt haben,
unter anderem eine Detailansicht.
Man kann also jetzt in der Liste 11 auf eine Karte tippen und bekommt eine Detailansicht,
wo dann auch so Dinge drinstehen wie eine Blockiergebühr oder ob es monatliche
Gebühren zu einer Karte gibt oder sonstige Notizen.
Diese Version 2.0 wird in den nächsten zwei Wochen rauskommen.
Also eigentlich ist sie schon fertig, aber das große Press-Release-Big-Bang-Ding,
sie dauert noch ein bisschen, aber für den Sommerurlaub sollte es dann noch reichen.
In diesem Fall, ja, was letzte Preis, ändert sich halt ständig.
Deswegen gibt es diese App.
Es wäre schön, wenn es diese App nicht bräuchte und einfach alle Anbieter einen
ordentlichen Preis machen würden,
aber es gab ja auch mal diese komischen Vorwähler, diese Internetprovider,
Wahlprogramme und ähnliche Dinge.
Aber wie kann man wirklich so eine wichtige Infrastruktur gleich vom Staat weg
so wieder so vergeigen wie Deutschland das macht, ich verstehe das nicht, also es ist wirklich.
Ich glaube du hast dir die Antwort schon gegeben, das war das Wort mit dem D.
Genau, das Wort mit dem D.
Ich habe ja eine Zeit in Amerika verbracht, das ist jetzt nicht so,
nicht so tragisch im Verhältnis.
Es ist nicht so viel besser da drüben, es ist nur alles anders und ein paar
Leute sind ein bisschen privilegiert, die haben ein paar ein bisschen gute Infrastruktur,
aber ansonsten ist das alles recht anstrengend.
Mach uns Mut.
Ja, genau. Ich mache euch sehr viel Mut, weil das Videobild ist jetzt schon
wieder weg. Vielleicht musst du die GoPro irgendwie kühlen oder so.
Aber sie hat das ganze eine Minute zwanzig gehalten.
Du hast Video auch aus gerade, ne? Guck mal.
Video geht dann immer automatisch aus.
Geh nochmal in das Zoom-Fenster rein.
Ja und dann?
Da unten, Video starten, ist schon wieder aus, die Kamera.
Ja, ist das aus, weil es weg ist, weil die Webcam verschwindet.
Und dann kann ich sie auch nicht wieder neu, nicht wählen.
Drück mal doch links einfach mal auf diesen durchgestrichenen Bereich.
Ja, dann nimmt er hier meine interne Kamera. Nicht die GoPro-Kamera,
weil die nicht mehr auftaucht.
Die ist jetzt natürlich besser als nix. Vielleicht machen wir das jetzt erstmal,
bis dir was Besseres einfällt.
Weil dann habt ihr mich noch, weil ihr habt mich am großen Screen, das hilft ja schon mal.
Aber was mache ich denn da? Schenke ich die dann wieder zurück?
Weiß ich nicht. Ich habe so einen Webcam-Haufen. Ich habe so eine Opal C1 gekauft,
weil ich gedacht habe, für Remote-Arbeiten ist das ja noch cooler.
Aber das ist auch eine Hipster-Cam, die ist echt zu teuer, wird zu heiß.
Aber ist halt wenigstens nicht
die Connectivity-Camera. Das kannst du noch ausprobieren. Dein iPhone.
Mach doch dein iPhone dahin. Du brauchst jetzt während der Sendung dein iPhone nicht, oder?
Dann kannst du doch mit der Connectivity-Kamera, wenn du die anschließt über
USB, kannst du das machen.
Connectivity-Kamera.
Der Hinweis kam auch schon im Spätstück.
Continuity-Kamera.
Continuity-Kamera, stimmt. Das wäre ja mal ein Feature.
Also eins von euren Telefonen, das ihr nicht braucht.
Stimmt.
Aber es muss schon mit Tim gepairt sein.
Stimmt, ich habe ja sogar Weitfinken-Köln.
Das sollte eigentlich ganz gut funktionieren aber du kannst dein Handy währenddessen
nicht benutzen also ich fand diesen Einwand den du in der letzten Freakshow hattest,
der ist nicht nur der der war bei mir gefühlt auch so deshalb habe ich die teure
Webcam gekauft obendrauf weil ich habe zwar erstmal so Stative für über den
Monitor mit zusammen gebastelt und die Kamera geht ganz gut.
Also wirklich sieht auch echt gut aus weil ist ja eine geile iPhone Kamera aber
du hast halt das Telefon nicht und das Telefon nicht haben ist so ein No-Go
irgendwie, Weil man so viele Reflexe hat da was nachzugucken und was zu machen.
Aber doch nicht während des Podcasts.
Nicht während des Podcasts unbedingt, aber während einer normalen Videokonferenz immer.
Sag mir mal kurz wie ich das überhaupt, ich weiß gar nicht wie ich das überhaupt mache.
Anstecken, einfach nur per Kabel anstecken und dann taucht es auf als Option. Das sollte schon sein.
Ja Kabel anstecken, also brauch ich hier ein.
Also du hast jetzt nicht gemerkt wie Apple gerade versucht dir ein zweites iPhone anzudrehen?
Ein Lightning auf USB-C.
Also ich muss das ja, ich brauch ein langes Lightning auf USB-C, das ist das Problem.
Erstmal irgendeins um zu testen, ob es geht, dann kannst du es irgendwo hinhalten
und dann kann man es ja optimieren. Ich meine, es kann ja sein,
dass das Setup nicht so gut läuft dann auch.
Ich gucke erst mal, was das längste Lightning-USB-C ist, was ich hier habe.
Es kommt auch noch die relevante Frage im Chat, warum eigentlich nicht FaceTime statt Zoom?
Audio-Stack auf dem Mac dann auch. Das ist auch nicht so dolle.
Also er ist die Kamera auch weg, aber so FaceTime macht immer irgendwas mit
dem Audio-Stack, dass auch dann die Aufnahme nicht so gut funktioniert.
Das heißt, wenn man das nach dem
Selberrecht macht, ist das ein bisschen gefährlich. Ja, bei mir, bei mir.
Nee, das andere. Ah, okay.
Also mein Audio kann das zerschießen und deswegen trauen wir uns das immer nicht so ganz mit FaceTime.
Liebe Hörer, nachfolgende Themen verschieben sich um.
Na gut.
Ich werde das mal probieren hier parallel, aber wir müssen uns nicht weiter
darüber unterhalten, bis ich hier ein passendes Kabel gefunden habe und dann
gucke ich mal ob ich da Erfolg haben werde.
Also noch ein bisschen Kleinkram vor der WWDC hättest du gerne.
Ich kann noch ein kleines Kram bringen und zwar wir haben uns in der letzten
Season irgendwann mal über den Amen Break unterhalten,
dieses Sample wo manche Leute sagen das ist der meist gesamplete Song der Welt.
Das ist so.
Es gibt,
von meinem Lieblingsmusiktheorie-Profi, 12tone nennt er sich auf Youtube,
gibt es jetzt ein Video, wo er diesen Amen-Break auseinander nimmt und ich finde
das muss man mal gesehen haben.
Ich schmeiß das mal eben in den Slack rein.
Was ist da jetzt anders als die ganzen anderen Videos, die sich damit schon
lange auseinandergesetzt haben?
Gute Frage, da ich die anderen alle nicht gesehen habe.
Ich hab die glaube ich alle gesehen.
Kann ich dir das jetzt so nicht beantworten, ich finde nur,
dass Twelve Tone üblicherweise eine sehr schöne Herangehensweise an das Thema hat,
zu ergründen, warum Musik funktioniert,
wie sie funktioniert und er beschreibt sehr schön,
wie dieser Break als Musikstück funktioniert, warum der so erfolgreich ist und
so weiter und wie es dazu kommt, dass der so einen besonderen Groove hat.
Das ist interessant, weil...
Was du gerade gesagt hast ist
ja so, wenn man selber ein bisschen was mit Musik irgendwie zu tun hat,
ich glaub man bleibt irgendwie bei einem YouTube Musikerklärbär hängend und
sagt sich so warum soll ich noch zu Thema XY noch 50 andere angucken,
wenn ich weiß irgendwie hier we've got you covered.
Bei mir ist das in der Tat Rick Beato.
Super.
Ja der ist auch nicht schlecht, das stimmt.
Also dessen Hauptgeschäft ist es halt irgendwo,
was auch immer für Songs, Rock, Pop, Elektronik,
was auch immer, halt live durch zu analysieren und er kann halt alles spielen
und sitzt im Tonstudio und produziert auch selber Musik und spielt den ganzen
Kram dann einfach mal live nach und erzählt wie da gerade so die Akkordfolge
ist und was da gerade speziell dran ist und der macht auch so relativ tagesaktuelle
Sachen als beispielsweise jetzt bei der dritten Season von Stranger Things hier.
Kate Bush mit Running up the hill so so gechartet ist und die ganze Jugend gar
nicht wusste was es eigentlich für ein Song ist, hat er sich dann gleich hingesetzt
und gesagt okay lass ich erzähl euch mal was warum dieser Song hier so great ist.
Den Kanal kann ich also auch sehr empfehlen, der kommt jetzt nach Berlin und
ich werde wahrscheinlich leider nicht nicht hinkommen, den hätte ich mir echt
mal gerne live angeguckt.
Das Schöne an Twelve Tone ist, dass er erzählt nur was und spielt so ein paar
Dinge ein, aber er zeichnet immer quasi live dazu.
Also er zeichnet ein bisschen das langsame,
als es dann hinterher abgespielt ist, aber er zeichnet erstens unheimlich schöne
Elefanten und er zeichnet auch einfach sehr schöne,
Auch die Assoziationen zu dem, was er sagt, was er dann zeichnet,
ist auch immer großartig.
Also allein sich das Video anzugucken, um seine Zeichnungen zu sehen,
glaube ich, lohnt sich schon.
Aber ja, hab jetzt genug Werbung dafür gemacht. Schaut's euch an,
findet's gut oder schlecht. Also, ja.
Im Bibliotheksbereich versuche ich ja immer die Leute ein bisschen zu schocken,
weil die meistens nicht so medienaffin sind. Und so eine meiner Klassik-Slides,
die ich dann drin habe, ist, was ist eigentlich in den jeweiligen Jahrzehnten
so der Hauptkristallisationspunkt des Menschheit-Wissens gewesen?
Wie ist dann halt irgendwie von den alten Bibliotheken, der Kloster,
die ganzen Iterationsschritte und irgendwann hast du dann halt den Brockhaus
und dann ist es aber irgendwann die Wikipedia geworden und der derzeitige Status
quo ist einfach YouTube.
Es gibt also als die zentrale Wissensquelle und da gibt es eben nicht nur Bibis
Schmicken Videos, sondern da gibt es also unendlich viel Wissensressourcen.
Man muss sie halt einfach nur suchen, aber es ist nicht so, dass sie sich da
besonders gut verstecken. Zu jedem Thema, wo man sich aufschlauen will,
findet man da einfach was.
Ja manchmal ist es schlimm, weil du suchst dann irgendwas, wie mach ich denn
das und das und dann findest du nur ein YouTube-Video und dann denkst du so,
ich will jetzt aber kein YouTube-Video finden, ich will jetzt hier schnell einen Text überfliegen,
Um zu sehen, ob es das ist, was mich weiterhilft, was mich weiterbringt und
dann kann ich den auch nochmal ordentlich lesen, aber nicht jetzt irgendwie
20 Minuten YouTube gucken.
Dafür nehme ich dann in der Tat mittlerweile Chat-Gipel-T4.
Nicht unbedingt in Bezug darauf, danach weiß ich es, aber dann habe ich zumindest
schon mal genug weitere Schlagworte, nach denen ich vernünftig weitersuchen kann.
Wenn ich also den Eindruck habe, okay, grundsätzlich scheint mir das hier in
die richtige Richtung zu gehen, aber ich will es nochmal genauer wissen,
dann weiß ich zumindest schon mal, wonach ich dann noch besser auf anderen Kanälen suche.
Und bei YouTube gibt es, glaube ich, auch wirklich eine geile Suchmaschine für
sämtliche Texte in YouTube irgendwo. Ich habe jetzt leider den Link nicht mehr
sofort am Start, aber letztens wurde mir hier reingespült in die Timeline und das war sehr hilfreich.
So schlecht ist das ja, wir haben jetzt mittlerweile schon mal eine iPhone Kamera
und schwenken sie wild in der Gegend herum.
Es hat so ein bisschen eine, weiß
nicht, Viva 2 oder so, oder wie war das damals, diese Shaky Cam Nummer.
Du bist jetzt aber noch nicht im Weitwinkelmodus, ne?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie ich den einstellen kann.
Einfach Fingerswipe gib mal her.
Wie Fingerswipe?
Du darfst währenddessen Fingerswipe machen, aber es geht auf Standby,
das musst du im Quicktime Player einstellen oder so ein Scheiß,
das ist so ein bisschen bescheuert.
Also du musst praktisch die Kamera konfigurieren, weil das Gerät selber ist
gefühlt danach einfach im Standby und nur im Standby funktioniert es,
wenn du es wieder benutzt, machst du Pause. Das ist so ein bisschen… Auserlaube Apple.
Für unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer, wir filmen jetzt wirklich gerade schon mit
der iPhone Kamera, das funktioniert.
Streamen sozusagen. Und ich dachte, Tim ist jetzt schon so grau und senil,
dass er nicht mehr weiß, wie man auf einer iPhone Kamera irgendwie den Weitwinkel
aktiviert, aber das, während jetzt hier gefilmt wird und das iPhone angeschlossen
ist, in der Tat der Screen schwarzt.
Das heißt also es gibt ja überhaupt nichts, wo man jetzt swipen könnte oder pinchen.
Genau, bei einem Quicktime-Player solltest du dir in der Lage sein,
praktisch die Einstellung auszusuchen oder so von der Kamera,
indem du Maximum Quality machst oder irgendwie sowas und das sollte dann für
alles gelten. Irgendwie so.
Ist ein bisschen kompliziert, aber sollte schon gehen. Ja, jetzt passiert was anderes.
Kurze Pause. Irgendwas hast du umgestellt? Weniger Auflösung?
Da habe ich die Qualität hochgestellt, aber das heißt nicht,
dass ich hier einstellen kann, dass er Weitwinkel macht.
Also vielleicht macht er ja Weitwinkel, aber...
Dann geh mal rechts oben ins Control Center. Ich glaube, da geht es. Ins Control...
Upsala. Jetzt habe ich wieder was...
Nicht im Telefon, sondern auf deinem Laptop. Gehst du ins Control Center rechts
oben. Genau, du kannst ja meine Kamera darauf zeigen, dann geht es auch.
Und dann solltest du bei der Kamera, glaube ich, was einstellen können,
weil du kannst ja da auch diesen Modus, dass du den Projektor-Modus hast. Folgemodus, was?
Folgemodus.
Und noch eins?
Versuch mal mit Alt drauf zu gehen, ob du da noch mehr Konfektionen hast.
Ich hab nicht drei Hände.
Also Dom, du hast, ich halte die Kamera.
Wie du hast nicht drei Hände?
Dom, du hast recht, da gibt es Einstellungen, aber leider noch keinen Weitwinkel.
Jetzt probier mal mit Alt, Klick.
Oh Gott, diese neuen User Interfaces.
Oh das ist auf alle Fälle schon eine Google Frage, die sehr hoch aufkommt und dann,
wenn man vorher das auf Weitwinkel stellt bevor man es verbindet,
hast du das mal probiert? Ich sag's dir gleich.
Ich bin jetzt in einem YouTube Video, das ich erst durchgucken muss, natürlich.
Also ich trenne das mal und mache einmal weit Winkel und dann schließe ich es mal an, ja?
Es geht nicht, aber es gibt so ein paar die Apps, die das können.
Okay, dürfen wir jetzt endlich die Hörer fragen, die wissen sowieso mal alles besser.
Also ich brauche eine Kamera, die mindestens 120 Grad macht, mindestens.
Und zwar nicht Temperatur, sondern Winkel.
Ja genau, ich weiß es gibt da irgendwelche super teuren Konferenzdinger,
vielleicht gibt's ja noch eine gute Alternative und ihr habt da irgendeine,
die sind dann auch also voll integriert und dann versuchen die wieder so viel zu intelligent zu sein.
Vielleicht ist tatsächlich so eine normale Kamera die beste Option,
wo man dann einfach ein Objektiv drauf schraubt.
Kann man auch machen, wenn die einen Live-Modus hat.
Ich habe ja dummerweise so eine Sony Alpha, die es genau nicht hat oder nur
einen ganz bescheidenen HDMI-Output gibt. Aber es gibt durchaus die Möglichkeit,
wenn du so eine Kamera hast, muss man sich halt auch informieren,
welche, weil nicht alle das geile Signal draushauen.
So schlecht war es jetzt ja gerade gar nicht, wenn wir die da hinten an die
Wand stellen, dann könnte das ganz knapp sogar reichen.
Aber mir fehlt jetzt das Kabel dafür. Ich habe einfach nicht so ein langes USB-C auf Lightning Kabel.
Du hast auch kein Verlängerungskabel oder sowas?
USB-C Verlängerungskabel habe ich auch nicht.
Es geht auch über WiFi und übers Netz, aber das macht euch wahrscheinlich das
Netz kaputt parallel. Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Problem ist.
Kannst du nicht mit USB-C auf USB-A und dann verlängern und dann auf Lightning?
Ich habe jetzt auch keinen Stativadapter und so weiter. Ehrlich gesagt,
ich habe jetzt auch keinen Bock. Ich glaube, das Projekt gilt erstmal als gescheitert.
Wir sehen dich, du siehst uns nicht, aber du hörst uns ja.
Ja, dann mach bitte aber deine an wenigstens.
Meine?
Ja, damit du wenigstens so den Moderator hast.
Okay, gut. Ich könnte ja noch so einen Spiegel halten.
Das Interessante war, dass du ja eigentlich den originalen Sendetermin auch
nach hinten geschoben hast, weil du erst das Kamerasetup machen wolltest.
Ne, das hatte andere Gründe. Naja gut. Alright. Fine. Dann würde ich sagen gehen
wir nochmal in Richtung WWDC.
Worldwide Developers Conference.
Warum nennen die überhaupt diesen Buchstaben W, wenn das so kompliziert ist
auszusprechen und dann müssen sie die ganze Zeit Abkürzungen,
das ist ja so als würden wir die ganze Zeit Yps Yps sagen.
Tun wir das nicht?
Hab ich noch nie gemacht Yps Yps.
Ja ein Lehrer tun das.
Wenn man nicht über das Heft spricht, nein sagt man normalerweise nicht Yps.
Ich meine wenn Webseiten mit Y Y Y anfangen würden, würden wir wahrscheinlich
auch Yps Yps Yps sagen. üps üps üps.freakshow.fm.
Okay, wann geht die live?
Mal gucken, ob das Händler noch passiert.
Naja so ist das halt. Na gut. Also auf jeden Fall fand statt,
fand wieder statt auf diese Art und Weise wie sie es die ganzen letzten Jahre,
oder schon gar nicht, wie sie es letztes Jahr gemacht haben.
Nämlich einerseits live gestreamt zu was weiß ich wie vielen Leuten,
haben wir da irgendwelche Zahlen genannt bekommen, wie viele Leute dazu gehört haben?
Kann ich mich nicht erinnern.
Das ist was sagen die gar nicht ne? Nee. Aber das dürften ne Menge gewesen sein.
Also das ist schon ein Streaming Event. Das kann man sagen.
Also bei Ralf waren wir zu wievielt? Zu fünft Katze und Kinder jetzt mal nicht mit gerechnet.
Das ist ein Drittwahn war oder?
Du möchtest jetzt sozusagen Ralfs Wohnzimmer hochrechnen auf die Weltbevölkerung?
Ich weiß nicht ob das funktioniert.
Das war jetzt nicht mein Ziel aber ja kann man auch machen.
Naja, in gewisser Hinsicht finde ich ist es, also mir geht ja diese ganze,
alles ist prerecorded Nummer ein bisschen auf den Senkel.
Ja, okay, es ist alles gut produziert meinetwegen, aber das war es früher auch
und es ist halt überhaupt nicht mehr...
Wie soll ich sagen, es ist nichts besonderes mehr,
es ist nur noch so eine Hochglanz-Produktshow, wo man so durchblättert und ich weiß,
ich müsste noch nicht mal live dabei sein, weil ich kann mir das in zwei Stunden genauso anschauen.
Das geht,
natürlich auch für die alten Kinos, die erinnern sich ja nach zwei Stunden auch nicht.
Ja dieser jensen wang hat sich da komplett zum horst gemacht und alle haben
sich lustig gemacht aber egal.
Ja ich würde auch nicht widersprechen. Also ich finde man hatte am Anfang von Corona,
also bei der bei den ersten sagen wir mal ein bis zwei Keynotes hat man so den Eindruck,
okay dafür dass es nicht live ist machen sie das jetzt aber doch ganz manierlich,
weil es war dann ja zu dem Zeitpunkt schon noch ein bisschen was frisches und
neues und hatte vom Production Value her war es natürlich deutlich besser als
alles was die anderen so hatten.
Aber das hat sich jetzt wirklich halt ziemlich schnell abgenutzt und ich verstehe
auch nicht ganz, warum sie jetzt die letzte nicht wieder live gemacht haben,
weil coronatechnisch hätten sie es ja eigentlich können.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich wegen der Vorlaufzeit.
Der organisatorischen Vorlaufzeit. Da hättest du vor einem Jahr,
hättest du dir sicher sein müssen, dass du das nicht unter Corona-Bedingungen machen.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob sie jemals wieder zurückkehren oder ob sie sagen,
wir sind hier eben nur mal die Control-Freaks und werden es immer sein und je
mehr Kontrolle desto besser.
Sie können halt viel Content, der jetzt für eine Keynote für sie inzwischen wichtig geworden ist,
der damals immer so dieser Übergang war zu den Einspielern und den Werbevideos eigentlich,
der jetzt aber mehr integriert ist, die können da das Rad nicht mehr so richtig
zurückdrehen glaube ich, weil das Verhältnis zu ich bin jemand der was Ding
auf der Bühne präsentiert zu da kommt irgend so diese ganzen Effekthascherei
und der ganze Kram drum rum,
das passt halt einfach nicht mehr zusammen vom Stil her, ich glaube die wollen da auch nicht mehr hin.
Ich vermisse es schon ein bisschen und ich muss es sogar sagen,
dass ich es auch ein bisschen in den Engineering Sessions vermisse.
Ich finde zwar, es ist viel angenehmer jetzt, wenn du was nachhören willst und
was lernen willst und so kriegen kannst, weil es eben nur so lange ist,
wie es sein soll und mehr polished und gleich mit Subtitles und allem.
Aber es war schon irgendwas anderes. Also für mich auch. Ich habe mehr Content konsumiert auch.
Nicht nur deswegen, weil ich jetzt nicht mehr so swifty bin,
sondern es ist halt wirklich auch so, das ist halt so ein steriles Videoformat.
Ja, kannst du schon durchgucken, kannst aber auch irgendwie querlesen,
kannst versuchen eine Doku zu finden, aber so dieses Gefühl,
dass du das anguckst und dann Leuten, also wirklich, dass du dabei bist,
so ähnlich wie bei einer Konferenz.
Wenn ich bei einer Konferenz bin, dann gehe ich in Sessions und dann erlebe ich die Sessions.
Ich gucke mir die Videos aber im Nachhinein nicht so sehr an und so ähnlich
geht es mir jetzt mit diesen Videos noch viel mehr als mit den Videos davor.
So, die habe ich gerne auch nochmal nachgeguckt und jetzt ist es echt so,
boah, die gucke ich jetzt nur, wenn ich das Wissen wirklich brauche.
Naja gut ich war nie auf der ich war nie auf der Konferenz selber insofern kann
ich hab ich immer nur Sessions nachgeguckt die ich spannend fand und dann natürlich
auch nicht alle insofern ja weiß nicht.
Aber die Kino selber war die denn spannend.
Also mir geht durch diese Hektik der Abfolge was verloren,
also ich fand das eigentlich viel sinnvoller, dass man sich noch mehr aufs wesentliche
konzentriert und natürlich fand ich den Entertainment Value einfach auch extrem hoch.
Also ich meine gerade die Steve Jobs Ära war einfach super unterhaltsam, fand ich.
Und gut, dass Tim Cook da nicht liefern kann, aber ich meine er hat ja irgendwie
genug alberne Vögel um sich herum, das kann ja auch funktionieren.
Naja aber ich meine, gut du hast jetzt keinen Steve Jobs mehr,
was sollen sie machen? John Hodgman irgendwie auf die Bühne holen oder was?
Frederici finde ich ja ganz, also.
Herr Force One?
Ja.
Boah der hat sich gemausert.
Der wird wahrscheinlich nie Apple Chef werden, aber wenn er es wäre, dann wäre wieder was da.
Ich meine das ist jetzt für Apple vielleicht nicht das allerwichtigste mich
zu unterhalten so und am Ende werden sie natürlich an verkauften Geräten gemessen,
aber das ist natürlich so ein Ding.
Ganz ehrlich, wie lange habe ich jetzt Macs seit, also ich habe meinen ersten
Mac 84 mal angefasst und ich glaube 99 oder 91
habe ich irgendwie meinen ersten gekauft und wenn man damals ein Auto sah,
wo hinten ein Apple Aufkleber drauf war, dann war das so, boah was,
es gibt auch noch andere.
Und gestern fuhr nämlich irgend so ein Porsche mit so einem Apple-Aufkleber
vor mir her. Und ich dachte mir nur so...
Oh Gott, ich muss in den Underground so,
also klar da können sie jetzt nichts hören,
das ist vorbei, das ist schon länger vorbei, aber wir sind ganz interessant,
wir haben ja jetzt wieder so eine Keynote wirklich in der es um eine Produkteinführung
geht, das heißt das ist ja ganz selten diese Dinge wie sie passieren,
Und ich finde auch, die ist leider viel zu steril gewesen im Verhältnis.
Wir kommen ja nachher gleich dazu.
Aber die war so, wenn du das iPad, selbst die Watch, die Watch war ja so ein
Event, so ein Live-Event, der auch keinen Sinn gemacht hat mit dem ganzen Gold.
Und wenn ihr das nochmal vor Augen führen könnt, dieses Watch-Video,
das dann auch im Stream übrigens abgekackt ist, irgendwie mit Interlaced-Streifen
und so gelaufen ist, so richtig ein schöner Fail gewesen damals.
Aber wenn man den Switch hat von iPad oder vom Telefon noch,
oder vom iPod, oder auch von Mac OS X, wo hat diese Produkteinführungen,
diese größeren, diese geileren, dann ist die jetzt schon irgendwie zu polished
rund und gar nicht so weit weg von so einem Google-Video gewesen.
So gefühlt. Und das finde ich auch ein bisschen schade, weil das hat irgendwie
mehr Spaß gemacht früher, weil begeistert hat es mich schon.
Die anderen haben halt auch einfach nachgezogen, finde ich. Also Microsoft-Geschichten,
Google-Geschichten, so ist es auch nicht so, dass die jetzt halt auch irgendwie
erst vor zwei Jahren auf den Trichter gekommen sind. Oh, okay,
vielleicht gehört das auch zu unserem Imageaufbau mit dazu.
Da ist auch einfach mal die gesamte Welt hat sich da verschoben.
Und ich glaube, vor zig Freakshows, als ich auch irgendwann mal Gast war,
habe ich schon gesagt, eigentlich müsste Apple mal wieder ein neues Grundformat irgendwie erfinden.
Also wo man wieder mal so ein Paradigmenwechsel hat und irgendwie mal wieder
eine ganz andere Art von Showkonzept in Anführungszeichen mal irgendwie ausprobiert.
Aber ich hatte damals keine Ahnung wie das aussehen könnte und hab's heute immer noch nicht.
Ja jetzt wäre ein guter Zeitpunkt dafür das stimmt. Ein Musical oder so.
Oh da kommt das Forstelcom zurück. Scott Forstel kommt zurück,
der hat ja Musik produziert.
Vielleicht irgendwas Dezentrales, dass du also irgendwie in den Apple Store
deines Vertrauens irgendwie pilgerst und hast dann da dann auch gleich irgendwie
eine Hands-on Geschichte ausliegen oder sowas.
Und es die Division Pro selber gibt natürlich einfach neue Formatdinger vor,
die sie auch nutzen werden für ihre Produkte natürlich, ganz klar.
Also das ist so, das ist nicht weit weg, was du gerade sagst indirekter Weise.
Also wenn Division Pro funktioniert und die Produktsegmente.
Die haben ja ihre Store-Infrastruktur. Warum dafür nicht Tickets verkaufen und
überall auf der ganzen Welt kannst du dann im Vorfeld das gemeinsam angucken.
Dann hast du schon mal ein bisschen mehr Live-Feeling als sonst und danach hast
du eine Hands-on-Area, als ob du da eben...
Wenn du in San Francisco bist, fände ich nicht so abwegig.
Sowas in der Art habe ich damals zur Einführung von dem Powermac G5 mitgemacht,
da hatten die tatsächlich so einen größeren Saal gemietet, dann gab es eine
Übertragung und hinterher konnte man dann in einen anderen Raum laufen und da
waren dann da die Kisten aufgestellt und man konnte da drauf rumklicken.
Also klar du hast mehr Chaos, du hast mehr irgendwie Leute die viel zu früh
anfangen irgendwo sonst was für Details dann irgendwie abzufotografieren,
jetzt müssen sie halt nur einen Raum unter Kontrolle halten,
ja das ist natürlich mit tausend Räumen, du musst die Sachen durch die Welt
schicken, da gehen natürlich dann Kisten verloren und werden sonst wo schon irgendwie geleaked.
Klar ist es nicht einfach, aber ich bleib dabei sich irgendwas in der Richtung
neu einfallen zu lassen wäre glaube ich keine schlechte Idee.
Gehen wir auf den Inhalt.
Genau, lasst uns mal schauen, was denn jetzt eigentlich tatsächlich vorgestellt
wurde. Es gab ja das eine oder andere interessante Produkt dabei,
auch ein paar uninteressante und ein paar die interessant sind,
weil sie so uninteressant sind.
Wieder bei den Unknowns.
Zunächst einmal gab es glaube ich das Macbook Air in 15 Zoll und dazu gibt es
von mir einen Daumen hoch, wenn es nicht halt diesen blöden Notch hätte,
den ich generell aussitze.
Da ist dann ja was vor dir.
Ich hab die Tastatur komplett ausgesessen, die kaputte.
Die hab ich auch ausgesessen.
Das hat sechs Jahre gedauert, da habe ich keinen Macintosh gekauft.
Guck mal, gerade Roddy und ich, wir sitzen vor Notch-Laptops,
also mich hat's noch nie auch nur im Ansatz gestört.
Also ganz ehrlich, die Notch guckt sich so schnell weg, wie beim iPhone,
das ist… Dieser riesen Menubar, da krieg ich ja schon… Also gerade wegen dem
Menubar geht es noch viel schneller weg als bei allen anderen Geräten,
weil es ist ja auch gerade beim 15 Zoller echt wurscht.
Beim 12er, 13 und 14 so von der Größenordnung merkt man es so ein bisschen,
weil eben halt einfach der Statusbarplatz ausgeht und das ein bisschen peinlich
ist. Aber ansonsten, Heike, du sagst es, der Platz geht weg.
Also ich habe hier ein 14 Zoll, das ist schon okay. Das kann man machen.
Es ist nicht so schlimm, dass die Kamera da drin ist, ist schon ganz gut.
Ich meine, die Kamera sollte eher noch besser werden. Das Display soll noch
tiefer werden und nicht dünner. Insofern, wenn du die Notch noch wegnimmst,
dann wird es noch eher schlimmer alles.
Außerdem bin ich ein großer Freund von dem Wedge Shape,
also ich finde einfach das M1, Macbook Air,
das ist einfach Hall of Fame, ganz weit oben, das ist einfach einer der geilsten
Computer die Apple je produziert hat und ich werde die noch so lange kaufen
wie sie da sind, bis sie was liefern wo ich sage, okay, dann geh ich jetzt wieder mit.
Ok, dann haben wir uns wohl getäuscht Ralf, wir saßen bei dir,
haben das MacBook Air 15 Zoll gesehen und uns gedacht, ah da wird Tim begeistert
sein, aber dem ist er wohl offensichtlich nicht.
Für andere Leute, für mich ist das nix, weil ich sowieso, der ist mir zu groß,
also ich will einen kompakten Computer haben und ich bin früher mit einem 11
Zoll rumgelaufen und war sehr glücklich, Da hätte ich auch kein Problem damit
gehabt, wenn das Format beibehalten worden wäre.
Der 13, das ist halt der kleinste, den es gibt. Der passt in meine Tasche rein.
15 Zoll ist mir schon too much. Also weil die paar Streifen Pixel da drum herum
extra, die bringen es für mich nicht.
Für mich ist kleiner Laptop, kompakt, möglichst leicht plus größtmöglicher Bildschirm,
Desktop, Rechner ist mittlerweile my way.
Und was ich dazu sagen muss, was wirklich geil wäre, wäre, wenn das damals total
underpowerte mit dem Atom, das 12er, das M1 Adorable, das wäre das Ideale eigentlich.
Das hätte ich gerne mit der M1 Ausstattung drin.
Das wäre so mein kleines Gerät und dann ein großes Desktopgerät,
was für mich im Moment trotzdem ein Laptop ist, weil ich ihn ab und zu mal mitnehmen
können will und es eh wurscht, das Gefühl, weil so viel sind die Mac Studios
auch nicht viel besser für meine Anwendungsfälle.
Aber so für dieses transportable Gerät zählt jedes Gramm und jeder Millimeter
links und rechts und oben dran.
Und das Display ist mir eh ab einer gewissen Größe zu klein,
damit es sich groß anfühlt. Und das 11 Zoll fand ich auch super.
Das würde ich auch wieder nehmen sogar, mit den geilen Innereien.
Also wo ich mitgehen würde, ist die Abkehr von der Wedge-Form,
dass das keine gute Idee ist, weil ich finde, das ist auch so ein Distinktionsmerkmal
des Air immer gewesen. Du hast sofort ein Air erkannt.
Jetzt hast du eigentlich keine echte Chance mehr, ein 13 Zoll Air von einem
13 Zoll MacBook Pro zu unterscheiden, es sei denn, du hältst sie direkt nebeneinander,
welches jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen dünner oder dicker ist.
Und das finde ich eigentlich schade, weil das so ein Designmerkmal einfach war.
Auch in der Benutzung. Also es fühlt sich ja auch gut an, diese Wedge,
so wenn man das Ding so durch die Gegend trägt, so ein bisschen an der schmalen
Seite, das ist einfach netter, als wenn es so ein gerades Ding ist.
Das gefühlte Gewicht ist weniger, selbst wenn es nicht so ist, das ist ganz komisch.
Also ich finde auch so, ich werde mein M1 MacBook auch, glaube ich,
bis zum Ende benutzen, bis Apple das nicht mehr supportet in irgendeiner Form,
weil das ist ein tolles Gerät, das ist schnell genug für alles,
was ich machen will mit diesen Geräten.
Ich habe mir die 2TB-Bike gegönnt damals, das wird einfach mal langen,
ich bin gespannt. Das wird wahrscheinlich das erste Gerät, das mich dann wirklich
beißen wird, im Sinne von, das ist ein unreparierbares All-in-One-Gerät.
Was mich gewundert hat, ist, dass sie wirklich einen neuen internen Aufbau gebaut haben für das 15er.
Da hätte man ja davon ausgehen können, sie nehmen einfach die Platine und die
Innereien vom 13er und packen in den zusätzlichen Platz einfach mehr Akku rein.
Aber die haben ja wirklich ein komplett neues Motherboard halt dafür kreiert.
Warum sie den Aufwand jetzt betrieben haben? Keine Ahnung.
Was ich noch interessant oder zu beachten finde und was für mich mittlerweile
ein Kauf-Ausschluss-Kriterium ist,
es hat halt wirklich den schlechteren Screen, den schlechteren Bildschirm,
der eben nicht diese MacBook Pro HDR-Funktion und Brillanz hat.
Müssen wir vielleicht irgendwann mal ein Sonderthema in der Freak Show zu machen, HDR.
Schönes Thema finde ich. Wenn man das einmal gesehen hat, einmal das Licht gesehen
hat, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, will man nie wieder zurück.
Ich konnte auch Retina sechs Jahre lang aussetzen, einfach weil diese anderen
Kriterien für mich viel, viel, viel wichtiger waren.
Naja, wenn man was mit Video oder Foto oder so macht und Farbtreue haben will,
dann ist es schon was. Ich meine jetzt für ein Terminal ist es vielleicht nicht ganz so wichtig.
Naja, aber auch da ist ein sattes Schwarz, dann halt mal ein Schwarz.
Du ich hab ein Pro, mir musst du das nicht sagen.
Also ich glaube für Apple ist es total überfällig gewesen so ein Format rauszubringen,
weil manche brauchen halt einfach einen größeren Bildschirm
oder wollen den einfach haben und das ist ja auch super und
ich ja ich wenn ich mir was wünschen könnte wäre das ein ein MacBook Air M2
im Wedge Design mit vier USB C Ports das wäre wirklich also der einzige Grund
für diese Pro Rechner ist vier USB C Ports weil es nervt.
Das sind nur drei.
Wieso?
Also ich hab drei.
Das sind nur drei.
Aber dazu dann noch ein...
Seit es die gute Tastatur gibt, gibt es nur noch drei USB-C Anschlüsse.
Dafür hast du dann ein MagSafe und ein HDMI-Anschluss.
Mehr als drei gibt es nicht.
Du kommst also realistisch trotzdem hin.
Okay, nur ein Port mehr.
Es sei denn, du willst jetzt vier RAID-Arrays anschließen.
Ja, einen SD-Card-Slot hast du sogar auch noch.
Genau, und den SD-Kart-Slot, wo ich immer meine SD-Karte drin habe.
Es gibt mittlerweile auch USB-C-Extender, also es gibt so irgendwie Dongles,
wo dann drei USB-C-Dinger dran sind.
Da werde ich mir glaube ich noch ein paar mehr von zulegen müssen,
weil sonst wird man diese ganze Kabellage nie los. Also ich meine diese ganzen
Standard-Adapter, mit denen man so rumläuft, wo dann so ganz viel USB-A dran
ist, Das war's für heute. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Hilft mir nicht, weil dann kann ich nicht noch mehr USB-C Kabel für alles mitnehmen,
ich brauche nur mehr USB-C Konnektivität und es muss ja nicht immer Thunderbolt
sein, es reicht ja wenn da mal nur USB drauf ist so, es geht ja um den Stecker
erstmal, dass man einfach wegkommt von A und.
Du hast eben ja ein MagSafe wo der Strom rein fließt, das heißt du hast dann noch drei USB-C frei.
Ja aber MagSafe weiß ich gar nicht, also will man das benutzen?
Ja natürlich, magnetisch, alles mit Magnetismus ist per se awesome.
Und man kann inzwischen die Kabel nachkaufen für lediglich 60 Euro waren es glaube ich.
Da ist auf der einen Seite MagSafe, auf der anderen Seite USB-C,
kannst du mit jedem Netzteil verwenden.
Aber da muss ich ja nochmal ein Custom Kabel mitbringen.
Das ist so die Geschichte, also die Absurdität, genau da brauchst du eigentlich
kein MagSafe, das ist irgendwie die geile Kombi bei mir zumindest.
Du hast weder Katzen noch kleine Kinder oder?
Zu Hause habe ich doch einen Dock für so einen Laptop, da kommt da eh Strom rein.
Ich habe keinen Dock, ich habe ein Kabel an einem Display.
Aber das ist mehr oder weniger das Dock.
Das ist ja dein Dock. Also du schließt ein Kabel an und fertig.
Also wie man es dreht und wendet, jeder Bauer braucht irgendwie wann anders
Regen. Aber so ist es halt nun mal.
Ich denke MacBook Air 15 Zoll können wir abschließen. Wir sind uns einig,
das ist ein korrektes Produkt, auch für einen korrekten Preis für Apple und können es machen.
Demnächst dann ohne Notch und dann kaufe ich sowas auch noch.
Ah Notch geht nicht mehr weg glaube ich.
Doch der Notch muss weggehen weil der Notch, das geht einfach,
sorry aber wirklich ich meine mitten in meinem Bildschirm da so ein Flansch rein.
Ja aber stört das dich denn bei deinem iPhone? Ich meine das Argument ist ja legitim.
Mein iPhone ist kein Macintosh.
Ach dem kann man kaum widersprechen aber macht das Argument ja nicht.
Stören ist ein großes Wort. Ich glaube, wenn es weg ist, würde ich es geil finden.
Würdest du dafür die Kamera hergeben?
Welche? Jetzt im iPhone?
Nein, im Mac. Wenn da jetzt keine Kamera wäre und dann auch kein Laptop.
Nee, da ist doch genug Platz. Macht da einfach ein paar Millimeter drüber die
Kamera. Also das geht doch. Sie wollen ja nur diesen Rand da irgendwie klein halten.
So viel Platz ist doch da nicht mehr.
Ja, dann mach halt mehr Platz. Mein Gott, das Gerät ist so groß.
Nehmt doch den Platz den ihr braucht, verdammte Scheiße, um die Geräte einzubauen
die ich brauche. Aber nicht alle auf einen Ort.
Tun sie ja.
Was kommt da jetzt nächstes? Ist noch ein Teil der Tastatur auf dem Bildschirm oder was?
Es ist doch jetzt wirklich, ich schieb jetzt mal gerade hier meinen Macbook
rüber, es ist doch jetzt wirklich an einem Ort, wo es jetzt nicht stört,
weil es keine Informationen verdeckt.
Es ist hässlich wie die Nacht, es sieht so furchtbar aus, es geht überhaupt
nicht, ich will es gar nicht sehen, das ist so schrecklich, es ist zum kotzen.
Nein, das ist nur deine Meinung.
Nein, gut, gehen wir weiter zum nächsten Hardwareprodukt, mit Sicherheit ohne Notch.
Ja, weil auch ohne Display.
Was ist denn das nächste Hardwareprodukt?
Das wäre ein Studiomax mit M2.
Und wir dürften uns alle freuen, dass das Studioformat geupdatet wurde,
weil dann bleibt es nämlich erhalten. Das finde ich ganz gut.
Und der Lüfter ist leise.
Genau, den Lüfter haben sie korrigiert, was super wichtig ist,
weil das fand ich peinlich, dass wirklich das Vorgängermodell zu viel Lüfter
hatte für ein Apple M-Produkt.
Das darf nicht sein, finde ich. Also ich finde gerade auch so noch ein Vorteil
von dem wedge-shaped MacBook, das ist lüfterlos, weil die Airs haben auch Lüfter, glaube ich.
Nee. Nee? Die MacBook Airs haben, ich glaube schon.
Immer noch keinen Lüfter, nein, ganz sicher nicht.
Also du meinst, das M2 Air mit wie viel? 15 Zoll, das meinst du, ne?
Das hat keinen Lüfter?
Nein, nein, ganz sicher, ja.
Weil ich muss nämlich zumindest feststellen, dass die MacBook Pro-Lüfter und
so, die fallen mir auf, wenn sie passieren in irgendeiner Form.
Also dieses Kein-Lüfter-Haben ist ein Feature, das unglaublich toll ist, finde ich.
Weil nur so können es wirklich gar kein Geräusch machen.
Also ich hab selten den Lüfter an, das letzte mal als der Lüfter tatsächlich
an war bei dem MacBook, aber da kommen wir gleich noch zu, das hat was mit der Vision Pro zu tun.
Die ersten zwei Jahre hätte ich auch geglaubt ich hab gar keinen Lüfter drin
in meinem M1 MacBook Pro und dann kam aber Machine Learning und dann war's vorbei.
Ja eigentlich immer, wenn das MacBook ordentlich Grafik machen soll,
dann springt der Lüfter an, weil der M1 grafikmäßig ein bisschen schwach aufgestellt
ist und sofort wegglüht.
Also ich hab jetzt einen M2 Pro bei mir drin und auch da wenn ich jetzt Stable
Diffusion mache, ist nach zwei Minuten der Lüfter an und auch hörbar an,
also dann zieht der auch ganz schön hoch, aber er hat halt auch einfach richtig
was zu tun auf seinen ganzen 12 Kinect Grafikkern.
Bei mir ist es immer noch FFmpeg. Da kannst du das Ding einfach auslasten ordentlich,
wenn du mit FFmpeg H.265 codierst. Was ich immer noch mache,
weil es die kleineren Files macht, als alles eingebaute mit irgendwelcher Hardwarebeschleunigung.
Und da hast du einfach volle Auslastung und dann bist du innerhalb von 0,0x
auf das, was denn hier lüftet.
So wir waren jetzt beim Studio, also hat Lüfter aber ist viel leiser und schneller.
Das ist schon mal gut und ist schneller. Wir haben jetzt zwei neue CPUs drin,
nämlich M2 Max und M2 Ultra und das ist letztendlich das was jetzt genauso der
Erwartungshorizont war.
Findet ihr, dass der gut aussieht, der Max Studio?
Ich finde, der sieht aus wie ein Mini, der halt höher gezogen ist.
Das ist nicht die Frage. Sieht das gut aus, wenn ein Mini höher gezogen ist oder nicht?
Was mich ein bisschen stört ist, dass der nicht so ein voller Würfel ist,
sondern er sieht so aus, als hätten sie irgendwie auf das BMW-Museum in München
noch einen Würfel drauf gestellt,
weil er diesen komischen Fuß da drunter hat, diesen runden Fuß unten drunter.
Das ist das, was mich stört.
Muss ja erstmal gucken wie das BMW Museum aussieht, achso mit diesen komischen Gedöns.
Es hat irgendwie so einen Block of Aluminium.
Ja aber dieser Block von Aluminium, wenn es wirklich nur der Block wäre,
wäre es ja okay, aber er hat diesen komischen merkwürdigen Fuß drunter.
Aber es geht ihm ja so ein bisschen was schwebendes.
Ja, aber nicht genug.
Ich finde ich also du hast ja nach dem design gefragt also dieser fuß stört
mich ansonsten finde ich das okay für mich wäre er eigentlich schöner wenn er
ein kompletter würfel wäre ich meine bei Steve wäre das noch ein richtiger würfel gewesen.
Also ich würde dir insofern recht geben als dass das auch hoch kann.
Ich hab hier jetzt mal diese Ansicht wo man wirklich genau von vorne drauf guckt,
das ist halt so eine Asymmetrie, es wirkt halt wie oben so ein bisschen abgeschnitten
beim Metzger so die Fleischwurst halt, als ob da vielleicht von oben irgend ein bisschen was fehlt.
So ein halber McPro.
Ja oder weiß ich nicht so eine Bärchenwurst mit zwei Mac Minis oder drei Mac
Minis übereinander, also es ist irgendwie, die Proportionen die passen nur so.
Aber es ist jetzt auch nichts was mich jetzt irgendwo stören würde auf dem Schreibtisch.
Wahrscheinlich auch nicht, wenn man das Geld hat sich so ein Ding auf den Schreibtisch
zu stellen dann ist es auch okay.
Ja, ja.
Aber oben abrunden wäre vielleicht echt eine Option gewesen.
Ja also ich finde ihn nicht hässlich, aber ich finde ihn auch nicht schön.
Also ich bin da wirklich so genau in der Mitte angelangt und denke mir die ganze Zeit so hmmm.
Und am Ende zählen natürlich die inneren Werte, die sind so nicht so schlecht
glaube ich, allerdings ist der Preis auch sportlich ne.
Der ist holler die Waldfee. Ja vor allem wenn man das so mit,
wo sie ja immer so richtig zuschlagen ist ja so SSD, also gerade da wo man sich
so denkt so einmal rechts unten bitte und was kostet irgendwie so ein rechts unten Mixstudio?
Gucken wir mal, weil großes Metathema hier in der Meta-Ebene,
mich kotzt mein Studio Setup an, ich hab das jetzt seit 14 Jahren und mittlerweile
komm ich selber nicht mehr klar damit, alles muss neu sein und ich denke schon
sehr sehr sehr lange darüber nach, was der Nachfolger meint ist, Aufgepasst!
Pro von 2009 sein könnte, den ich hier immer noch betreibe und der funktioniert
super und der jetzt in diesem Moment diese Sendung aufzeichnet.
Wohlgemerkt Intel auf das was du so fürchterlich viel geschimpft hast.
Ja ja klar das ist ein Verbrenner.
Vielleicht hättest du da die GoPro einstecken sollen.
Naja so also was will man haben wenn man m2 max haben was sollte ich mir kaufen,
kauf mir doch mal ein max studio für mich für mein studio weil es ja offensichtlich
steht ja studio drauf ich brauche ein rechner für das studio das scheint ja
das richtige ding zu sein.
Wie viele kerne hast du jetzt zwölf ne?
Achso wie viel ich jetzt habe ist ja egal.
Naja nicht ganz also wenn du sagst du hast jetzt zwölf Kerne aber nutzt sie
nicht aus dann brauchst du kein 24 Kerne. Ja.
MechPro. Also vielleicht reicht ja sogar ein Pro.
Ob ich sie jetzt nicht ausnutze ist ja nicht entscheidend die Frage ist ob ich
sie in Zukunft ausnutze und ich mach durchaus Dinge die parallelisiert werden können und.
Können ist das interessante Wort.
Ja auch werden, vielleicht nicht so effizient wie ich mir das vorstelle,
aber das ist ja durchaus noch was zu holen. Also konkret, Reaper macht ja diverse
Dinge verhältnismäßig parallel, aber nicht so parallel wie ich mir das so vorstelle.
Mal anders gefragt, findest du, dass dein jetziger Mac-Profil zu langsam ist?
Für ein paar Anwendungen ja also so rausrendern
und so wenn ich jetzt hier den Cut
gehe dann starte ich so eine
Silence Detection das dauert bei so einer Freakshow 4 Tracks 4 Stunden da sitze
ich dann erstmal so 10 Minuten und dann weißt du und dann bin ich an den Parametern
rumfummeln und dann breche ich das nochmal ab und dann mache ich das nochmal
und dann dauert das, dann gehe ich auf einen anderen Rechner.
Also dann ziehe ich dann doch auf mein Mac Mini um.
Und der Mac Mini macht das in was für einer Zeit?
Deutlich schneller.
Aber das ist jetzt ein M1 ne?
Also ich finde so ein echter Sweet Spot CPU technisch ist eigentlich der M2 Pro.
So der hat ja dann 10 Kerne statt 12 aber ist halt einfach nicht so teuer wie
der Max aber den gibt's für ein Studio halt nicht.
Den Studio gibt's nicht also da gibt's halt den Max und den Ultra.
Der Ultra ist halt die richtig fette Maschine wahrscheinlich wäre der Ultra
Overkill für dich jetzt.
So 24 Kerne.
Naja also wir können ja mal diesen Mac Mini hier auch mit rein nehmen,
der ist, wann ist der angekündigt worden? Vor ein paar Monaten,
den haben wir aber hier nie so richtig besprochen. Oder? Glaube nicht.
Und den finde ich ja auch sehr interessant, also Mac Mini bin ich sowieso ein
großer Freund davon und gerade wenn man das jetzt mal so preislich vergleicht,
da kriegt man dann die Dinge dann doch auch noch sehr viel billiger also das
ist bei Mac Studios dann der ganze extra Kram auch nochmal teurer.
10 Core CPU, naja 10 Core CPU, sogar 12 hier der Mini.
Nee der M2 oder der M2 Pro,
der M2 hat 10 Core und der M2 Pro hat, nee andersrum M2 hat 8 Core und,
stimmt 8, 4 und 4 und der M2 Pro hat 10 also 8 und 2 oder so.
Aber nicht beim Mac Mini erstaunlicherweise, ich bin jetzt hier gerade auf der
Apple Mac Mini Seite und da steht der M2 Pro mit 12 Core CPU,
live klicken mit der deutschen, es gibt dann noch ein Update,
es gibt den M2 Pro auch noch in einer 12 Core Variante, da legst du dann nochmal 345 Euro extra drauf.
Genau, also man kann die schon irgendwie ähnlich konfigurieren.
Ich kann ja mal folgendes Experiment machen.
Ich nehme mal den größten Mac Mini den es gibt mit 12-Core,
also den Pro, den M2 Pro, genau, mit 32 GB RAM und sagen wir mal 2 TB SSD,
das ist so das was ich haben will, 10 Gigabit Ethernet, kostet mich 3.160,
Euro laut Apple. Dann gehe ich mal auf ein Mac Studio mit dem M2 Max,
der auch nur eine 12-Core CPU hat aber halt noch sehr viel mehr GPU,
hier steht auch noch 16-Core Neural Engine, was ist eigentlich bei dem M2 Pro,
der hat doch auch eine Neural Engine, ja genau.
Ja das dürfte dann der gleiche Prozessor sein.
Das ist so ähnlich genau.
Da solltest du in der Tat mit einem halben Auge auch mal hinschielen,
so Stichwort Whisper lokal.
Ja natürlich ist das interessant.
Aber das ist interessant, wenn man die vergleichbare Konfiguration hat,
dann ist der Studio tatsächlich einen Tick günstiger als der Mini.
Richtig, ich komme jetzt hier tatsächlich 100 Euro besser weg in dem Vergleich.
Das ist weird, aber ja warum nicht?
Also doch ein Studio.
Ja könnte durchaus auch auf ein Studio hinauslaufen.
Und dann hast du auch ein M2 Max und kein M2 Pro.
Also du wählst glaube ich auf alle Fälle ein Studium wegen der Kühlleistung,
weil die ist definitiv beim Studio besser als beim anderen. Wenn du wirklich
das Ding unter Last fährst öfter mal und lüftertechnisch dann bist du da bestimmt besser mit besetzt.
Das wäre meine.
Das Problem ist jetzt, wenn ich den natürlich so konfiguriere wie den mic mini
ich maximal konfigurieren kann, dann konfiguriere ich ja ein System,
wo überhaupt nichts auf maximal ist und dann sitze ich so vor dieser Bestellung
und denke mir so, das ist aber jetzt nicht das Rechtsundmodell.
Und dann denkt man sich so, ach ja, hier, da könnte man ja nochmal ein bisschen,
ach, den gibt's auch mit 24 Chor, so ultra.
Ich mich ein bisschen frage, warum du nicht als SSD bei so einem Standgerät
da hinten einfach die externe, so eine Samsung T5 oder sowas dran haust,
weil das ist viel günstiger und ist auch schnell genug für das, was du machst.
Was ist eine Samsung T5?
Naja, eine NVMe SSD mit, weiß ich nicht, Thunderbolt.
Genau, die sind so Scheckkarten groß nur noch, da musst du halt nur einen Thunderbolt-Port
hergeben, mehr oder weniger, aber ich hab das damals eigentlich auch bei dem
Mac Pro so gemacht, weil das Interne ist, also wenn du das Gerät eh da liegen
hast, dann ist es auch wurscht.
Und diese Dinger sind super stabil gelaufen bei mir, also die haben überhaupt
keinen Ärger gemacht. Die werden ein bisschen heiß, da musst du ein bisschen
aufpassen, aber so, die sind halt echt… In der PC-Welt gibt es inzwischen Lüfter
für SSDs. Die sind ja gigantisch viel günstiger.
Da kannst du ja 2TB für einen Furz kaufen.
2TB, wenn sie einigermaßen schnell sein sollen, kosten jetzt so um die 200 Euro.
Samsung T5 oder so gibt es, glaube ich, heißt das Ding.
Ich sehe T7, aber das ist mit USB. T7 gibt es auch, ja.
Ja, das ist wurscht. Wie ist es wurscht?
Das ist schnell genug.
Wie schnell genug? Also das ist ja nicht so, dass dir dann der Dampf ausgeht
für das, was du da so normal machen musst.
Naja, so eine ganz schnelle, die gehen ja über PCI-Express,
die schnellen SSDs, und dann willst du sie schon per Thunderbolt anschließen,
aber dann würde ich eher gucken, Dann würde ich eher gucken,
ob du ein entsprechendes Gehäuse findest und dir dann entsprechend die dazugehörige
Karte kaufen oder die SSD kaufen, die du dann haben willst, weil der SSD Markt ist extrem volatil.
Das was heute eine gute ist, ist in vier Wochen halt nicht mehr eine gute.
Gibt es ein externes NVMe SSD Gehäuse mit Thunderbolt, wo man mehrere Dinger
rein machen kann, weil das wäre dann sozusagen the way.
Also ich weiß, dass es sowas als Steckkarte gibt, aber...
Mit irgendwie 24 Slots oder so, aber jetzt als, bestimmt, musste man mal ein bisschen suchen.
Hätte ich auch gesagt, bestimmt.
Also das daran soll es eigentlich nicht scheitern, weil ich mein Thunderbolt
ist auch nur PCI Express über ein anderes Kabel.
Also deswegen da würde ich jetzt, da würde ich keine Komplettlösung nehmen.
Du musst trotzdem wieder viel Recherche machen und das Richtige machen und so weiter.
Wenn du die maximale Geschwindigkeit haben willst, dann bekauf dir den internen
Scheiß von Apple, weil dann befährst du besser mit.
Wenn du aber damit leben kannst, dass du nicht die maximale Geschwindigkeit
hast, dann hast du halt wirklich mit diesen externen USB-C-Dingern halt echt
einfach ein unglaublich großes Budget für viel Platz und die Dinger nimmst du halt einfach auch.
Also ich habe da einfach vier von, fertig. Und wenn ich irgendwo Daten hin und
her transportieren muss oder mal was brauche, dann sind die halt da dabei und fertig.
Und die sind nicht die interne eingebaute Geschichte, das heißt,
es hängt nicht an dem Rechner, dass der mal kaputt geht oder nicht und man zahlt
halt die Apple-Steuer nicht. Dann kannst du nämlich wirklich interne Größe relativ klein nehmen.
Da muss ja nur das Betriebssystem drinnen sein.
Mehr oder weniger.
Also es gibt für verhältnismäßig wenig Geld so 150,
ne stimmt gar nicht, doch das Gehäuse ab 150 Euro gibt es ein Thunderbolt von
OWC Envoy Express wo zwei Slots reingehen und wenn man sich da irgendwie 2x8TB
reinballert dann ist irgendwie alles super und das kann man halt zur Not auch
mitnehmen und in den Laptop stecken und so weiter das ist natürlich auch ganz geil.
Wobei ich gerade so ein bisschen gebranntes Kind bin,
weil mir meine Synology abgeraucht ist nach dem Softwareupdate und sich auch
mit dem Hardreset und Factoryreset bisher nicht wieder in die lebendige Zone holen lässt.
Das Ding was hier blinkt?
Jaja, das Ding was hier blinkt, das sagt gerade ich bin K.O.
Und die Daten sind alle weg?
Das hoffe ich nicht.
Ist doch als Raid alles angelegt drin.
Ja schon, aber das schöne an Hardware Rates ist ja, wenn was mit der Hardware
passiert, dann bist du halt auch gerne trotzdem die Platten, die die Daten sind.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was kaputt ist, weil ich kann ja nicht darauf zugreifen und das geile ist,
ich hab versucht das Ding, also Hard Reset ist mir dann auch gelungen,
dann kommt irgendwie diese komische Software, dieser Synology Assistant mit
dem schlechten User Interface hoch und sagt so, ja hier würde ich gerne neu einrichten und so.
Ja, okay, dann muss ich selber mir das richtige Disk-Image mit dem Betriebssystem
aussuchen, was ich da gerne installieren möchte, das sie das für mich tun könnten oder sowas.
Und dann mache ich das und dann fängt er so an und dann ist er so bei 56 Prozent.
Und dann meinte er so, ja ich kann dieses Ding nicht lesen, da ist ein Fehler
irgendwie passiert, Klammern 22. Also so eine richtige Apple Fehlermeldung.
Und natürlich keine Hilfe, ja könnte das Motherboard sein.
Sagt mir die Datei ist irgendwie nicht lesbar, aber es könnte das Motherboard sein.
Also Synology muss ich sagen ist ja hier hochgelobt worden und ich hab mir richtig
mich da rein investiert und muss sagen bisher ist meine Erfahrung eher schlecht.
Aber jetzt mal ganz ehrlich, seit 15 Jahren reden wir über ZFS und du kaufst
eine Synology. Das geht halt einfach auch nicht.
Naja es gibt halt auch keine Lösung mit ZFS.
Egal. Auf jeden Fall, wir waren ja gerade bei MacStudio und bei Expansion und
ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass ich mir so ein MacStudio kaufe.
Ich bezweifle nur, dass ich den dann in der maximalen Konfiguration kaufe,
wie ich ein MacMini kaufen könnte.
Sondern Leute da gehen 192 Gigabyte RAM rein.
Aber nur wenn du den Ultra nimmst, den Ultra Chip.
Genau, der geht nur beim Ultra.
Weil das sind ja zwei Chips die sie aneinander klatschen und dann haben sie
zwei RAM Interfaces und nur da kriegst du dann den ganzen Verhältnis.
Ich will keine 192 Gigabyte RAM, um das gleich mal klarzustellen.
Die eigentliche Frage ist, wie viel will man denn?
Also ich habe jetzt in meinem Rechner 32 drin, das reicht bis jetzt ganz ordentlich.
Die Firma hat mir einen Rechner mit 64 Gigabyte hingestellt,
was ich ein bisschen übertrieben finde und wahrscheinlich bis zum Lebensende
oder dem projektierten Ende des Rechners auch wahrscheinlich nicht ausnutze.
Aber your mileage may vary.
Also die 16 merkt man auf alle Fälle. So die 16 sind ein bisschen zu wenig.
32 finde ich ist für meine Anwendungsfälle immer ganz gut gewesen.
Da ist auch immer noch gut Luft für auch mal Experimente zu machen mit irgendwelchen
komischen virtuellen Machines und so weiter. Da ist aber ein bisschen Platz
und dann ist gut. Ich meine die SSD ist eh so schnell, dass im Zweifel,
wenn was passiert, kann man gut ausgleichen.
Ich denke mehr als 32 solltest du wirklich nur nehmen, wenn du weißt,
du brauchst es, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Oder du willst ein ultra haben weil dann hast du automatisch 64 gigabyte darauf
läuft es nämlich hinaus so und dann bin ich bei 5.260 euro brutto.
5.260 euro also da kannst du schon alles ausgeben aber brauchst du das.
Da hast du jetzt wie viel wie viel SSD rein konfiguriert. Brauch?
Also ich habe, dann ist die Diskussion sowieso vorbei.
Also ich meine mit diesem Brauchen, das ist immer so die Frage,
also Brauchen würde ja sagen ich wüsste ja jetzt schon welche Anwendung ich dann damit fahren will.
Also als ich mein M2 mir jetzt geholt habe, habe ich mir relativ genau vorher
angeguckt wie war meine Nutzung als ich noch den Classic M1 hatte,
den allerersten und da hatte ich schon 16 Speicher.
Und ich hab hier ja hier iStats Pro und da kriegst du ja wirklich so eine History
über ein paar Tage, Wochen, Monate, wenn du ständig drauf guckst und ich hab's
nie geschafft den über 50 Prozent Speicherauslastung zu kriegen.
Und ich hab sicherlich 20 Programme gleichzeitig plus noch Machine Learning
Geschichten, die parallel laufen. Also von daher mehr als 32 ist echt nicht
realistisch. Also nimm 32, wenn du Seelenheil haben willst, aber alles mehr ist Quatsch.
Nimm 64 meinst du.
Ja 64 wenn du dich gut fühlen willst aber wirklich alles da drüber ist dann wirklich.
Also ich würde schon sagen 32 ist schon zum gut fühlen also.
Jaja also unter 32 würde ich jetzt nicht gehen.
Nee.
Auf keinen Fall.
Nein.
Und 64 kriege ich sowieso wenn ich sage ich brauche jetzt Doppelchor Glück.
Also Ultra.
Ultra.
Aber was willst du denn mit 24 Kernen?
Ich will das meine ganze Audio scheiße schneller.
Ja ja aber du kannst doch pro Reaper Spur auch nur einen Kern spielen du hast
doch nicht 24 Leute hier.
Ich krieg dieses Programm mühelos ins Ruckeln ich möchte nicht.
Ja aber das wird sich mit 24 Kernen nicht ändern weißte das ist ja das Problem.
Ja weil scheiße programmiert ist.
Ja das hatten wir schon ein paar mal.
Also Mac Studio ist auf jeden Fall ein interessantes Angebot,
ich finde den Mac Mini finde ich auch sehr interessant und dann gibt es noch
diesen Mac Pro, darüber müssen wir jetzt mal reden.
Der hat so große Löcher habe ich gehört, da haben Leute Angst vor.
Ich finde das Ding ist mittlerweile, also jetzt haben sie ihn wirklich kaputt
gespielt, also jetzt ist es wirklich überhaupt nicht... Ich meine,
ich habe jetzt jahrelang gewartet, um zu wissen, was ihre Vision für diesen
Mac Pro ist und dann kommen sie mit so einem Ei? Also wirklich.
Also es ist erstmal kein Ei sondern derselbe Formfaktor wie vorher.
Keine Tonne, kein Ei.
Prinzipiell ist es erstmal keine schlechte Maschine würde ich sagen.
Die Frage wozu das ganze müssen sie aber doch irgendwie nochmal verargumentiert bekommen.
Also ich meine es ist ja jetzt nicht so als wie viel kann man wie viel PCI Karten
kann man da reinstecken fünf oder sechs oder so fünf sind.
Ich glaube, das ist dann auch schon der gesamte Markt für PCI-Karten,
die mit dem Mac funktionieren und einen Armtreiber haben.
Also das ist halt das eigentliche Problem an der Kiste.
Also wenn ich da jetzt sagen würde, ja ich könnte da jetzt vier AMD,
nicht AMD, vier professionelle Nvidia-Karten für, weiß ich nicht,
Machine Learning reintun.
Und das würde out of the box funktionieren und und alles ist schick,
okay, aber ich glaube,
ich glaube, wenn ich mir angucke, was was was Nvidia, aber auch AMD Grafikkarten,
die größeren allein an Strom ziehen, da sehe ich ja noch nicht mal die Kabel
dafür, um da den Strom in diese Karten zu kriegen.
Also das ist so das Ding wo ich mich frage okay wozu?
Also die Distinktionsmerkmale gegenüber dem Studio sind halt schon schwierig
herzuleiten also genau du hast die PCI-Karten darfst aber keine Grafikkarten reinstecken.
Also darfst du schon aber sie funktionieren nicht. Das passiert an der Stau
nicht wenig, was auch immer dann passieren mag.
Also ich meine selbst diese komische professionelle AMD-Karte,
die es noch für den alten Mac Pro gab, letzte Generation AMD-Karte,
die funktioniert da drin ja auch nicht, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Du hast halt 76 GPU-Cores drin, das ist natürlich nicht wenig und das macht
schon einiges, aber es ist halt irgendwie nur die Hälfte von dem, was Windows hält.
Die krieg ich doch auch in dem
Mac Studio oder nicht? Oder zünden sie da jetzt noch eine Stufe ab Werk?
Absolut identisch.
Wie der Ultra im Studio. Du kannst halt den Speicher nicht aufrüsten,
du kannst die Grafikkarte nicht aufrüsten. Und damit sind die beiden irgendwie
Hauptversprechen von einem Desktop Modular.
Und einen M2 Slot hast du auch nicht oder hast du? Keine Ahnung.
Wo du noch SSDs reinstecken kannst.
Ich glaube SSDs kriegst du irgendwie dran. Aber natürlich die sind ja nicht
so schnell wie halt die interne.
Du hast diese 3,5 Zoll Disk Slots da, da kannst du halt SSDs reinstecken.
Nein ich rede ja von NVMe, also diese kleinen Dinger, für das du gerade das
Gehäuse rausgeholt hast.
Ne wahrscheinlich nicht, dafür machst du dann PCI Karten.
Ja, okay.
Gut.
Wenn es da eine gibt, für die es drei gibt, meinetwegen.
Aber also ganz ehrlich, mir erschließt sich die Zielgruppe nicht,
die scheint mir doch sehr sehr klein zu sein.
Also es hätte halt funktioniert, wenn sie halt diesen Quad M2 rausgebracht hätten,
also eben nochmal eine Doppelung von dem Ultra, dass du eben alles mal zwei
nochmal oben drauf hast,
dann wärst du irgendwo bei 48 Kern gewesen und bei irgendwie 140 GPUs,
damit hätte man dann schon wieder irgendwie ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal gehabt
und da hättest du auch argumentieren können so, da brauchen wir jetzt Gehäuse
und da brauchen wir nochmal ordentlich Lüfter und das kriegen wir in den Studio so nicht rein.
Oder andersrum, du hast das Ding und kriegst ihn in allen Konfigurationen,
in denen du auch den Studio bekommst, nur du hast halt zusätzlich die PCI-Slots
und das für nicht allzu viel mehr Geld.
Oder so.
Also das würde ich ja auch noch verstehen, weil es gibt garantiert Leute,
die haben ihre Karten, die sie brauchen, aus Gründen. Die Frage ist, Armtreiber?
Also das ist halt so, ja ich glaube wir sind uns einig, das Ding ist erstmal nur eine Luftnummer.
Ja ich hab, PMA schreibt gerade im Chat, in dem Pro bekommt man 76 GPUs,
das war das was ich mitgeschrieben hatte und in den Studio nur 60,
also das sind schon nochmal 16 Unterschied, aber gut, die machen halt den Braten
nicht fett, also das ist ein anderer Chip dann der drin sitzt.
Ja, aber auch das ist glaube ich, naja gut,
also diese GPUs haben halt sehr viel, also was der eigentliche Vorteil an dem
Gerät ist natürlich, dass du dieses Shared Memory zwischen GPU und CPU hast
und wenn du dann so ein Mac Pro mit weiß ich nicht wie viel,
Hunderten an Gigabyte Speicher hast, dass du dann, wenn du das professionell
benutzt als Grafiker, dann entsprechend halt auch viel Speicher verbrauchen kannst.
Das ist ja das Problem an kommerziellen Grafikkarten, dass sie eigentlich für
professionelle Anwendungen zu wenig Speicher haben.
Deswegen verkauften die Grafikkartenhersteller ja die, die mit dem viel Speicher
noch mal zu richtigen Profi Preisen.
So und ich muss gleich mal korrigieren der Chat schreibt das auch nicht bin
gerade auf der original Apple Seite auch in den Studio M2 Ultra mit 24 Kernen
und 76 Core GPU rein und auch bis zu 192 GB Arbeitssprecher.
Es ist einfach der exakt selbe Chip und das Ding ist halt half-assed und ich
wage mal die These aufzustellen, dass das so gekommen ist.
Sie wollten ursprünglich diesen Plan, der ja schon lange geleakt ist,
eines Quad quasi, also wie auch immer der dann gießen hätte, einen Supra.
Trans-Ultra. Und haben denen dann aus verschiedenen Erwägungen,
die sicherlich was mit Kosten und vielleicht aber auch mit Produktionsproblemen
zu tun haben, haben sie dieses Ding nicht gebaut bekommen zu diesem Jahr.
Vielleicht kommt es ja noch.
Und würde man nämlich alles hochrechnen, was diese Kiste kann,
dann wäre er zumindest in einem Bereich,
wo man sagen würde, okay, da ist er so halbwegs konkurrenzfähig mit dem,
was du so derzeit an PC-Grafikkarten dir zusammenkaufen kannst in so sinnvollen Konfigurationen.
Und mit 384 GB RAM bist du zwar noch lange nicht bei den 1,5 TB,
aber da hast du schon wieder nochmal eine Schwelle genommen,
weil es gibt natürlich Anwender.
Insbesondere so im audio Bereich das unterschätzt man immer was die für RAM Bedarf haben.
Die Sample Libraries die sie einfach komplett halt.
Die laden einfach alle die ganzen Scheiß die ganzen Plugins die ganzen Samples laden die in RAM rein,
da ist also keine Seltenheit dass die also wirklich alle Slots gefüllt haben
mit irgendwelchen Spezialkarten Und dann 500 Gigabyte RAM einfach hochbooten
und das ist dann sozusagen ihre Maschine, da gibt's nicht viele von.
Klar wenn du in deinem Song 200 Spuren hast das summiert sich.
Genau und so wird da gearbeitet because they can und dann werfen die halt nochmal
3000 Euro auf den RAM da kichern die drüber das haben die in 2 Stunden Studioarbeit
haben sie die Kohle wieder drin.
Also für die Leute ist halt so der Mac Pro auch nicht teuer,
weil die investieren noch mal das Dreifache an Karten und an Plugins und so weiter.
Also für die ist sozusagen die Studio Rechner Basisausstattung ohnehin ein extrem
fünfstelliger Bereich, der vielleicht schon in den sechsstelligen Bereich reingeht.
Da ist der Computer selber eher Pipifax, deswegen kann sich Apple an der Stelle
auch diese Preise erlauben, die sie dann wahrscheinlich aber auch nehmen müssen
für ein Gerät, was halt in so geringen Stückzahlen verkauft wird.
Können sie natürlich auch sagen, sie lassen diesen Markt ziehen,
aber da waren wir schon mal.
Also das kann sich Apple nicht erlauben, bei den Top-Kreativen nicht dabei zu
sein, insbesondere nicht im Musikbusiness, wo sie so fett investiert sind und
deswegen gibt es halt diesen Mac Pro trotzdem, aber dieses Gerät ist ein Kompromisskandidat.
Und dass sie sich entschieden haben, Grafikkarten jetzt auch komplett außen
vor zu lassen, ist eine rein politische Entscheidung, weil das hätten sie natürlich
auch auf dem ARM SoC machen können.
Ich glaube, das Problem daran ist, dass die letzte Generation ARM-Karten oder
letzte Generation ARM-Silicon, das sie hatten als Grafikkarte,
im letzten Mac Pro halt auch nicht mehr gut aussieht heutzutage.
Und die aktuelle Generation AMD Grafikkarten,
die haben ein Hardware-Problem und sind nicht so schnell, wie sie ursprünglich
mal geplant waren, weswegen wahrscheinlich Apple sagt, das ist uns auch nicht schnell genug.
Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie auf die nächste Generation AMD setzen.
Weil ich denke, dass sie, sie wollen auf ihr Single Universal System,
wollen sie hin und der Gedanke jetzt schon auf einer ARM Plattform dann doch noch mal zu sagen,
wir können aber trotzdem noch mit diskreten GPUs arbeiten, was sie rein softwaretechnisch
könnten, aber das ist eine rein politische Entscheidung, dass sie das nicht machen.
Und ihr Kernmarkt für dieses Teil ist der Audiomarkt.
Ja ja das ist richtig nur.
Also promoten tun sie Video.
Ja aber Video ist auch nicht so GPU intensiv sondern geht es mehr um Encoding,
Decoding da gibt es halt die Karten.
GPU intensiv ist halt 3D und da sind sie halt nicht.
Ja, nee, aber ich glaub das ist auch ein Problem der Hardware.
Sie wollen nicht mit Nvidia gehen, weil sie irgendwie Probleme mit Nvidia haben.
Das haben sie ja seit Jahrzehnten fast schon.
Wahrscheinlich aus gutem Grund, weil Nvidia wahrscheinlich nochmal so richtig
Geld haben will, wenn Apple anklopft.
Und mit AMD, die derzeitige Generation AMD-Karten ist einfach nicht so gut wie
AMD, glaube ich, die geplant hatte. Die sind nicht verkehrt und die können halbwegs
gegen Nvidia anstinken, aber eben nicht hundertprozentig.
Und ich glaube, das sitzen sie aus. Oder aber, sie haben halt dieses Ding,
also die Gerüchteküche ist halt,
dass AMD das halt gerade so mit den Treibern hingekriegt hat,
dieses Silicon soweit unter Kontrolle zu behalten, dass du es benutzen kannst
und es ein ordentliches Bild gibt und es kann dann einfach sein,
dass die Treiberportieren halt einfach noch ein halbes Jahr dauert,
bis die ordentlich laufen und dann sehen wir vielleicht die Karte 7000er Serie.
Ich weiß es nicht, wir werden sehen.
Aber meine Vermutung ist, dass wenn sie nochmal eine externe GPU anbieten,
oder eine zusätzliche GPU anbieten, dass sie dann wahrscheinlich auf die nächste
Generation AMD setzen, 8000er Serie, wie auch immer sie dann heißen wird.
Also mich würde das überraschen, wenn sie das machen.
Heißt nicht es ist unmöglich, aber ich glaube der Chip has sailed.
Also die haben jetzt einfach gesagt wir ziehen das jetzt durch hier mit Universal System und fertig.
Naja klar weil sie da am meisten dran verdienen, das ist ja logisch.
Nee weil sie halt auch software technisch sozusagen weg wollen von diesen Treibern.
Ja aber dann brauchen sie auch kein Mac Pro mit Slots anzubieten,
wenn es keine Karten gibt, die man da reinstecken kann.
Das ist halt auch so ein bisschen das Ding.
Das ist ja aber das Ergebnis bei dem wir gerade sind.
Es gibt eine Menge Karten, die keine Grafikkarten sind, dafür ist dieser Rechner gedacht.
Es hat was mit Beschleunigerkarten, mit irgendwie, Videoencoding,
Audioencoding, da laufen dann halt so spezialisierte Chips drauf.
Videoencoding haben sie ja gesagt, ihr neuer Prozessor, der ist halt so schnell
wie sieben von diesen alten Beschleunigerkarten, die sie nicht mehr anbieten.
Andere Formate, die halt in diesen SOCs jetzt nicht drin sind,
das ist ja alles irgendwie MPEG-4 hat 264,
hat 265, ihr RAW-Kram, gibt auch noch andere Sachen und dann gibt es halt so MADI-Karten,
also es gibt so High-Performance-Audio-Karten, wo du dann,
was weiß ich, 256 oder 1024 RAW-Audio-Channels dran hast, die alle irgendwie,
weißt du, Bus-Kapazität brauchen, Stecker brauchen, also es gibt diesen Bedarf.
Das ist kein Riesenbedarf, das ist ein Nischenmarkt, aber es ist ein Nischenmarkt,
den Apple nicht aufgeben kann. Deswegen haben sie sich für so ein Half-Ass-Ding
jetzt entschieden, weil sie nicht noch länger, als sie es ohnehin schon gemacht
haben, diese Transition verschleppen wollen.
Ja und die Leute hinhalten, das stimmt natürlich.
Ich glaube dieses Teil was sie jetzt vorgestellt haben das wird etwas kläglich
in die Geschichte eingehen als so ein AIA Ding und ich glaube keiner ist stolz
bei Apple auf dieses Gerät.
Sondern es ist so können wir jetzt bitte über das Headset reden. So ein Gerät ist das.
Gutes Stichwort.
Naja, vielleicht sollten wir erstmal im Softwarebereich nochmal kurz abklappern,
das braucht vielleicht nicht so viel Aufmerksamkeit.
Vielleicht ein paar Sachen, die uns
bei den ganzen Betriebssystem-Releases aufgefallen sind, die worth noting.
Also viel war da nicht, also es scheint jetzt Widgets überall zu geben,
das ja okay, wer es braucht.
Was ich ganz spannend finde sind die Audio Message Transcriptions in Messages
und ich hoffe, dass sie das auch als API anbieten für andere Messaging Systeme.
Ich hab's mir nicht näher angeguckt, weiß ich nicht, Dom, weißt du da näheres,
ob's da eine API für gibt?
Ich hab da jetzt auch nicht so reingeguckt, ich bin aber nach wie vor leider,
also für Klangsynthese gibt's ja leider auch nicht die geile API.
Das wollte ich mal so rum machen, die gibt's ja heutzutage schon nicht,
dass man die geilen Siri Stimmen praktisch generieren lassen kann mit der API,
insofern ist die umgekehrte Geschichte bestimmt auch hinter irgendwelchen komischen Limits.
Vielleicht mal kurz erklärt was Rob macht, weil der Begriff selber ist da jetzt
noch nicht. Jemand schickt eine Audio Message und irgendeine… Unhöfliche Menschen,
sagen wir wie es ist, schicken Audio Messages.
Wir alle kennen diese Menschen, wir alle kennen diese Menschen,
die in einem Chatverlauf plötzlich, ja ich hab jetzt keine Zeit zu tippen,
ich schick mal kurz eine Audio Message und dann hast du fünf Minuten Audio Message da drin.
Und logisch wäre natürlich, wenn man ein Audio-to-Text, wie auch immer das dann
heißt, Transkription macht und er dir im Chatverlauf einfach mal als Text anzeigt,
was hat denn die Person da gerade erzählt.
Genau.
Naja, die Systeme sind bestimmt gut genug, als dass ich da, wenn der es nicht
versteht, verstehe ich es dann wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr in der, egal.
Man hat in etwa eine Ahnung.
Solange es so gut ist, halbwegs so gut ist wie die YouTube Autotranscription,
dann wäre das für mich immerhin hilfreich.
Das ist nicht der Benchmark.
Das ist nicht der Benchmark, natürlich ist es nicht der Benchmark,
aber das würde mir schon weiterhelfen, weil ich könnte mir dann trotzdem immer
noch erschließen, worum es geht.
Es gibt halt viele, also mir geht es so, dass es viele Situationen gibt,
wo ich dann halt einfach auch keine Audio Message hören möchte oder kann,
sondern einfach halt auch kurz drüber lesen, worum geht es eigentlich und muss
ich mich da näher mit beschäftigen und dafür finde ich das sehr sehr gut.
Also viel interessanter fand ich ja die Integration, die sie für den amerikanischen
Markt angekündigt haben, dass sie ja auch den Anrufbeantworter,
also die Voicemailbox, quasi auf dem Telefon transkribieren lassen.
Und das ist natürlich in einer Hinsicht sehr interessant, weil das ja bedeutet,
dass ein Anruf, der eigentlich auf eine Mailbox geht, was ja sagen wir mal eine
Funktion ist, die wir primär eigentlich als Leistung des Netzwerks kennen,
dann auf dem Telefon bearbeitet wird.
Das heißt, der Anruf wird tatsächlich angenommen, ohne aber wahrscheinlich abrechnungstechnisch...
Keine Ahnung, also das ist abbrechnungstechnisch auf jeden Fall eine Frage,
das werden sie geklärt haben.
Auf jeden Fall das Telefon zeichnet dann diese Nachricht auf.
Und ich hab mich immer schon gefragt, diese Voicemail-Integration,
die sie ja eigentlich von Anfang an hatten beim iPhone, das war ja so eins der
ersten Features, so wir machen Voicemailbox ordentlich.
Also nicht du hast so anrufen, drücken sie eins, drücken sie fünf und so.
Leider nicht bei allen Providern, aber das ist nochmal ein ganz anderes Thema.
Sie haben sich bemüht das so zu ziehen und mein Verständnis damals war,
Sie machen das eben bei Providern, die Provider wurden dann von Apple gezwungen,
Apple eine API dafür bereitzustellen.
Ja. Das ist mein Verständnis, vielleicht liege ich da falsch,
aber ich glaube so ist es gelaufen.
Und jetzt, entweder sind wir da schon eine Weile oder das ist jetzt quasi das
neue Zeitalter, dass das Telefon vollständig selbst den Call handelt,
selbst wenn du nicht rangehst.
Das heißt, dich ruft jemand an, du hast eigentlich auf Voice Mailbox gestellt,
das Telefon geht einfach ran, sagt dir nicht Bescheid, spielt irgendwas ab und
während dann diese Person in dein Telefon hinein quatscht, wird es transkribiert
und läuft dann eben auf dem Bildschirm mit.
Das heißt, du kriegst schon angezeigt, dass da ein Anruf ist,
aber dass der eben erstmal quasi so ein Text-Gateway bekommt und das ist natürlich ganz cool.
Ja, für mich jetzt keine Anwendung, weil es gibt nur eine Person,
die bei mir auf die Mailbox spricht, das ist meine Mutter und die hat immer noch nicht verstanden,
dass sie mich nur erreicht, wenn sie mich aufs Handy anruft und dass ich auch
die Mailbox von meinem Festnetz, hier sind Airquotes, Anschluss auch selten abhöre.
Also die Technik das ganze on device in Echtzeit zu machen ist einfach da,
wir testen im Ultraschalluniversum gerade halt viel mit Whisper rum um halt
eine lokale Transkription von Audio Podcasts zu machen,
dass man es also nicht zu irgendeinem Internetdienst hinschickt sondern wirklich
konkret auf dem Gerät und selbst ein kleineres Whisper Modell ist von OpenAI
auch das ganze rausgebracht und es gibt halt einen Port für die M1,
M2 Architektur und selbst ein kleines Sprachmodell läuft in zweifach,
dreifach Realtime durch mit einer sehr guten Erkennungsqualität für Deutsch.
Also der Drops ist gelutscht und das läuft dann komplett auf der Neural Engine
und braucht praktisch keinen Strom.
Das heißt, du kannst dann auch aussuchen, du sollst auf den GPUs das Ganze rendern,
Dann siehst du also auch wie der Stromverbrauch hochgeht oder schickst das ganze
in die Neural Engine rein von den M-Chips und da verbraucht es dann praktisch
gar keinen Strom und ist genauso schnell. Das ist also schon beeindruckend.
Also für mich ist das auf jeden Fall ein Feature, wo ich sage, gesagt habe, ja.
Nehme ich mit, will ich haben. Danke.
Weil es sogar so reinpasst, in Anrufbeantworter in FaceTime können dir Leute
jetzt auch Videonachrichten schicken auf deinen Anrufbeantworter in Anführungszeichen.
Das heißt FaceTime gibt es jetzt auch asynchron, das heißt du hast die Menschen,
die gerne diese asynchrone Zeichenhebersaufnummer machen mit Audio und live
angucken müssen, die sind mit FaceTime noch viel heißer drauf demnächst. Bin ich mal gespannt.
Transkribiert er dann auch das Videobild im Hintergrund sehen sie.
Das wäre interessant ob er den Inhalt auch transkribiert an der Stelle wahrscheinlich
nicht oder weil das so eine komplette Videosache sein und FaceTime funktioniert
doch eh immer so schlecht wie eh und je.
Simon im Chat bringt gerade den richtigen Hinweis uns noch, dass es natürlich
auch sein kann, dass nach wie vor die AP beim Provider ist, nur er sich das
dann runterlädt. Aber soweit ich das verstanden habe, war das in Realtime diese Transkription.
So habe ich die Keynote verstanden von daher bin ich jetzt davon ausgegangen,
dass das Telefon tatsächlich den Call händelt.
Also nachträglich geht es natürlich auch aber es war ja so das Ding transkribiert
und anhand dessen was geschrieben wird entscheidest du ob du den Anruf dann
in dem Moment auch annimmst und dann muss das ja ein Realtime sein also das, das, das, das.
Eine andere Sache die da so mit IOS und so mitgekommen ist, ist ein neues Auto, korrekt?
Und das ist wieder ein Moment wo sie AI gesagt haben ohne AI zu sagen,
was ihnen ja die ganze Zeit gelungen ist, ich glaube es ist kein einziges Mal
der Begriff AI gefallen.
Wir hatten Schnaps stehen zum runter kippen aber kam kein einziges Mal.
Wir sind alle nüchtern geblieben.
Also darüber müssen wir hinterher aber auch nochmal auf Namita Ebene,
was erlaube, die müssen jetzt serienlos werden, wir haben die letzte,
vorletzte Sendung ja unendlich schon drüber geratet, die muss sterben.
Aber sie haben glaube ich auch Maschinen-Learning nicht gesagt, oder?
Doch, ein bisschen Maschinen-Learning noch, aber sie haben in dem Fall nicht
Maschinen-Learning gesagt, sondern das andere.
Transformer-Modell.
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Das ist sehr interessant generell, ich weiß gerade gar nicht wo ich jetzt diese
Anregung her habe, das war irgendeine kluge Analyse von jemandem auf Youtube.
Achja genau, dieser MKHDB. MKBHD.
MKBHD. HDSML.
Marques Brownlee.
Ich immer noch nicht genau weiß, ob ich den eigentlich, genau,
Brownlee, ich find den irgendwie charmant.
Er macht gute Punkte. Ich weiß bloß immer noch nicht, ob ich das ganz toll finde.
Da bin ich irgendwie noch nicht. Aber eine Sache hat er sehr schön erläutert,
nämlich wie Apple generell mit Bezeichnungen umgeht und wie sie Sachen nennen.
Und nahezu alles, was ihre Betriebssysteme, ihre Geräte so können und wo irgendwie
special source drin ist. So hier haben wir eine Technologie benutzt.
Dann sagen sie aber nicht AI. Sondern sie denken sich entweder was eigenes aus,
also jede Sache hat immer so einen eigenen Apple Namen, Shareplay,
Name Drop, Retina Display und so
weiter, wo man auch irgendwie das nennen könnte, was alle anderen sagen.
Aber Apple will halt nicht das sagen, was alle anderen sagen,
weil wenn sie das Wort nehmen, was alle anderen sagen, dann sind sie ja Me Too.
Erstens sind sie Me Too. Und zweitens, ja aber wenn auch andere Firmen dann
diese Begriffe vielleicht auch übernehmen, dann sind sie sozusagen Büttel der
Definition anderer, das mögen sie überhaupt nicht.
Und sie schützen sich natürlich auch vor anderen Konnotationen mit diesem Begriff,
unter dem sie nicht in der Zukunft leiden möchten und das ist zum Beispiel bei
AI so, weil wenn du an AI denkst, dann denkst du halt nicht nur an,
Google macht Transkription, sondern AI ist halt auch Gefahr aus dem Weltall,
wir werden alle sterben, ich verliere meinen Job,
Weltuntergang, alle möglichen Leute benutzen diesen Begriff,
überall wird der debattiert und du weißt nicht, ob Fox News nächste Woche irgendeine
Kampagne lostritt und dann stehst du da mit deinem Hochglanzprodukt,
was du für viele Billionen produziert hast und dann viele Billionen Leute verkaufen möchtest.
Und dann ist halt diese Basis, dieser Message ist dann halt verloren.
Und deswegen denken sie sich für jeden Scheiß was eigenes aus.
Das fand ich eine sehr schöne Analyse und das passt.
Autokorrekt benutzen sie allerdings wie alle anderen.
Und hier haben sie dann aber eben dieses Transformer-Model als Begriff eingeführt
und was sie damit meinen, ist halt so, naja, halt Chachipiti sozusagen.
Wir können jetzt ganze Sätze vorhersagen, wir machen jetzt auch das mit den
Texten und mit der Wahrscheinlichkeitsvorhersage, also Autokorrekt ist jetzt
eben nicht nur einzelne Worte.
Aber das ist jetzt eine Interpretation von dir, dass da Chet GPT drin ist,
das haben sie so nicht gesagt.
Nein, das wollte ich damit auch gar nicht ausdrücken.
Ein Large Language Model.
Also sozusagen die Technologie, die auch ein Chat GPT ermöglicht.
Die wissenschaftliche Basis quasi dessen, was da drin ist.
Nicht Chat GPT und auch vielleicht nicht genauso, aber Apple hat da auch schon
mal was von gehört und die haben auch ein paar Leute, die sich ein bisschen
mit Machine Learning beschäftigen und sind auch in der Lage das vielleicht mal einzusetzen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob es funktionieren wird, aber ich denke mal eine Verbesserung
bei Autokorrekt könnte ein ganz großes Feature sein.
Ich muss sagen, als Kunde sehe ich das ja echt mit so viel Schmerz,
wie schlimm das geworden ist mit der Zeit.
Es ging ja wirklich einfach nur mit der Zeit bergab, wie das mit dem Tippen funktioniert hat.
Am Anfang, wie das iPhone 1 rauskam,
hat jeder gemeint, wir haben ja keine Buttons, das ist ganz schwierig.
Und da hat es ganz gut funktioniert im Verhältnis. Da war es irgendwie gefühlt
gut, weil man konnte relativ gut tippen. Und dann ist es mit der Zeit mit jeden
mehr Features immer schlimmer geworden.
Und im Moment ist es wirklich so, was mir das AutoCorrect zusammenschreibt,
in meinem Gebrauch vor allem, wo ich so ein gemischtes Englisch-Deutsch-System
habe, wo ich nicht immer auf der richtigen Tastatur bin, ist einfach eine Katastrophe,
was ich teilweise Leuten schon geschrieben habe.
Das Ended Feature von Messages von letztem oder vorletztem Jahr ist mit das
wichtigste Feature überhaupt, dass ich das irgendwie so korrigieren kann,
weil was da teilweise rauskommt, ei, ei, ei.
Ich habe inzwischen AutoCorrect abgeschaltet. Kann man das?
Jaja kann man. Also du bekommst noch Vorschläge aber er korrigiert nicht mehr von alleine.
Geht das? Auf dem Mac geht das? Aber ich wusste nicht, dass es auf iOS auch geht.
Nee es geht auch auf den iOS.
Also meine Arbeitsthesis immer ist es auf Englisch eigentlich genauso schlimm
oder ist das einfach ein Punkt von sie geben sich im Deutschen keine Mühe.
Es ist auf Englisch genauso schlimm.
Naja ich meine deren Beispiel, das sie in der Keynote hatten,
sagte er auch alles mit ihrem Ducking Autocorrect.
Also das war ja irgendwie, das war ja ein Problem, in das alle reingelaufen sind.
Aber gut, vielleicht ist es auch der Apple Stock im Arsch Profanity Filter,
den sie da irgendwie mal ausgemacht haben. Das kann ja nicht auch sein.
Also grundsätzlich glaub kann man natürlich sagen kann man das nur begrüßen
also jede Verbesserung in dem Bereich ist gut und wenn sie da in der Tat jetzt
ein eigenes large language model drunter haben besteht ja vielleicht doch noch
Hoffnung dass sie das als nächstes oder übernächstes dann auch mal auf Siri ausrollen.
Wobei hat haben die die Geräte sowas wie jetzt hier die ich AirPods sondern
wie heißt diese Krachmacherkugel.
Homepods, genau danke.
Die Krachmacherkugel.
Naja mit zwei kleinen Kindern.
Das ist kein Brüllwürfel, ich weiß, das ist eine Krachmacherkugel.
Hat die nen Chip drin mit ner Neural Engine?
Oder ist das neuer?
Das ist die Aktuelle schon.
Ich weiß nicht was ist da drin A12?
Irgendwie sowas wahrscheinlich.
Weil also ich wiederhole mich diese Whisper Geschichte die läuft halt wirklich
verstörend gut auf der Norel Engine, wo man sich immer jahrelang gefragt hat
wozu promoten die die eigentlich so und immer ist sie irgendwie in ihren Werbungen
drin aber was macht denn dieses Viech jetzt eigentlich wirklich.
Und wenn man das mal wirklich sieht so Performance versus Energieverbrauch,
das wären also dann für die Homepods wäre das, wo ja Siri als quasi alleiniges Merkmal drauf läuft,
dann könnten sie das da schon in Stellung bringen und vielleicht ist jetzt diese
Autokorrektur quasi erstmal ein erster Breitband-Feldversuch um zu gucken,
so funktioniert das wirklich so wie wir uns das vorstellen.
Also mir wäre ja schon geholfen, wenn diese Krachmacherkugel, wie du sie nennst,
sich mal merken würde, in welchem fucking WiFi-Netz sie bitteschön sich anmelden
soll und nicht immer irgendwie ins andere Netz springen. Also das ist so, naja, gut.
Ich hab das bei uns zu Hause jetzt so gelöst, dass ich das Netz von einem Repeater
zum nächsten einfach nur noch immer weiter abmixe.
Naja, ich hab halt ein Netz für mich und ein Gästenetz.
Und sämtliche Apple Devices haben Probleme damit zu verstehen,
dass manche Geräte in das eine Netz gehören und andere Geräte in das andere Netz gehören.
Und dass man halt auch egal, ob man jetzt über iCloud jetzt weiß ich nicht oder
die Netze shared, dass manche Geräte in manchen Netzen nix zu suchen haben.
Das weiß ich nicht, das kriegen sie nicht hin.
Also ein HomePod hat einen S7 Chip, das ist der gleiche der in der Apple Watch
drin ist und ich sehe da keine neuere Engine.
Aber die Apple Watch macht ja auch irgendeine Art von Siri.
Ja, es ist definitiv Serieunterstützung in irgendeiner Form.
Naja aber für die jetzige Serie brauchst du keine Neural Engine,
weil das ja komplett an den Server geht. Du hast so ein bisschen Transkriptions-Fu
und Kompressions-Fu von dem Audio, aber die läuft ja eben nicht on device.
Also ich find hier nichts dazu.
Ja das sind schlechte Nachrichten.
Ja gut machen wir weiter. Ein Feature wo ich noch so dachte so Holla Amerika
ruft an, war ja dieses Check-In Feature für die Kids.
Wo ich so dachte das ist ja ein echtes Helikopter-Mum Feature.
Check in Peter, was war das?
Wo die Kids immer sagen können wo sie sind oder sagen müssen wo sie sind?
Genau das ist quasi so foursquare in apple messages,
also das ist ein neues Feature von apple messages, dass Kinder in deiner Family sagen können,
so ich bin jetzt hier bei der Schule angekommen oder ich bin beim Sport angekommen
oder ich bin bei Freund XY angekommen
und dann kriegst du das auf deinen Devices, kannst du dann sehen.
Find my sozusagen mit, Find my kid genau.
Genau, nur dass es quasi eine Umdrehung weniger helikopterüberwachungsmäßig ist.
Also du kannst dann quasi, wenn du deinem Kind schon etwas mehr vertraust,
kannst du offiziell das, genau, kannst du das Find My abschalten auf dem Device
des Kindes, dass es etwas mehr Freiraum und weniger Überwachung hat.
Und kannst dann aber sagen, so und dafür checkst du dich dann aber bitte bei
den entsprechenden Stellen ein und was dazwischen geschieht, ja, stays in Vegas.
Ich gutes feature ja okay so betrachtet ist es natürlich so es gibt auch leute
also was man auch machen kann es eben zu sagen dass man wenn man irgendwo wieder
hinkommt dass es automatisch eine nachricht gibt so da muss man so.
Wenn man nach hause fährt von den eltern zum beispiel die mögen das ja auch
gerne dass man dann bescheid bekommen wenn man zu hause ist und die gucken dann
immer auf ein mal und die können dann auch push nachricht bekommen stattdessen.
Also Find My hätten sie auch gerne noch ein bisschen ausbauen können,
weil es ist ja durchaus ein hilfreiches Feature, aber gerade in puncto so selektive,
wie soll ich sagen, Freiraumschaffung, weil die einzige Möglichkeit ist mit
all den Leuten, mit denen du deinen Standort teilst, du kannst halt entweder
den Standort teilen mit allen oder ganz ausschalten.
Und das ist eigentlich nicht zeitgemäß.
Also es müsste möglich sein hier Gruppen schaffen zu können,
zu sagen, es gibt hier meine Favorites, die dürfen auch weiterhin gucken,
aber ich will halt auch mal so ein Privacy Mode haben, wo jetzt nicht jeder gucken muss.
Was ich halt immer mache, ist das bis zum Ende des Tages.
Da musst du ja immer wieder neu aufsetzen. Ja das ist nervig,
aber das ist halt das was ich dann meistens mache.
Also da hat man keine Management Ebene noch drüber zu satteln, dass wir hier frei sind.
An sich ist es nämlich auch ganz reizvoll, ich hab so ein paar Freunde,
die sehe ich selten so, aber die sind auch in anderen Städten,
teilweise in anderen Ländern.
Jemand der die ganze Zeit um die Welt zieht zum Beispiel, Leute die auf Weltreise
unterwegs sind und so weiter und das ist einfach super cool.
Dann so, ah da bist du jetzt angekommen und tralala dann könnte ich ja jetzt
mal wieder Kontakt aufnehmen, weil hm bist du jetzt wieder da,
dann wollte ich ja sowieso mal vorbeischauen.
Die Nummer oder ich bin in einer
anderen Stadt und lauf Leuten einfach dadurch über den Weg, ist geil.
Ich meine es hat auch seine Kost, gar keine Frage, aber es ist ein interessantes Spiel.
Hier etwas, was auf der einen Seite super creepy sein kann, aber auf der anderen
Seite auch super super super nützlich und richtig lustig, das irgendwie besser zu balancieren.
Das fände ich schon mal ganz geil. Aber da haben sie leider keinen neuen Schritt unternommen.
Und was ich auch schöner fände ist, wenn man genauer einstellen kann,
wie lange das jetzt gehen soll. Weil ich glaube das Maximum ist bis zum Ende des Tages.
Ich kann halt nicht sagen, hier die Woche ist Camp und innerhalb dieser Camp
Woche dürfen diese Leute alle wissen wo ich bin. Und zwar so lange wie bis zu
dem Zeitpunkt und dann ist gut.
Genau, weil es ist eh klar wo du bist und dann ist es einfach nochmal nützlich ganz genau zu sagen.
Oder halt auch einfach zu sagen, heute bin ich für, also ich würde halt ganz
gerne zu so einer Insidergruppe, also quasi so Family oder halt alle anderen.
Also das wäre schon mal ein Anfang. Ich hätte es auch noch gerne genauer,
aber wir wissen Apple würde so einen Schritt nicht so schnell gehen.
Aber dass man auch sagen kann also entweder gar keine oder nur eine ungenaue
Position, weil für die meisten Leute reicht es aus zu wissen dass ich in Berlin
bin so, aber das mehr muss dann auch nicht gesagt werden so.
Ja das wäre jetzt auch das nächste gewesen was ich gesagt habe immerhin man
kann jetzt die Airtags sharen.
Was wie was man kann Airtags sharen das habe ich nicht mitbekommen.
Das habe ich zumindest nicht notiert. Das wundert mich jetzt auch in der Keynote.
Mir war so als könnte man jetzt AirTags sharen. Das wurde nämlich auch mal Zeit.
Share AirTag. Find my AirTag or find my network accessories with up to five other people.
Jetzt hast du mich kurz nervös gemacht, wenn ich jetzt hier Unsinn erzähle.
Du machst mich ganz irre.
Jeder in der Gruppe kann Precision Finding benutzen und einen Sound spielen.
Ja bis zu fünf bis zu fünf leuten kannst du dein deine find my devices teilen.
Da kannst du dann auch mal Dinge ausleihen, die mit AirTags, das ist ja geil.
Ja ne das war so eins wo ich sagen würde so sinnvolles Feature danke.
Ja vor allem können sie auch gleich diese erwartet dass sie mal was in das family
sharing gleich einbauen dass man so so ein family ertag hat.
Also so das auto naja gut ich meine wenn sie das mit dem teilen jetzt schon
mal implementiert haben vielleicht gibt's dann da nochmal eine erweiterung zu.
Zu Airtex habe ich in der Tat für eine der nächsten Sendungen mal eine schöne
Geschichte wo meiner Frau das Fahrrad mit Airtex gestohlen wurde und was danach
geschah. Können wir schon mal teasern, sind aber so ein 20 Minuten Blog also
den machen wir nicht heute.
Okay, schalten Sie uns das nächste mal ein wenn Sie live stoppen.
Wieso ist Apple TV plus besser geworden man weiß es nicht wahrscheinlich nicht.
Heute ist es wieder aufregend. Keine Ahnung interessiert mich nicht.
Zu iPadOS habe ich mir noch was markiert, was ich noch sagen wollte.
Offline-Maps.
Offline-Maps, ja.
Was gibt's jetzt für Apple-Maps?
Das ist ganz neu. Haben sie versucht seit Jahren anzubauen und jetzt haben sie
es wohl endlich gemacht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo das große Problem dabei ist.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht haben sie nochmal bei TomTom nachgefragt, wie man das macht.
Oder bei Google.
Ich benutze ja immer TomTom, weil da gibt's halt Offline-Maps.
Du benutzt TomTom?
Für Autorouting, ja.
Echt?
Tatsächlich? Ja.
Krass.
Ah, weil?
Weil das gut funktioniert.
Besser als Apple Maps?
Ich würde sagen ja. Also,
naja die machen seit Jahrzehnten nichts anderes und da kostet irgendwie so das
Volldings kostet irgendwie zwölf Euro im Jahr oder so. Also es ist halt ne Subscription.
Okay.
Du kannst dann im Prinzip alle Länder der Welt runterladen und du kriegst Verkehrsinformationen
und so ein Gedöns. Also ich bin damit ganz zufrieden, ehrlich gesagt.
Die können inzwischen sogar Carplay. Das hat sehr lange gedauert,
bis sie das hingekriegt haben.
Können die auch Apple Watch?
Das können sie nicht.
Oh, schön.
Also wenn du jetzt Gebrumme auf der Uhr haben willst.
Dann ist die endlich aus beim Autofahren. Super. Allein deswegen würde ich es hernehmen.
Autofahrt immer meine Apple Watch mit brummt, macht mich so fertig.
Wieso? Das kannst du doch ausschalten.
Wie?
Geht die?
Ich wüsste nicht wie, wenn ich das auf Kabel habe, dann macht meine Uhr mit.
Ich habe das bisher noch nie gemacht. Und dann macht meine Uhr halt immer mal
sechsmal Pieps oder dreimal Pieps und kurz und lang und ich weiß nicht mal was
sie tut und ich denke immer mich ruft jemand an und dann ach ja ist nun die nächste Kurve.
Also für mich ist das ja essentiell deswegen würde ich gar nicht auf die Idee
kommen das auszuschalten aber ich gucke gerade mal hier Karten.
Aber du kennst meine Eselsbrücke zum Thema?
Du kannst das hier in Settings, in Apple Watch Karten kannst du das einstellen.
Du kannst für Fahren mit Carplay fahren, Gehen und Radfahren kannst du abbiege Hinweise ja, nein.
Na in der Apple Watch App. Auf deinem iPhone hast du eine Apple Watch App.
In der Apple Watch App da gibt es zu Karten eine Einstellung.
Da gibt es einen Eintrag für Karten.
Beim Autofahren vibrierst du nicht bitte. Das geht. Fahren oder mit Carplay
fahren, das ist, ich hab was gelernt. In der Freakshow lern ich wieder was.
Abbiegehinweise.
Nicht nur du, auch viele andere, auch ich.
Die Eselsbrücke noch schnell, Ronny, bitte.
Die Eselsbrücke. Also rechts rum ist Hitler Hitler Hitler Hitler Hitler und
links rum ist Ulbricht Ulbricht Ulbricht Ulbricht.
Auch gleich die passende Richtung.
Ich weiß nicht, meine Apple Watch hat von alleine,
also die schaltet die ganze Zeit meine Settings aus und ich betreibe ja alle
meine Devices generell stumm,
nur meine Apple Watch hat sich dann wieder die Töne eingeschaltet und das ist
tatsächlich bei der Navigation ist das hilfreich, weil die Töne sind hilfreicher als die Vibration.
Also die Vibration ist bei mir, mag an meiner dicken Haut keine Ahnung was liegen,
ist auch nicht so, dass ich es gut auseinander halten könnte,
auf welche Art und Weise die mich jetzt da antappt, auf dem Fahrrad schon mal fünfmal nicht.
Genau Fahrrad und wo es halt auch leider versagt ist auf dem Motorrad,
da habe ich auch noch das andere Problem, dass es auch sehr schwierig ist die
Apple Watch zu bedienen, insbesondere weil ich halt so ein Elektromotorrad habe,
was auch automatisch bremst, deswegen kann ich die rechte Hand überhaupt nicht
benutzen, damit ist die Apple Watch eigentlich komplett aus dem Spiel.
Dann habe ich neulich diese Accessibility-Geschichte eingeschaltet,
weil du kannst ja auch mit so einer Handbewegung mit Fingerschnipsen und Handballen
kannst du ja tatsächlich Dinge tun auf deiner Apple Watch, wenn du das einschaltest.
Die kurze Variante der Geschichte ist, hat für mich auch nicht funktioniert,
aber es war ein schöner Traum, weil es so war, dass ich in irgendeiner Form
mit einer Handbewegung meine Apple Watch steuern könnte.
Stimmt, das habe ich auch nur einmal ausprobiert und mir gedacht, äh.
Da müssen sie noch dran arbeiten, mal gucken.
Genau das.
Wir kamen ja jetzt eigentlich von den Offline Maps und man kann natürlich die
Frage stellen, wo braucht man die eigentlich und in welchen Szenarien?
In Brandenburg zum Beispiel.
Ja aber um dort dann eben auch dann was zu tun und
da schreibt schon jemand im chat also wenn es um solche sachen wie
irgendwie wandern oder fahrradfahren nach kate
oder sowas geht muss man natürlich schon gucken wie verhält sich das dann hinterher
gegen so konkurrenz wie komod den link hier gerade mal reingeworfen kennt ihr
das ja was halt auch schon ein dienst ist den es seit vielen vielen vielen jahren
gibt ich glaube seit sechs sieben jahren oder sowas nutze ich den glaube ich
und die haben halt vor allen dingen Karten,
die auf Wandern, Fahrradfahren, Sightseeing, Abenteuer erleben, optimiert sind.
Mit Höhenlinien und Routen, die du selber hinterlegen kannst und kannst dir
von anderen Leuten Routen, die besten Sachen zusammenschnipseln und hast schon
gleich ein Bild, so sieht das an der Stelle aus und.
Alles geschenkt, nur die Möglichkeit mit Bordmitteln einfach mal eine Offline-Karte
zu haben, finde ich gut und ich werde sie wahrscheinlich auch entsprechend nutzen.
Besonders wenn man hier die Stadtgrenzen von Berlin verlässt,
verlässt einen ja auch meistens die Connectivity.
Genau, die Open Street Map App wird gerade auch noch gerühmt hier,
die hat auch schon lange lange lange einen Offline-Modus.
Ja, alle anderen haben es vorher schon gekonnt. Das ist nicht die Frage.
Ja, also...
Wir können es glaube ich einigen so gut, dass es jetzt auch irgendwie das Apple
Device oder die offizielle Apple App kennen, das ist kein Fehler,
aber für viele daran hängende Nutzungsszenarien gibt es vielleicht in der Tat
noch bessere Alternativen.
Die Frage ist, wie funktioniert diese Funktion? Ich weiß nicht,
ob sie dazu überhaupt irgendwas gesagt haben.
Also kann man nur da offline machen, wo man ist?
Es sah so aus, als würde man so Bereiche in der Map markieren,
aber es gibt ein Screenshot auf der Seite.
Also das wäre schon schön, wenn ich nach Nordfinland fahren möchte,
dass ich mir, bevor ich ins Flugzeug steige, markieren kann,
ich hätte gerne für den Bereich die Karte runtergeladen.
Ja ich will aber nicht den Bereich, ich will ja schon das Land.
Und das ist die Frage ob das geht. Naja ich meine Schweiz ist zum Beispiel so ein Problem,
ist nicht in allen Mobilfunktarifen drin, ja und du willst nur rein und wieder
raus und das ist schon ein Problem und kann dich arm machen, da wäre das hilfreich.
Oder du kommst halt in so einem fernen Land an und willst dort vor Ort dann
irgendwie eine SIM-Karte shoppen und brauchst eigentlich erstmal nur die Hilfe
in unmittelbarer Umgebung des Flughafens oder sowas.
Da kann das helfen. Wobei übrigens, wo wir gerade bei dem Thema sind,
vielleicht könnte man das auch mal kurz erwähnen, haben wir nämlich glaube ich so noch nie gehabt.
Wenn man jetzt dieses Problem hat, Schweizer Problem, Israel Problem,
das war es in meiner Anwendung.
Du hast also quasi einen Mobilfunktarif, der das Land nicht abdeckt,
wo du hinfährst. Habt ihr schon mal diese ganzen eSIM Apps ausprobiert?
Noch nie.
Ja also das funktioniert im Prinzip also ich habe jetzt nur Erfahrungen gesammelt
mit Airolo, A-I-R-O-L-O.
Es gibt auch noch andere, also ich sag jetzt nicht das ist das beste oder tollste,
aber das funktioniert zumindest so halbwegs, da kannst du halt sagen,
hallo ich will fahren nach Land, Na, keine Ahnung, Schweiz.
Und dann kriegst du so verschiedene Datenpakete angeboten als eSIM und sagst
ja okay, hier, was weiß ich, Schweiz, ich bin da eine Woche,
ich brauche eine Woche, irgendwie gib mir 10 Gigabyte, fertig ist die Lucy.
Und dann klickst du da drauf und dann kaufst du das,
lädst die eSIM direkt runter, installierst es direkt in dein Telefon,
dann ist die eSIM schon mal so voraktiviert und wenn du dann ins Land kommst,
dann schaltest du die so richtig scharf und dann sagt die Hallo,
hier ist ja auch das Netz, was ich kenne, ab jetzt funktioniere ich und dann
laufen die Daten darüber.
Und das war manchmal mit ein bisschen Zickerei, aber es hat dann am Ende funktioniert.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was das letzte Mal das Problem war,
als ich in der Schweiz damit Ärger hatte, weil sich dann irgendwie das nicht
aktivieren ließ und unklar war warum. Das kann aber auch genauso ein Netz-Hickup
gewesen sein. Also grundsätzlich funktioniert das.
Übrigens, Schweiz kostet dich bei TomTom 242 Megabyte.
Das lädt man dann einmal runter und dann hat man die Schweiz.
Ah ja, ok. Kostet dich vorher. Vorher.
Du musst es vorher irgendwie runterladen. Nee, es kostet nicht extra.
Du kannst alle Karten runterladen, die du runterladen möchtest.
Also es gibt hier die große Auswahl an Kontinenten. Antarktis ist jetzt nicht dabei.
Ok, aber TomTom macht ja nur Navigation.
Macht nur, ja was heißt, ja nur Navigation im Sinne von.
Ja du willst ja Restaurants, Orte, Tralala, alles mögliche auch haben.
Ja, das natürlich nicht. Genau, deswegen ist das ja interessant.
Ja, ich weiß nicht genau. Ich glaube, die Suche sucht in der lokalen Karte,
aber sie sucht auch im Netz bei TomTom. Ich weiß nicht genau,
wie sie das machen. Aber sie haben halt auch...
Mehr als nur Straßennamen. Da gibt's auch Sehenswürdigkeiten und so ein Gedöns,
aber jetzt nicht so viel.
Aber es ist vor allen Dingen für Routing, für Auto ist es halt gut.
Das Fahrradrouting habe ich jetzt so noch nicht ausprobiert, muss ich mal sagen.
Alright. Gut, dann können wir vielleicht IOS-Land auch schon mal verlassen.
Eine Kleinigkeit wollte ich zur IOS noch glatt sagen, ist PDFs werden jetzt
besser unterstützt vom iPad.
Das klingt jetzt nach einem Problem, das keiner hat, aber für mich ist es so,
dass ich beim Chor gerne von den Noten im iPad singe.
Erstens da kann man stufenlos vergrößern und zweitens mal sind leuchten die
noten von sich aus also auch unter schlechten sichtbedingungen
schlechten beleuchtungsbedingungen kann man da viel sehen.
Und was sie da gezeigt haben sah jetzt nicht so viel anders aus als das was
eigentlich die files up schon konnte aber sie haben da glaube ich noch mal ein
bisschen aufpoliert und so weiter und i approve.
Machst du nicht Fourscore?
Was heißt das?
Nutzt du nicht die App Fourscore für das?
Wie heißt die?
Fourscore. Das ist so eine sünkende iPad App,
wo man Noten drin verwalten kann, ein bisschen annotieren kann,
wo du als mit Musik zu tun habende Mensch einfach mal so automatisch blättern
und den ganzen Scheiß machen kannst.
Ja und die ist ganz okay. Und ich will eh die ein bisschen verschlagworten,
weil Files ist, es tut mir echt weh. Files kann so viel, also es sind teilweise
echt coole Features drin, aber so PDFs angucken und so gehört da immer nicht dazu.
Also das einzige bei Files, nervt mich ist, dass du ihm nicht sagen kannst,
halte den Quatsch jetzt auf biegen und brechen mal bitte lokal,
wo du im Zweifelsfall immer das Zeug neu runterladen musst.
Das geht mir tierisch auf den Senkel, warum sie das machen.
Er merkt sich auch nicht, ich hab jetzt, weiß ich nicht, ich hab das jetzt vor
einer halben Stunde, hab ich diese Datei aufgemacht, da könnte ich sie jetzt
noch ein bisschen nachhalten und sie erst morgen löschen, nein,
dann ist sie gleich wieder weg.
Du kannst sie halt lokal speichern, das einzige was du wirklich machen kannst,
aber dann bist du halt in einer anderen Welt.
Was ist denn falsch am PDF Support derzeit auf dem iPad? Also was genau ist denn dann besser jetzt?
Also man kann live zusammenarbeiten auf einem pdf, also du kannst das quasi
freigeben für beliebige Leute und dann können gleichzeitig Annotationen und
so weiter erstellt worden, also das haben sie zumindest gezeigt.
Ist das das was du meinst?
Ehrlich gesagt erinnere ich mich nicht mehr so ganz genau, aber sie hatten gezeigt,
dass man jetzt auch PDFs, ganz hochoffiziell, dass das jetzt gut ist,
um mit denen zu arbeiten.
Das hatten sie gezeigt und da dachte ich so, jo endlich mal nicht nur so ein,
okay in Files kann man PDF öffnen und irgendwas mit dem Stift machen, also das ist so.
Genau, was sie gemacht haben, ist mehr oder weniger sowas Ähnliches wie die
Freeform App oder in die Freeform App integriert PDFs angucken,
annotieren und kollaborieren daran, gemeinsam ausfüllen auch,
also auch die ganzen Formulare und so weiter.
Da haben sie ein bisschen rumgeteasert und das ist ja jetzt across the board,
ja, also nicht nur auf iOS.
Deswegen ist es glaube ich entweder in Freeform drin, was ich schlimm genug
finde, weil Freeform finde ich mit einer der übelsten Apps leider so, obwohl die Idee gut ist.
Und ja, also ich habe eher Angst vor dem Feature, wenn ich ehrlich bin,
von dem was ich mich erinnere.
Also ich hatte so ein bisschen den Eindruck gewonnen, ich weiß nicht,
ob das stimmt, dass sie quasi die PDF-Engine von,
allen OS, also ihre PDF-Engine generell, die sie auf allen Plattformen verwenden,
generell überarbeitet haben, also ich weiß nicht, das wäre nicht das schlechteste.
Ja ja ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt wirklich so auf dem Level von Revride ist oder so,
aber immerhin haben sie diesen ganzen, ich darf ja nicht AI sagen,
Machine Learning Teil mit reingebracht,
mit dem sie quasi innerhalb von PDFs die Struktur erkennen für Formular ausfüllen,
Selbst wenn die PDFs nicht korrekte PDF-Formulare sind,
was die meisten PDFs ja nicht sind, das heißt sie lesen,
wo ist irgendwas und das könnte auch dazu führen, dass so Copy-Paste von Text
in PDF vielleicht ein bisschen noch sinnvoller ist,
so Spalten, Erkennung oder sowas, habe ich jetzt noch nichts dazu gehört,
aber das wäre so ein bisschen meine Hoffnung, gerade wenn du sagst,
wird besser, das wäre etwas, was besser wird, so Sharing und Collaboration habe ich nicht so vermisst.
Was auch ganz schön wäre, wenn die Annotationen nicht ganz so viel Speicher verbrauchen würden.
Ich hab nämlich immer wieder das Problem, dass wenn ich tatsächlich in Noten
Notizen mache, hier mit dem Pencil, und dann versuche die auszudrucken,
dass dann der Drucker aussteigt, weil das PDF zu groß wird.
Ich hab immer das Problem, dass wenn ich, ich hab zum Beispiel so Anwendungen
wie Buchhaltung, Bewirtungsbelege.
Ich geh mal eben aufs Klo.
Wie wärs denn mit einem Outliner vielleicht?
Nein, ich hab einfach ein PDF, was ich quasi so als generischen Bewirtungsbeleg verwende.
Das heißt in dem Moment, wo ich irgendwie was als Bewirtungsbeleg abrechnen
muss, muss ich ja eintragen, werde daran teilgenommen und so weiter.
Zum Beispiel die Pizza, die hier vor der Sendung gegessen wird oder was war's
heute? Ja Pizza. Heute gab's Pizza, ich hab heute nicht mitgegessen,
deswegen hab ich das nur so am Rande mitbekommen.
Ralf hatte eine Pizza, ich hatte einen Salat.
Genau, also kleine Information hier, die Freakshow beginnt immer erst mit Essen.
Nur dass ich ausnahmsweise noch nicht mitgegessen habe. Backstage.
Genau, Backstage Essen wird natürlich hier hochoffiziell von der Mitterebene
finanziert von euren Spenden.
Ja danke dafür.
Da kommen sie unter anderem rein. Aber das muss ja alles auch korrekt abgerechnet werden.
Also muss ich ein Bewirtungsbeleg für die Freakshow erstellen,
wo dann schön eingetragen wird wer daran teilgenommen hat etc wie viel Geld
das gekostet hat und jetzt will ich das diesem Beleg hinzufügen.
Also habe ich eine Vorlage auf meinem Macintosh Bewirtungsbeleg Vordruck.
Und dann fülle ich das da einfach aus, habe also quasi ein Formular und tippe das dann alles ein.
Und dann mach ich so drag and drop von dem ausgefüllten Formular.
In das PDF wo der eigentliche Kaufbeleg gescannt ist, um daraus eine Datei zu
machen und die gemeinsam abzulegen.
Und dabei fliegen mir dann diese Annotationen manchmal einfach weg,
das heißt ich hab dann einfach ein leeres Formular drin und ich frage mich halt
immer was soll das, wenn ich allerdings das ausgefüllte Formular nehme und ich
sage drucke und öffne das aber druckst nicht wirklich auf dem Drucker,
sondern öffne das in Privat.
Und dann nehme ich diese Datei und drehe die rein, dann ist alles supi.
Das mache ich immer deswegen.
Es ist so nervig und das muss sich ändern, das geht gar nicht.
Weil manchmal geht es auch und dann denkst du nicht drüber nach und dann machst
du es rein und Monate später machst du die Datei auf, ja was steht denn hier
drin, ja alles leer. Ich habe nochmal nachgelesen.
Sie haben es auf alle Fälle verbessert im Sinne von ausfüllen.
Können Sie besser ausfüllen mit den Metadaten, die du so hast.
Also wenn das irgendwie Namensfelder sind und Kreditkartenfelder und so weiter,
dann wissen die das ein bisschen besser. Das finden sie raus.
Es wirkte ein bisschen so, als wäre das ganze PDF-Handling ein bisschen besser,
plus dieses Feature, das ich vor Angst vor Freeform gesehen habe,
ist ein Feature der Notes-App dann. Das heißt, wenn du kollaborieren willst
oder annotieren, dann kannst du das jetzt in der Notes-App machen für beliebige PDFs.
Die Frage ist, ob sich jetzt an dem Verhalten auf dem Mac was ändert,
wenn man so ein Formular ausfüllt und die Datei dann irgendwie nicht speichert,
schon speichert, nicht ausdruckt.
Also für mich war Drucken immer das Speichern von Formularen auch.
Ich wusste gar nicht genau. Ich hatte immer so viel Respekt vor ausgefüllten PDFs.
Dass ich mir dachte das ist doch irgendwo wird das doch bestimmt gespeichert
und das macht er bestimmt falsch,
bestimmt gibt es zehn Orte im PDF wo man das irgendwie speichern kann aber wenn ich es jetzt drucke,
ja dann muss es ja drin sein sonst könnte man es ja nicht drucken insofern war
das für mich immer so zack das ist das Feature und außerdem ist das Drucken,
wiederum in PDF drucken für mich so ein Killer Feature so per se von macOS,
Das ist bei mir so innen drin, egal welche App irgendwas drucken kann,
dann druck ich es in einen PDF, dann habe ich einen PDF und dann mache ich mit dem dann weiter.
Das nutze ich so häufig und das ist Gott sei Dank auch nie ganz kaputt gegangen.
Ab und zu gab es mal ein bisschen Verhalten, das so ein bisschen komisch ist,
aber so aktuell geht es immer noch sehr gut.
Wirklich den Druckdialog starten muss, dafür ist so ein Quatsch,
ich meine so ein Normalisierungsbutton hätte ja schon gereicht oder so ein Indikator
mit dieses PDF enthält Formulardaten,
möchtest du sie einbrennen, ja irgendwie sowas oder das ist einfach generell für dich?
Also auch eine Geschichte, die mich nach wie vor echt hart trifft,
ist, dass wenn du den Share-Button drückst im Preview, dann kriegst du oben
so eine kleine Zusammenfassung.
Das ist ja diese Datei mit PDF und mit einem Icon. Und du könntest einfach dieses Icon draggen.
Wenn ich das Icon wieder auf Preview draggen würde, dann hätte ich genau das
machen. Share drücken, draggen, fertig. Ja, dann hätte ich dieses Feature so,
das wäre so ganz, geht natürlich nicht. Aber ich habe ja das Save to Downloads
von dieser App, die ich mir empfohlen habe.
So, du hast ja gerade gesagt, Notes und Kollaboration.
Da können wir vielleicht mal kurz fallen lassen, was einige noch nicht gemerkt
haben und was jetzt gar nichts mit den neuen iOS-Versionen oder macOS-Versionen zu tun hat,
nämlich dass jetzt die Notes-App, also auf Deutsch Notizen, sowohl in iOS als
auch in macOS jetzt einen Pad-Modus hat.
Das heißt also, viele Leute können gleichzeitig an einem Text schreiben und
man sieht, wer schreibt wo was.
Das geht schon vorher.
Na das geht so seit ein paar Wochen, Monate, ich glaube noch nicht Monate,
das gibt es noch nicht, also du könntest schreiben, aber du hast nicht gesehen
live, wer schreibt gerade wo und dieses,
dass du mit zwei Fingern nach rechts swipes, könnt ihr einfach mal ausprobieren
auf einer beliebigen Note,
die ihr gerade habt, dass da noch farblich hervorgehoben wird,
wer zuletzt welche Abschnitte mit seiner Farbe editiert hat und ähnliches,
also so ähnlich wie man das wirklich jetzt von Hatchdog oder sowas kennt,
also von einem vernünftigen Pet Programm, das kann jetzt plötzlich Notes.
Es ist nicht perfekt, wie vielleicht auch nicht zu erhoffen war.
Wir hatten jetzt hier im Vorfeld, hat Tim ein bisschen rumgetippt und bei mir
fängt dann sofort der Bildschirm an zu flackern, weil er irgendwie das,
wohin scrolle ich jetzt gerade, wenn oben neuer Text entsteht und ich bin aber
unten drunter und er kann nicht so wirklich berechnen, was passiert da gerade.
Also es ist noch längst nicht so rund wie beispielsweise im Hatchdog,
aber es ist schon mal wieder ein echt Riesensprung nach vorne in Bezug auf wir
bearbeiten gemeinsam einen Text hier auf dem Mac.
So jetzt sollten wir aber nochmal zu MacOS kommen bevor wir dann endlich zur
Vision Pro kommen, im Chat scharren schon alle die Hufe, zu Recht aber so sind
wir, es muss raus, was ich, wieso?
Bevor wir dieses Thema dann beleuchten weil ich möchte deine Läuterung erleben.
Hier geht's um Buchhaltung und das ist spannend.
IPadOS oder was ist das?
MacOS, iPadOS ist ja im Prinzip, es gibt Widgets und es gibt PDF.
Und es gibt eine Health App.
Es gibt immer noch keinen Calculator.
Also darüber müssen wir jetzt.
Ist so.
Und das nur weil sie beim allerersten iPad nicht mehr dazugekommen sind und
es dann nie gemacht haben.
Aber jetzt gibt's ja eine Sache, die wirklich, wo ich am Anfang nicht so richtig wusste,
was soll man davon halten, das ist das mit diesem Gaming und das war ja insofern spannend,
als dass das ja auch so ein bisschen die Prelude war, schon so dieser Aufheizer
in punkto Headset und sich alle gefragt haben so,
wird Apple zur Gaming Company, Spoiler nein, aber immerhin scheinen sie dann
doch etwas getan zu haben.
Und zwar haben sie ein, ja zwei Sachen, ne? Es gibt diesen Game Mode für den,
für macOS, das hab ich nicht ganz in Erinnerung.
Der Game Mode oder dieses, also was sie da quasi gezeigt haben,
ist im Prinzip ein Wine, also sprich ein Windows-Emulator, ähm,
mit, äh, den entsprechenden 3D-Frameworks, so DirectX-Gedöns dabei.
Und das Ganze läuft dann auf Rosetta. Das heißt, du kannst mit ein bisschen
Glück einige Spiele, so wie sie sind, unverändert direkt auf dem Mac spielen,
also jetzt auf der Beta, auf der aktuellen.
Allerdings bisher auch zu relativ
niedrigen Frameraten, weil dieses ganze Framework noch nicht soweit ist.
Grundsätzlich machen sie aber, und da geht's jetzt einen Schritt weiter,
das Framework, was sie da gebaut haben, ist so ein bisschen das,
was auch Steam gebaut hat für die Steam Deck und für dieses ganze Linux Gaming
ist im Prinzip ein Toolset,
um DirectX und andere Gaming 3D Frameworks quasi auf den Mac zu holen,
sodass wenn du als jemand,
der ein Game portieren will, das dann einfacher hast und nicht Metal machen
musst, sondern eben die anderen APIs benutzen kannst. Also so hab ich's zumindest verstanden.
Genau, es sind zwei unterschiedliche Geschichten. Das eine ist der Game-Mode,
das ist mehr so User-Facing-Geschichte, dass wenn du jetzt ein Spiel aufmachst,
der automatisch in Game-Mode geht.
Das heißt, das Spiel kriegt ein bisschen mehr Wumms als vorher vom System her.
Das ist im Endeffekt nicer als alles andere, also ganz grob gesprochen.
Und das andere ist eben, dass sie sehr wohl hergegangen sind und wirklich wohl
Crossover hat sich irgendwie bedankt,
auch wahrscheinlich wirklich bei Crossover ein bisschen Technologie eingekauft
haben und ein bisschen weitergetrieben haben,
dass einfach mal die Windows Binarys laufen, es ist, wenn man will,
aber eigentlich mehr gedacht als Entwicklermodus, nicht als Enduser-Modus an
der Stelle, um als Startpunkt für Ports zu agieren.
Es ist jetzt nicht so diese Geschichte, die das Steam Deck gemacht hat,
wirklich im Sinne und wir haben alle ...
Wir kümmern uns darum, dass die Spiele einfach mal laufen auf unserer Hardware-Plattform.
Nee, nee, nee, das macht Apple auch sicher nicht.
Aber es ist zumindest mal ein großer Schritt dahin, dass es vielleicht mehr
Ports gibt, die halt einfach mal laufen zumindest.
Ob die jetzt wirklich schön laufen, schnell laufen und besonders gut sind,
sei dahingestellt, weil ich meine, die eine Geschichte ist, im Mobile Space
sprechen wir ja schon eigentlich von ganz guter GPU-Leistung jetzt mit den M-Chips
und so weiter, im High-End-Gaming-Bereich natürlich noch nicht.
Und deshalb ist die Frage, okay, was passiert da? Ich glaube nicht,
dass es mehr Ports geben wird wirklich, weil das lohnt sich einfach nicht.
Der Mac-Markt ist nicht groß genug für die. Es wird mehr Ports geben im Sinne
von, mehr schlechte Ports wird es geben. Die Spieler werden halt eher laufen.
Und vielleicht geht Crossover den größeren Schritt auch noch und sagt,
okay, ich brauche jetzt nicht mehr so viel Handstand, bis das Zeug läuft.
Und dadurch, dass Apple mit im Spiel ist, läuft es vielleicht auch ordentlich.
Ich habe ein paar von den größeren Spielen mal mit Steam und der Crossover laufen
lassen wollen, wie der M1 so rauskam und da gab es halt schon immer wieder mal
Grafikglitches und die kannst du halt alle bei Software beheben eigentlich.
Also wenn du diesen Layer ordentlich machst, dann läuft es, dann ist es nur
potenziell langsam, aber laufen tut es.
Und es ist schon ein großer Schritt irgendwie, aber es ist jetzt auch nicht,
also die Welt wird sich auf Mac spieltechnisch nicht ändern, glaube ich.
Also zumindest nicht innerhalb der nächsten paar Monate, gar keine Frage.
Aber ich hab mir diverse Tests angeschaut, wo Leute irgendwelche Games,
die ich nicht kannte natürlich, gespielt haben und meinten,
Da wären teilweise signifikante Framerates bei rausgekommen einerseits und vor allem Stutter-free,
also sozusagen ohne solche Glitches, also sicherlich nicht alles,
aber sehr viel und auch top aktuelle Sachen insbesondere, weil sie ja damit
auch diese DirectX 12 API quasi mit bedienen, also was sozusagen das aktuelle
ist, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Ja, es gibt aber auch viele Games auf älteren DirectX-Versionen,
also da muss man mal gucken, was da passiert.
Bisher war sozusagen das neueste quasi noch überhaupt,
gab es überhaupt gar keine Optionen und Apple hat sich halt jetzt richtig reingesetzt
und in dieses existierende Framework ihre spezielle DirectX to Metal Translation reingebaut,
quasi um den Gaming Buden mal zu zeigen, guckt mal, schon ohne eine explizite
Anpassung kriegen wir diese Performance auf dieser Maschine hin.
Wenn ihr das anpasst, dann sieht es vielleicht noch besser aus.
Aber da muss ich jetzt kurz eingreifen, es ist nicht die Technologie von Apple,
sondern die haben sich tatsächlich ein paar Open Source Sachen gekrallt und
haben sie zum Laufen gekriegt, da ist wahrscheinlich noch viel Luft nach oben
was Optimierung anbelangt.
Genau aber sie haben explizit diese diese diese Anbindung gemacht und auch kontributiert,
wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ich will das jetzt gar nicht.
Es haben sich Leute beschwert, dass sie nicht kontributiert hätten,
aber vielleicht passiert das noch.
Ich hab's so gehört, dass sie es getan hätten. Egal, das ist nochmal eine andere
Diskussion, die können wir später noch haben.
Ist mir eigentlich auch egal, zeigt nur das Thema ist Apple nicht komplett egal,
weil sonst hätten sie diesen Aufwand natürlich nicht getrieben und man muss
mal schauen was bei rauskommt.
Es ist Crazy Country Apple in dem Regard, weil ich habe ja die Leute,
die die Hardware machen, also die Leute, die die GPUs machen und die Displays
machen und alles, was damit zu tun hat, was eigentlich geil für Spiele sein könnte.
Die haben immer so die Idee, dass man das bräuchte und man das macht,
aber irgendwie hat keiner die
Zügel in der Hand, wirklich mal in diesen Spielemarkt einzusteigen damit.
Und deshalb passiert halt immer so ein halbgarer Ding, der zu wenig ist.
Also ich glaube nicht daran, dass es den großen Wurf geben wird.
Ich glaube aber, dass die grundsätzliche Situation sich dadurch deutlich verbessert
und dass Steam sich nicht entgehen lassen wird, da ein bisschen mehr Support
für anzubieten, einfach automatisch auch, weil man einfach ein bisschen mehr Markt mitbekommt.
Wenn wir eh schon auf dem Mac sind, dann können wir auch ein bisschen die Leute
auch noch unterstützen und das noch helfen, dass das geht. Also da wird schon
ein bisschen was passieren dadurch.
Und grundsätzlich ist es natürlich so, dass Apple die richtige Entität ist,
die diesen Translation Layer schreibt.
Weil die können Metal einfach gescheit. Und die anderen halt nicht,
weil es halt nur ein Apple der Technologie ist. Wenn Apple es nicht macht,
dann wird es halt immer hier weiter rumgegurkt. Und jetzt wird zumindest für
eine Zeit lang dieser Translation Layer existieren.
Und den zu maintainen, glaube ich, ist einfacher als ihn überhaupt herzustellen.
Insofern ist es zumindest eine spannende Geschichte, dass es möglich ist.
Und deswegen, wenn jetzt die Trajectory so weitergeht,
also wenn das Apple eigene Silikon, Silizium, cool,
so viel weiter sich bewegt, wie es es gerade tut, dann wird es auch mal so sein,
dass die GPU auch mitstinken kann in irgendeiner Richtung.
Und dann wird es halt noch mal spannender und Kosten nutzen und andere Geräte
natürlich auch. Also es ist auf alle Fälle interessant.
Es ist mal der größte Schritt in die Richtung, den es jemals gab,
aber er ist immer noch keiner, der wirklich Spiele, die aktuell sind,
gleichzeitig releasen wird für sich alleine.
Ja, auf keinen Fall. Also ich glaube, das funktioniert auch nur,
wenn Apple da auch bei den Spieleentwicklern Geld einwirft.
Also ich meine, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr je Apple Arcade ausprobiert habt.
Das macht man irgendwie drei Monate, dann hat man die zwölf interessanten Spiele
gespielt und dann ist auch Feierabend, weil da ist halt auch Tumbleweed bei
Apple Arcade, meiner Meinung nach.
Ja also da ist echt nicht viel los das bringt nix und wenn Apple den Dienst
mal auf fordernde Mann bringen will dann müssen sie auch bei anderen Spielen
Buden Geld einwerfen und sagen portiert uns die Scheiße.
Gibt doch nur fünf Spiele.
Skip Skip Skip.
Nächstes Thema.
So wir können jetzt meiner Meinung nach nochmal kurz,
ne halt eine Kleinigkeit noch sie haben ja diesen Kojima da gezeigt,
diesen wirren Japaner mit seinem Spiel Death Stranding und dann dachte ich mir
das musst du dir mal angucken dann gab's das bei Steam gerade ein bisschen günstiger
allerdings bisher nur für Windows Und dann hab ich mir das angeguckt und hab
das mal eine Stunde gespielt und von dieser Stunde,
am Anfang waren gefühlt 60 bis 70 Prozent Cutscene,
das Ding hat wirklich ganz schön viel Story,
also wer, wer, Cutscene, also Dinge wo man nicht selber spielt,
sondern Story wo erzählt wird und sehr wirr, sehr komisch, aber auf jeden Fall
mal ein Spiel was man sich mal anguckt.
Das ist halt auch ultra alt, das ist wirklich so vor PS5-Launch kam das raus,
das kam noch zur PS4 raus und wurde für die PS5 dann noch optimist.
Also wir sind schon wirklich, das war mal so ein ganz spektakuläres Spiel und
ich hab das auch deutlich gerne gespielt, also das war cool,
weil das halt so eine andere Art von Spiel ist, aber es ist halt wirklich so,
es ist wieder so eine, oh da hat mal jemand ein Port gemacht von, ja.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, wenn das tatsächlich auf dem Mac ankommt und ich kann
das unter Steam einfach nur runterladen, dann werde ich mal gucken,
wie ist denn der Vergleich?
Läuft das tatsächlich ordentlich oder ähnlich gut? Playstation 4 2019.
Ah ja okay, naja das ist aber halt auch das Ding, dass sie halt auch kein,
kein, kein aktuelles Spiel gezeigt haben, das ist halt, das ist halt wirklich
so das, wo man sagt so okay, sie haben jetzt den Typen mit dem Jahre alten Spiel da, gezeigt, was.
Es ist ne wichtige Größe für Spiele, der Hideo Kojima, das ist schon so,
das ist so, das ist so ne Sony Größenordnung, so die eher von Mario Erfinder so, aber von Sony.
Das stelle ich ja nicht in Abrede, aber es ist halt auch kein Spiel,
wo du sagst, wir machen Spiele jetzt richtig, dann zeige ich halt nicht ein
vier Jahre altes Spiel, sondern was, was dieses Jahr erschienen ist.
Den Nachfolger der Apple Exclusive dann wäre beispielsweise.
Weiß ich nicht, so ein Jedi Survivor oder so ein Harry Potter,
wie heißt das neueste Spiel?
Das sind alles so Spiele, die Probleme haben auf 8 GB Grafikkarten zu laufen,
weil sie halt wirklich so viel Grafik haben, dass halt das nicht reicht,
eine 8 GB Grafikkarte zu haben.
Also so ein Spiel, wenn sie das gezeigt hätten, hätte ich gesagt Hut ab,
aber nichts, was so alt ist. Aber egal. Nächstes Thema.
Achja diese Games irgendwie, immer die müssen die Computer schon,
also wenn die ein Jahr alt sind dann kann man schon gar kein Spiel mehr spielen
hab ich immer so den Eindruck wann spielt man die denn überhaupt wenn man die
gar nicht mehr spielen kann.
Ich mach Konsole.
Man kann die schon spielen.
Ja mir ist das ein Rätsel alles diese ganze Game.
Nur nicht eben unter Ultra Grafikeinstellungen.
Spiel halt Minecraft, da machst du nichts falsch.
Tales of the Kingdom.
Sorry da eine Fott wäre eine Enttäuschung zu sein aber das Game was mich zieht
das muss erst noch geschrieben werden.
Du warst doch ganz groß drin hier bei diesem einem Handyspiel,
da warst du auch in Level 140 hinterher, also das hat's ja gegeben.
Casual Kram, ja aber das ist.
Was war das nochmal?
Ach da war mal irgendwas, aber das ist, ich versuche auch selber zu verstehen,
es ist ja auch nicht so ein Diss oder so, Ich verwundere mich ja selber,
warum mich Spiele meistens nicht interessieren.
Das hatten wir nur wirklich schon fünf mal. Lass das Thema wieder dann das nächste
Mal aufrollen, wenn Roddy oder ich mit einem coolen Spiel um die Ecke kommen.
Wenn das auf meinem Mac läuft.
Dann setz mich wieder auf die Couch und gucken was da schief läuft.
Bevor wir zur Vision Pro kommen vielleicht noch ein letztes Ding,
was nämlich Apple bei Safari gemacht hat, ist vielleicht noch der Erwähnung
wert, weil das sieht nämlich ganz interessant aus.
Abgesehen davon, dass Sie mal zusehen könnten, dass Safari auch noch benutzbar
ist, wenn mehr als 30 Tabs offen sind.
Haben sie erstmal ein Feature eingebaut, was es schon...
Ganz lange gibt, wie hieß das, wie hießen diese Programme, da gab es glaube
ich mehrere, mit denen man so stand alone aus einer Webseite eine App machen kann.
Hab vergessen wie das Tool hieß.
Vor 10 Jahren hat das mal begonnen.
Gute Idee das einzubauen und das dann auch gleich richtig zu machen so mit Cookie
Handling und pipapo, also wovon wir reden ist, man hat eine Webseite wo man
sich häufiger einloggt und die man eben benutzen will wie eine App.
Was auch immer eure Webseite der Wahl ist, beim einen mag es Facebook sein,
beim anderen keine Ahnung.
Es gab ja schon immer auf iOS so als Homescreen Icon exportieren,
das hat ja dieselbe Funktion gehabt mehr oder weniger und jetzt haben sie es
halt auch wieder auf dem Mac zurückgeholt und ein bisschen erweitert glaube
ich, so würde ich es mal nennen.
Also ich hab zum Beispiel mein Chat-GPT4 so laufend wunderbar.
Mit welchem Tool? Ach sie ist mit dem neuen.
Ich hab hier schon die Beton auf bei mir. Ja ich hab den.
Der feine Herr.
Sagen wir mal so ich hab halt das Schicksal als Arbeits Laptop ein Windows 10 fahren zu müssen.
Nein nicht auf meinem Mac sondern ich habe ein Windows Laptop,
ein PC Laptop für meine ganze tägliche Arbeit und kann es mir darum aber leisten
auf meinem Freizeitspaß Macbook Betas zu betreiben ohne dass ich damit meine
eigentliche Arbeit gefährde. Ach, it could be worse.
Naja aber darum habe ich jetzt also schon.
Ah du könntest einen Linus Desktop haben.
Oder Windows 11.
Aber ich hab gehört nächstes Jahr ist es soweit.
Nächstes Jahr ist Linus auf dem Desktop.
Ich hab dieses Jahr Linus auf dem Desktop mal wieder benutzt.
Mit funktionierenden Audio Treibern.
Es war schwierig mit dem Copy und Paste aber es wird es dauert nicht mehr lang.
Ja auf jeden Fall ich hab Sonoma, so heißt das ja,
die haben ja irgendwie der erste Name den man aussprechen kann,
finde ich nicht, finde ich schwierig, Sonoma, resoniert irgendwie nicht,
also diese Weinregion, hab ich seit irgendwie Tag eins halt drauf wo es irgendwie
verfügbar war und läuft gut, ich bin zufrieden damit.
Sieht es irgendwie anders aus?
Ne, ne sieht alles eigentlich aus wie vorhin.
Tätigst du es immer noch scheiße oder?
Du müsstest die Notch da oben jetzt wegdenken. Ach der Notch.
Nein aber Webapps super,
ich hab also drei oder vier gleich, das ist so ein bisschen wie das Auge hat
ja auch so einen blinden Fleck und so musst du einfach nur dein Gehirn darauf
trainieren, dass da oben halt irgendwo Void ist.
There is no notch.
There is no notch ja genau.
Aber ich habe jetzt hier Discord laufen als Webapp, ich habe Chat-GPT4 laufen,
weil ich da auf gar keine, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es eine offizielle App gibt,
ich glaube nicht, selbst wenn, würde ich sie nicht wollen an der Stelle.
Meine Masterwall 1.1 habe ich da laufen.
Es gibt eine Chat-GPT App auf iOS und mittlerweile auch auf iPad.
Aber auf MacOS glaube ich nicht oder läuft dann die iPad App?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man die installieren kann auf dem Mac.
Naja, aber da habe ich auf jeden Fall ganz gerne die Funktionalitäten einfach
der Webseite und habe ich das also bei mir als App in Anführungszeichen drauf.
Und das Schöne ist halt, dass es sich dann wirklich verhält wie jede andere
App auch. Also im Task-Switcher wird es vernünftig angezeigt,
das holt sich als Icon halt das VW-Con, was die Webseite mitbringt.
Und it just works. Das funktioniert also richtig gut. Was finde ich weniger
gut oder offensichtlich funktioniert, zumindest derzeit jetzt hier,
ich hab jetzt die Beta 2 drauf, ist dieses Profiles.
Schade.
Also auch innerhalb von Safari.
Also der Sinn von Profiles ist eigentlich, dass man häufig, also Leute die viel
mit Internet zu tun haben, kennen das Problem, ich habe irgendwie drei Logins
für einen und denselben Dienst. Also sagen wir jetzt irgendwie Mastodon, was auch immer.
Alles YouTube, jede Webseite.
Weil ich einfach verschiedene Personas von mir ein bisschen getrennt haben möchte
und unterschiedliche Use Cases habe.
Gerade bei Selbstständigen ein echtes Thema. Du hast immer irgendwie so ein
Business-Dranala genau.
Und der normale Weg immer ausloggen und wieder neu einloggen und hoffen,
dass One Password oder das macOS oder drei Browser benutzen,
das habe ich auch lange gemacht, ja, also einen Firefox und einen Chrome und einen Safari,
unter dem habe ich andere Login Cookies irgendwie am Laufen,
was ich dann zwischenzeitlich hatte,
was das Problem schon ganz gut gelöst hat, ist eine Firefox Extension,
die ich an der Stelle vielleicht doch auch einfach noch mal empfehlen kann,
das ist so ein Multi-Account-Containers, Ich muss mal gucken,
wie die offizielle hieß.
Da kannst du dann eben eine Anzahl von verschiedenen Personas quasi definieren
oder Arbeitsumgebungen und jede von denen bekommt dann halt einen eigenen Cookie-Space
und kannst dann halt deine Logins damit ganz gut trennen und separieren und
kannst jederzeit im Firefox hin und her schalten,
so mit welcher Domäne möchte ich jetzt gerade arbeiten hier.
Und meine Erwartungshaltung war, dass das jetzt eigentlich genau so bei Safari läuft.
Und grundsätzlich läuft es auch so. Du kannst also beliebig viele Personas dort
anlegen, aber irgendwie ist das Umschalten überhaupt nicht so,
wie ich es mir vorstellen würde.
Du hast jetzt also oben links so einen großen Button, wo auch irgendwie sowas
Umschaltmäßiges erscheint, aber da kannst du im Wesentlichen erstmal nur deine
bisherigen Tab-Gruppen, die ich gar nicht nutze, hin und her schalten.
Und wenn du jetzt zwischen deinen Personas hin und der schalten willst,
dann muss man noch mal in unter Menü rein oder sich in den kryptischen Vierfinger,
es sind wirklich Vierfinger, Shortcut merken.
Also das macht mir irgendwie den Eindruck, als hätten sie dieses Feature eigentlich
ausprogrammiert, aber auch nicht vernünftig in der GUI implementiert.
Es kann auch sein, dass das einfach in der frühen Beta liegt,
aber Vielleicht kommt das noch. Wundert mich ein bisschen.
Ja, weil das müsste front and center sein. Also ich hätte da einfach gerne so ein Icon im Browser.
Genau, du hast jetzt hier oben links, ich bin jetzt hier in der Arbeitsdomäne.
Jetzt möchte ich in die Freizeitdomäne, dann würde ich sagen,
klicke ich doch da drauf.
Ist aber nicht. Und dann musst du wieder ein New Window machen und musst dann
sagen hier Machine Learning. So und du kommst aber nie in die anderen vernünftig.
Ja sie haben es ja glaube ich genauso gemacht wie die Private Windows,
wie Private Browsing so an der Stelle. Du machst ja auch Private Browsing,
gehst du in den Modus und dann bist du im Private.
Also du kannst Fenster nicht umstellen, sondern du bist halt in anderen Unterbereichen vom Safari.
Du öffnest ein neues Fenster im neuen Modus, ne?
Also ich fürchte, dass diese etwas,
wie ich finde im Vergleich zu dem, wie es jetzt eben mit diesem Firefox Plugin realisiert ist,
diese etwas umständliche und quasi zu suchende Funktion dazu führt,
dass viel weniger Leute es am Ende nutzen werden, wenn es dann so bleibt,
als es eigentlich wünschenswert wäre, weil eigentlich ist das ein Killer Feature,
warum verstecken sie es oder warum machen sie es so umständlich?
Du bist ja Beta User, kannst jetzt die Feedback App aufmachen und sagen.
Ist in der großen schwarzen Nichtswolke.
Naja wenn keiner was sagt dann wird es natürlich so bleiben.
Ich schiebe einfach jetzt mal die Verantwortung auf dich.
Ja es ist ja nicht so dass das auf taube Ohren fallen würde.
Also mit den Entwicklern reden ist ja ein Lieblingshobby von mir und Github
rauf und runter schreiben.
Aber das ist halt ja ein altbekanntes Problem also ATP beraten sie da ja jede zweite Folge drüber.
Ja, mit Apple reden ist schwierig.
Mit Apple reden ist schwierig und dann habe ich da auch keinen Bock zu.
Ja, ja, das verstehe ich auch.
So, one more thing.
Ja sie haben one more thing gesagt und recht unspektakulär von der Art und Weise
wie er es gesagt hat oder?
Das hätte, das ist eine vertane Chance gewesen.
Ach für so, was soll er da noch so groß sagen, also.
Ja, das haben ja alle gewusst, dass es kommt.
Eben. Also das war klar, nicht so ganz klar war, was jetzt eigentlich wirklich kommt.
Und ich denke es ist jetzt erstmal sinnvoll, dass wir vielleicht erstmal kurz
abstecken, worum handelt es sich jetzt hier eigentlich bei diesem Produkt jetzt
mal nur so rein technisch.
Also wir haben halt ein Headset was technisch ein VR Headset ist,
das heißt es ist keine Brille wo man durchschaut oder so, sondern man schaut
auf Bildschirme, jedes Auge schaut natürlich auf einen eigenen Bildschirm.
Du hast noch nicht gesagt, dass wir jetzt über Division Pro reden.
Wir reden jetzt über Division Pro.
Nicht Division Standard.
Genau, das war vielleicht überhaupt schon mal die erste wichtige Botschaft,
dass das Ding Pro heißt und auch Pro ist und Pro bepreist es.
Von daher auch den Preis halt, genau. Pro wie Preis.
Das Ding macht man sich halt rüber, es ist relativ gut abgeschirmt,
besteht so aus mehreren Teilen die auch austauschbar sind,
da gehört das Band was hinten hält, das ist austauschbar,
Die Muffe, die genau die Muffe, ich hab gerade nach dem Wort gesucht,
das ist sehr gut, die Gesichtsmuffe, die Gesichtsmuffe ist auch anpassbar,
also überhaupt ist das Ding in vielerlei Hinsicht sehr konfigurierbar,
so auch was die Augen betrifft, das ist ja auch etwas was wir in der letzten
Sendung als Problem aufgezeigt haben,
also wir haben ja in der letzten Sendung im Prinzip formuliert,
Wenn das was werden sollte, dann müssten sie ja all diese Dinge berücksichtigen.
Und eine der Sachen ist halt Anpassungen zum Beispiel an deine Augen, also Brille.
Da gab es dann speziell Linsen mit verschiedenen Stärken.
Also es funktioniert so, dass du mit einer echten Brille hingehst,
die diese Brille scannen.
Also dort hat das so funktioniert, genau.
Also der Gedanke ist wohl nach allem, was man gehört hat, dass du die im Apple
Store abholst und dort deine Brille gescannt wirst,
vor Ort und dann halt ausgemessen wirst,
wie jetzt eben die Geometrie dieser Brille ist und dann bekommst du eine möglichst
dicht dran reichende Standardlinse von Zeiss, mit denen sie kooperieren an der
Stelle und die wird dann da quasi zusätzlich reingebaut zur normalen Optik der Vision Pro.
Wäre es nicht sinnvoller, wenn du mit deinem Brillenpass vom Optiker,
vom Augenarzt hingehst und sagst, das sind meine Werte, die möchte ich in der Brille haben.
Aber wahrscheinlich geht das in der Amiland nicht.
Vielleicht messen sie ja auch Dinge, die in diesem Brillenpass so nicht drinstehen.
Ja wenn die da nicht drinstehen, dann kann die Brille auch danach nicht gebaut werden vom Optiker.
Alles was wir wissen ist, so hat es dort auf dem Event stattgefunden,
wie das dann sein wird, wissen wir ja eh nicht, ist ja auch noch mindestens ein halbes Jahr hin.
Aber so funktioniert diese Brille, also Display linkes Auge,
Display rechtes Auge, für jedes Auge die Möglichkeit eine an dich,
an deinen Sehfehler angepasste Linse noch einzusetzen.
Es ist ein Lautsprecher verbaut, der nicht direkt im Ohr sitzt,
sondern in dein Ohr rein strahlt von außen.
Funktioniert da erstaunlich gut. Könnte man sich wundern, ob der Ton nicht zu
weit weg ist vom Ohr, aber ich würde auch sagen Ton ist eines der wenigsten.
Außerdem unterstützt uns natürlich die Airpods Pro.
Ja okay gut, aber das heißt ja, dass in der Konfiguration auch andere zuhören können, was da kommt.
So ein bisschen, aber es ist nicht so besonders laut. Also bei der Quest 2,
wenn du Leuten mal zuguckst, die das machen, das nervt nicht super,
weil es schon irgendwie Richtung Ohr strahlt. Also es ist schon für dich gemachtes
Audio, aber es ist halt so, es ist wie so ein offener Kopfhörer so ein bisschen.
Genau, ein On-Ear Kopfhörer. Also nicht Over-Ear, sondern On-Ear Kopfhörer.
Das ist so die Lautstärke Ecke.
Aber es deckt ja nicht wirklich das Ohr ab.
Irgendwie ist es gerichteter Schall, aber das kriegen sie schon. Ja.
Okay, gut, so ist es auf jeden Fall.
Und das ist soweit, sagen wir mal, der vielleicht etwas weniger überraschende Teil gewesen.
Also dass sie das so mit den Linsen so gemacht haben, ist gut,
ist wichtig, ist richtig, hätten sie es nicht gemacht, wäre es ein Fail gewesen,
weil dann hätte man irgendwie eine Brille darunter ziehen müssen und da wäre
das Produkt für mich schon durchgefallen.
Aber was sie dann noch zusätzlich gemacht haben und was sie glaube ich jetzt
von allen anderen Ansätzen,
die bisher so auf dem Markt zu sein scheinen, abhebt, ist,
dass sie natürlich auch noch nach vorne ein Display haben und auch wenn glaube ich,
dass der Moment war, wo alle so dachten, so uuh, creepy, ich war auch so mit
so anderen Entwicklern, haben wir gemeinsam in den Keynote geschaut und das
war wirklich so der Moment, wo sich alle so gegenseitig anschauten und so.
Really?
Das war schon Uncanny Valley Royal, also das war… Das haben sie dann ja auch…
Sehr, sehr viele dystopische Momente in dieser Produktvorstellung, finde ich.
Und ich weiß nicht, wie viel davon wirklich ist, ob es in live nicht so schlimm
ist, aber so die Art und Weise, wie es präsentiert wurde und gemacht wurde,
da habe ich schon öfter die Idee gehabt, das ist jetzt eine Coldmirror Folge
anstatt eine Produktpräsentation.
Also vielleicht kurz, was die Idee dahinter ist. Also man hat halt...
Ja genau, technisch mal beschreiben, was da ist.
Also man hat vor... eigentlich ist die Brille ja geschlossen und zu.
Sie versuchen aber den Eindruck zu erwecken, als dass sie auf Wunsch quasi eine offene Skibrille wäre.
Und dazu haben sie ein Display verbaut, was nicht vorne quasi die LEDs drin
hat, sondern durch ein irgendwie noch nicht näher spezifiziertes Linsensystem
quasi so ein bisschen hologrammmäßig das Bild weiter nach hinten erscheinen lässt.
Und dann scannen sie oder fotografieren sie oder filmen sie von innen die Augen
ab und machen eine 3D-Modellierung des angeblichen Gesichtes und auch wo die Augen hingucken.
Sodass man also so eine vage Illusion hat. Plötzlich würde die Brille vorne durchsichtig.
Ich habe aber in der Tat kein Video und kein Screenshot gesehen auf dem ja,
also Uncanny Valley ist genau das richtige Stichwort.
Also etwas ist schon recht gut, Aber es ist so zwischen Zeichentrick und real,
dass es irgendwie sehr unangenehm wirkt und das fand ich dabei auch,
ich finde es sieht richtig schlimm aus und sie haben es dann bei der Hands-On
Demo kein einziges Mal gezeigt.
Also niemand hat das bisher in Aktion gesehen, warum auch bisher schon gemutmaßt
wird, sie haben es noch nicht fertig und sie wissen es ist noch nicht so richtig
geil und hoffen, dass sie es in einem halben Jahr noch besser hinkriegen.
Genau, also das Display ist, was du da meinst,
was sie da verbaut haben, also das ist ein lenticular Display und das funktioniert
im Prinzip genauso wie diese,
weißt du noch diese Wackelbilder, also du hast im Prinzip ein,
jetzt weiß ich nicht ob ich die richtigen Begriffe mache, aber wenn du sozusagen
von einem bestimmten Winkel schaust, dann siehst du quasi,
Immer eine bestimmte Zeile, das heißt auf diesem Display was in dem Teil drin
ist, hast du quasi für jeden Pixel mehrere Spalten.
Haben sie das spezifiziert irgendwie?
Interviews drüber gesprochen worden, dass es so funktioniert.
Ich weiß nicht genau wie fein das aufgeteilt ist, sagen wir mal du hast jetzt
20 verschiedene Blickrichtungen sozusagen und benutzt 20 Spaltenpixel quasi
um eine bestimmte Blickrichtung zu machen.
Das heißt sie rendern tatsächlich das Bild da vorne nicht einmal,
sondern N-mal für verschiedene Blickwinkel und wenn du halt aus diesem Blickwinkel schaust,
sorgt eben diese Umlenkung dafür, dass du auch nur genau dieses eine Bild siehst,
obwohl das Disney quasi so 20 verschiedene Bilder gleichzeitig anzeigt.
Und das ist so ein Ding, wo ich mir dachte so okay wow, damit hab ich wirklich nicht gerechnet.
Also nicht, dass sie das überhaupt machen und dann auch in dieser,
weil damit lösen sie mehrere Probleme auf einmal. Das ist wirklich cool.
Und das ist schon so das erste Moment wo ich mir dachte so,
ok ihr meint es also wirklich ernst mit dem Teil,
das muss ich euch jetzt mal zugestehen,
weil dazu kommen ja jetzt noch, um vielleicht mal die technische Aufzählung zu vervollständigen,
Eine ganze Batterie an Kameras ich weiß nicht genau wie viele da drin sind 8,
12 oder sowas in der Größenordnung hab ich jetzt im Kopf weiß nicht weiß das jemand genauer,
egal der Chat wahrscheinlich auf jeden Fall sie scannen halt alles sie scannen
natürlich den Raum verschiedenste Perspektiven nach oben nach unten links und
rechts einfach damit du in dem AR Modus,
dass sie ja dieses Headset primär positionieren.
Eigentlich, du setzt dir das Ding auf und sollst angeblich...
Den raum so sehen wie du ihn sonst auch sie also ich glaube niemand hat behauptet
dass sie keinen unterschied gemerkt haben aber alle haben gesagt sie sehen keine
pixel und damit wäre der nächste haken gesetzt also wenn sie es wirklich schaffen
dass man keine pixel sieht.
Also es geht also ich habe zwei zwei reviews verlinkt dass du auch in der blickwinkel
so breit ist irgendwie 140 160 grad.
Verlinkte heißt sowas in den Chat schmeißen ne?
Achso ja das tue ich in Italien von Daring Fireball.
Sonst ist nichts verlinkt.
Da dem anderen aus dem, also zwei Leuten denen ich zutrauen würde,
dass sie genau auf sowas angemessen achten und die haben also beide konsistent
geschrieben, man sieht keine Begrenzung, keine Ränder.
Die müssen ja nie scharf sein und die müssen nie perfekt sein,
das wissen wir ja auch, das menschliche Auge ist sehr sehr auf einen engen Fokus
eigentlich in der Mitte konzentriert, Aber es ist schon schön,
wenn man drum rum überall zumindest
vage eine Anmutung hat, was da ist und das scheint es umzusetzen.
Und ich habe auch gehört wirklich, dass es keinen Unterschied im Blick fällt
und keinen Unterschied in der Verzerrung.
Das ist das Wichtige, glaube ich, auch wenn du schon mal so ein Pass-Through
aufgesetzt hast von der Quest 2 oder auch von den Besseren.
Da hast du halt immer so ein bisschen so eine Verzerrung in dem Ganzen drin.
Das ist zwar schon so grob so, aber schon allein davon wird dir schlecht.
Also das ist, glaube ich, schon wichtig zu sehen,
oder ich glaube Ihnen das auch,
und das ist, glaube ich, auch, warum es was Besonderes ist, dass es Apple macht an der Stelle,
dass sie den Teil wirklich so gemacht haben, als wäre das zum Durchgucken,
so, und dass sie das wirklich geschafft haben, so, in beide Richtungen,
und das ist so eine, das ist schon technisch, macht ein anderes Spiel draus,
finde ich, eine ganz andere Nummer.
Also in der Tat, all das was man vorher so an Checkmarks hatte,
so sie eigentlich damit das ganze irgendwie mal auf den Next Level kommt,
müsste XYZ, das haben sie relativ radikal würde ich sagen abgehakt.
Auflösung 23 Megapixel, das heißt also 4K pro Auge, das heißt also auch da ein
Begriff Retina, also die Leute sehen keine Pixel.
Ich hab mich gewundert warum sie ausgerechnet jetzt nicht von Retina auflösen,
ich meine jetzt wäre es ja mal wirklich angemessen gewesen.
Vielleicht wollen sie noch eine Auflösungsstufe in der Hinterhand haben.
Naja gut, also niemand hat gesagt, dass Pixel als solche zu sehen gewesen seien,
das ist ja im Prinzip die Definition davon.
Zusätzlich zu den Kameras gibt es dann aber auch noch Sensoriken bzw.
Diese quasi ihre Variante der, wie heißt die, Depth Kamera im iPhone,
also mit dem sie quasi dreidimensional abtasten.
Field of Depth oder so ähnlich. Depth of Field. Irgendwie sowas. Genau.
Also Infrarot, Pixel etc. Also wie man auch Face ID erkennt,
um halt einfach auch die Umgebung abzutasten.
Oder war es sogar Lidar? Ich glaube es war sogar Lidar.
Und das Face, was sie dann auf dem Display anzeigen.
Also du scannst ja dein Gesicht damit.
Genau. Also im Prinzip eine dreidimensionale Abtastung in Echtzeit,
um dann eben auch Tischflächen, Wände etc.
Zu erkennen. Also im Prinzip genau das, was Sie jetzt über Jahre mit Ihrem AR
Toolkit so Schritt für Schritt entwickelt haben, dass es dann eben so ausgereift,
dass Sie eben den Raum nicht nur sehen,
machen können sondern eben auch in seiner Struktur erfassen
und damit halt in der Lage sind auch Dinge korrekt zu
platzieren auf der einen Seite aber eben auch Lichteffekte zu berücksichtigen
sie nehmen zur Kenntnis wie das Lighting ist und wenn halt jetzt ein Fenster
oder irgendein anderes Objekt in diese dreidimensionale Szene virtuell platziert
wird dann übernimmt es halt dann auch eben das Licht der Umgebung was auch nochmal zu zeigen ist.
Das auch übernehmen. Also das, was dann in den Entwickler-Workshops wohl rauskam,
ist, dass man daraus dann auch als App-Entwickler keinen Einfluss hat.
Das heißt also, du kannst dann deinem Spiel oder deinem Browser-Window oder sowas nicht sagen,
so, du bekommst jetzt mal dieses Lightning-Theme mit,
sondern der Hauptaugenmerk ist, also das hat man vielleicht noch gar nicht gesagt,
diese ganze Konstruktion mit den vielen Kameras ist hauptsächlich dafür da,
dass das grundsätzlich als Augmented-Reality-System gedacht ist.
Das heißt, du sollst nicht in einer komplett virtuellen Welt versinken,
sondern du sitzt in deinem, das kannst du auch, kommen wir gleich noch zu,
wo und wie, mit welchen Einschränkungen, sondern du sitzt in deinem normalen
Zimmer und kannst das erweitern durch beliebige digitale Elemente.
Ich gucke jetzt an die Decke und da habe ich, oder ich liege nachts im Bett,
gucke an die Decke und habe da meinen Film laufen und gucke noch irgendwie eine Folge Grey's Anatomy.
So, also das ist der eigentliche Gedanke davon, so den Raum,
in dem man in echt sitzt, ganz normal zu sehen und beliebig digital Genau und
dann hat man noch dieses Rädchen an der Seite, mit dem man sozusagen diesen
Grad der Immersion einstellen kann. Sehr coole Idee das Hardware zu machen.
Absolut und auch sozusagen so als Primary User Interface Element,
also quasi so eine große Crown wie an der Uhr.
Zum Drehen drehe ich das nach vorne, hinten,
keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich nach hinten würde ich jetzt mal sagen,
wenn ich es nach hinten drehe, dann, also nach hinten im Sinne von auf der rechten
Seite platziert gegen den Uhrzeigersinn, ist für mich jetzt nach hinten, Dann...
Verschwindet das Kamerabild des Raumes und wird in zunehmendem Maße durch eine
künstliche Szenerie deiner Wahl ersetzt.
Das kann einfach nur schwarz sein, das kann irgendwie ein Hintergrundbild sein,
irgendeine dreidimensionale Szenerie, Bäume, Wälder, keine Ahnung.
Und dann eben zusätzlich noch diese Objekte, die du siehst. Und diese DEVDS Kamera, bzw.
Dieses Leader, taugt dann eben auch noch für die Erkennung anderer Menschen,
die sich dir nähern. Und das ist der nächste Knackpunkt, wo ich sage,
okay, alles klar, ja, hab da mal so richtig drüber nachgedacht,
weil das war ja so dieses Problem.
Also so ein Headset, du setzt es auf, du verschwindest da drin und du verlierst
den Kontakt und rennst in Dinge rein und vor allem Leute rennen in dich rein
und du weißt nicht da steht jetzt irgendjemand vor dir,
nimmst die Kamera ab und hast auf einmal ein Gesicht vor dir.
Super scary. Du willst es die ganze Zeit abnehmen, aber ich denke,
wenn sie das richtig hinbekommen und das war ja so ein bisschen so dieses Flugbegleiter Beispiel, ne.
Sitzt im Flugzeug guckst den Film an und dann wirst du halt irgendwie angesprochen
mit wollen sie noch irgendwas haben und dir gibt's Abendessen.
Und die Stewardess ragt so in dein Bild quasi rein.
Genau.
Auch ein bisschen scary.
Aber besser als anders so. Also das ist schon irre.
Also da ist an viel gearbeitet worden.
Dann hast du nochmal die die hardware technisch dass wir das mal bis zu ende
führen also wir hatten glaube ich noch nicht eindeutig und deutlich erwähnt
i tracking ist wirklich super genau noch an der stelle nach innen gerichtet um zu genau zu sehen,
wie die wie die augen drauf sind dann hat das ding natürlich schon auch in irgendwem
mit dem mit dem ziel darüber die navigation zu machen den ganz wichtigen teilen
das heißt also du point ist auch wie bei der quest zwei mit dem finger irgendwo
hin beispielsweise sondern du guckst etwas an und klickst dann mit deinen händen
zusammen und hast den button aus.
Genau, ich wollte bei den Hardware-Features bleiben, erst bevor wir in der Richtung sind,
weil was mir noch gefehlt hat an der Stelle ist, irgendwo braucht das Ding auch noch Strom,
der Strom ist nicht im Kopf, sondern der hängt wirklich irgendwo unten rum mit so einem Kabel,
mit so einem Schnur, dass man sich so an die Seite einsteckt,
das wohl nicht MagSafe ist, schon ein bisschen fester, aber schon auch wirklich so ein Kabel,
das man sich irgendwie mit Batteriepack umhängt, irgendwo reintut,
wie groß das genau ist, hat jetzt noch keiner gesagt an der Stelle,
habe ich noch nicht gesehen, ist wahrscheinlich noch nicht so final auch.
Hosentaschen groß.
Ich glaube sie sagten was von zwei Stunden Batterielaufzeit.
Das war die andere Geschichte genau zwei Stunden Batterielaufzeit,
das finde ich noch ein wichtiges Hardware Eckdatum, das wir noch nicht erwähnt haben.
Man kann es aber auch direkt an die Steckdose anschließen, also man muss es
nicht mit der Batterie betreiben, sondern man kann es einfach quasi USB-C mäßig
irgendwo anpluggen, wenn man am Schreibtisch sitzt.
Und was noch fehlte bei der Hardware war die Kamera nach unten,
die die Hand filmt, mit der man dann Gesten auslösen kann.
Also nicht nur nach unten, du kannst die Hand auch oben halten,
aber sie gucken auch richtig steil nach unten, damit du eben auch so vor deinem
Körper mit dem Finger rumspielen kannst.
Damit du die Hände nicht die ganze Zeit hoch halten musst.
Falls du mal in so einer Situation bist, wo du mit deinen Fingern nah an deinem Körper.
Also die Idee ist wirklich, dass du den kompletten Bereich deiner Arme scannen
kannst mehr oder weniger und auch erwischst,
dass du, egal wo du deine Hände hast, dass sie das erkennen können,
wo deine Hände sind und die dadurch auch Gesten erkennen können.
Ich glaube das ist so das wichtigste.
Werden denn die Arme auch reingerendert, wenn man jetzt selber seine Hand vor
dem Display hin und her macht.
Das habe ich nämlich nirgendwo erwähnt gesehen. Also ob sozusagen auch der eigene
Körper einem selbst auch noch reingerendert wird. Also ich meine,
wenn schon meine Augen für andere Leute gerendert werden, dann können sie ja auch noch meine Hände.
Gleich mit reinrennen oder oder ist das dann sozusagen wirkungslos?
War nicht klar aber ich meine wenn die Kamera die aufnimmt.
Also das ist ein guter Punkt, müssten, müssen, die sind ja dann im 3D, sind ja eh da ja stimmt.
Das haben sie wahrscheinlich noch nicht so weit. Haben sie nicht so richtig
gezeigt aber müssen sie eigentlich.
Wobei das dann eine Sache ist, dass beispielsweise auch die Quest 2 schon super
hinkriegt, also wenn du da den Controller in der Hand hältst und die dann in
der Zeit geländert werden, das geht schon.
Wenn wir jetzt in die Diskussion einsteigen wollen,
ich habe mir die Quest ja wieder mal rausgenommen, so diese absolute Stabilität
im Raum und diese absolute,
ich weiß genau wo der Hand ist, mit dem Unterschied zu, es ist ungefähr so grob
da, wo du jetzt gerade bist und es fühlt sich ganz okay an, das ist,
glaube ich, die Weltunterschiede, ich bin so heiß auf dieses Gerät,
weil ich würde gerne sehen, haben sie es wirklich geschafft.
Weil alles, was ich bisher hatte,
ist genau immer so ein bisschen an Kenny noch, so ein bisschen schräg.
Der Controller geht zwar relativ gut, wo ich bin, aber er ist halt nicht so genau da.
Und wenn ich jetzt in so einem Quest 2 auf den Knopf drücken soll mit meinem Controller,
und wirklich so physikalisch in einer dieser Video-Apps geht es halt so,
dass man den Controller an der linken Hand irgendwie hat und an der rechten
Controller auf die linke Hand so zuführt und dann so einen Play-Knopf drücken
soll, wirklich um eine Play zu machen.
Da macht man nicht irgendeinen Knopf auf den Kontrolle, sondern man drückt den
und das war schon zum Kotzen.
Und ich hoffe halt, dass dadurch, dass A, Sie überhaupt keine Kontrolle haben,
sondern Gesten und Augen, plus alles super stabil im Raum, keine Veränderung
außenrum, reinrendern, rausrendern, alles gut gemacht, dass dadurch eine ganz
andere Art von Interaktion entsteht, die wirklich ...
Wirklich ein anderes Computing aufmacht an der Stelle,
das ist wirklich so, das ist die nächste, das ist einfach eine andere Art,
das ist ein Computer zum durchgucken, that's it, mir wurscht,
was es ansonsten noch so kann, aber das ist ein Bedienparadigma,
das es wert ist, Bedienparadigma genannt zu werden und nicht irgendwelche komischen
Controller, die ich mit Avataren vor einem Sackerberg rumhopfen lasse.
Und ich glaube, ich bin echt scharf drauf und finde es schade,
dass das jetzt erst in einem halben Jahr, dass man da rankommt,
oder in einem Jahr, weil ich will halt wissen, ob sie es geschafft haben.
Und wenn sie es geschafft haben, dann ist es geil, glaube ich.
Auch wenn es vielleicht jetzt in der ersten Iteration noch zu schwer,
zu wenig Batterielaufzeit, sonst irgendwas hat.
Aber wenn sie das Bedienkonzept hinbekommen haben und das Interaktionskonzept
zusammen mit anderen Leuten,
mit einblenden, ausblenden und man kann durchgucken und es ist jetzt ein bisschen
creepy, aber es ist absehbar, dass es nicht mehr creepy bleibt,
so, dann ist es halt echt eine geile Nummer, so.
Was mir bei der ersten Präsentation auch auffiel, ist vor allem,
was sie alles nicht gezeigt haben.
Also alle Personen saßen oder standen, niemand hat sich bewegt.
Und es gab nie welche mit zwei, also zwei Personen mit einem Headset in einem Raum.
Doch der Typ in dem Büro hatte, der sich nicht wenigstens, der ist zu dem Schreibtisch
hingelaufen glaube ich.
Der hat sich bewegt, aber er war auch alleine in dem Büro.
Ne, die anderen auch, aber er war alleine mit dem Headset. Die anderen Leute
waren auch, aber die hatten keins auf.
Also ich sag nicht sie waren jetzt alle festgenagelt auf dem Boden aber es war
jetzt sagen wir mal generell einerseits nicht sehr viel Bewegung selbst also
die Leute haben sich nicht aktiv irgendwo hingegeben.
Die Kamera hat sich immer viel bewegt ja die flog die ganze Zeit in alle möglichen Rotationen.
Und aber auch der Content war relativ statisch, also man sah immer den Raum
statisch, die Leute sind jetzt nicht...
Du hast keine Games gesehen, wo man irgendwo lang fliegt und so weiter.
Alles so Dinge, die nicht drin waren. Und mein erster Gedanke nach der Genote
war so, okay, jetzt haben sie es zwar nicht Reality OS, sondern Vision OS genannt,
aber mein Eindruck war erstmal so, dass es jetzt so Isolation OS ist.
Also du bist jetzt sozusagen so dein Betriebssystem für die totale Isolation.
Du alleine in deinem Wohnzimmer, du alleine in deinem Hotelzimmer,
du bist allein und was tust du jetzt? Setz dir sozusagen diese Brille auf,
um dich von deiner Isolation zu befreien.
Aber auf der anderen Seite haben sie natürlich einen Punkt,
dass sie damit ja auch aufzeigen,
so ein bisschen wie mit Podcasts, wo du quasi tote Bewegungen nutzen konntest,
so in der Bahn, spazieren gehen, also immer wenn du nichts Produktives tun kannst,
kannst du Kopfhörer aufsetzen, kannst du Podcasts hören.
Und hier wiederum kannst du sozusagen so tote Momente,
so Reise, Flugzeug, eben das Hotelzimmer in der fernen Stadt,
wo du dann abends so alleine rum bist und dann vielleicht mal den Fernseher
anschaltest, auf einmal kannst du das irgendwie alles nutzen und vor allem,
du schaffst auch eine Privatsphäre.
An orten wo es eigentlich keine gibt
also gerade so in der bahn oder im flugzeug oder so jetzt an geheimen dokumenten
arbeiten oder sachen die jetzt keiner sehen will ja also jetzt nicht unbedingt
porno aber es gibt auch so andere sachen die ich mir dann auf dem bildschirm
zaubern könnte wo ich mir denke so da will ich jetzt noch nicht mal dass da
jetzt irgendjemand quer drauf guckt weil das verstehen die nicht.
Also ganz einfaches Szenario, irgendeine Netflix Serie die ab 18 ist,
was weiß ich Witcher oder sowas.
So guck ich nicht in der Bahn, weil ich weiß da laufen kleine Kinder vorbei
und die gucken bei mir auf meinen schönen großen 14 Zoll Laptop und die sollen
nicht sehen wie da irgendwelche Köpfe rollen.
Ja okay genau, so hast du es schön gerettet jetzt mein Argument.
Und bis jederzeit.
Tritt dein Porno aus. Zurück zu Pornos.
Ja aber ich mein das war natürlich auch Teil der Erzählung, uns ein Gefühl zu
geben, was sie sich jetzt eigentlich darunter vorstellen unter Spatial Computing.
Und jetzt kommen wir vielleicht schon so ein bisschen zu diesem wofür es gemacht,
was haben sie jetzt eigentlich im Sinn und dann will ich auch nochmal kurz auf
die letzte Sendung und vor allem unsere Interaktion mit dem Chat.
Da kamen ja dann so Ideen mit, ich meinte ja immer so, keine Ahnung wofür man
das benutzen soll. Dann kam so der Chat und meinte so, naja du könntest ja dein
Macintosh als Bildschirm benutzen. Und ich mir dachte so, Leute das kann doch kein Feature sein.
Ist es aber.
Könnte sein, dass es das doch ist, genau. Weil sie das mit der Auflösung hinbekommen haben,
weil ich hab jetzt von allen, wir haben es ja nicht gesehen,
aber Leute die das benutzt haben meinten,
es würde dann so sein, ich kann mir das kaum vorstellen, aber es sei so als
würde man auf ein 4K Bildschirm schauen und dann halt auch die Details erkennen
und die Schrift wäre scharf.
Und beliebig viele davon, das heißt also man muss sich immer wieder so ein bisschen
klar machen, ich hatte immer dieses Problem so wie soll ich dann darauf tippen
oder wie soll ich dann da mit dem Trackpad arbeiten oder sowas.
So und das Problem ist das Problem gibt es einfach gar nichts und ich habe vor
mir mein normales Laptop stehen wie jetzt auch, dahinter kann ich drei 4K Monitore mir hinstellen.
Stopp!
Kannst du nicht!
Sie haben gesagt du kannst einen Bildschirm, einen virtuellen 4K Bildschirm
von deinem Mac spiegeln, mehr geht nicht.
Lass es die nächste Generation sein.
Der Rest sind dann eingebaute Apps.
Aber sie haben ganz ganz viele Videos in denen sie irgendwie vier,
fünf Screens sonstwo verteilen im Raum.
Ich hab jetzt extra einen Macbook Pro gekauft mit dem man drei Bildschirme anschließen
kann und der weg geht's nicht.
Der Punkt auf den ich will ist ein anderer. Dadurch, dass aber diese ganze Kameratechnik so gut ist,
siehst du ja deine eigenen Hände ganz normal auf deiner normalen Tastatur davor
und du siehst deine Hände ganz normal auf dem Trackpad und mit denen steuerst
du dann einfach deinen virtuellen im Raum hängenden neuen 4K Monitor.
Das heißt du hast überhaupt gar kein Input Problem an der Stelle,
sondern du siehst ja den selben Input wie sonst auch, nur dass da halt kein
echter Monitor steht, sondern halt ein virtueller Monitor in der Luft.
Das wird funktionieren, ich bin mir da ziemlich sicher. Und dann brauchst du
nämlich auch kein runtergespecktes, der kann da nicht so viel oder sowas sein,
das ist halt einfach dein ganz normal erweiterter Computerscreen an der Stelle.
Ja, aber das geht natürlich dem ganzen ein bisschen konträr dazu,
dass sie plötzlich ein komplettes Betriebssystem für das Ding vorstellen,
wo du halt Apps drauf laufen lassen kannst, ne.
Also ich habe ja vorhin von der Ladefuchs App gesprochen und ich habe,
als das SDK für die Vision Pro dann verfügbar war, habe ich einfach das runtergeladen,
habe gesagt, hier, Target Vision Pro, angeworfen, bam, funktionierte.
Also ich musste nix machen, das hatte halt einfach das Ding für die Vision Pro
kompiliert und dann konnte man das in dem Vision Pro Simulator,
konnte man sich das angucken und konnte da also das Fenster dann entsprechend in diesen…
Da könntest du mal einen Screenshot von irgendwo hinwerfen.
Genau, ich, ich, ich.
Wäre PR-technisch für eure zweier Version, läuft schon auf der Vision Pro.
Lass mich mal fertig reden. Das Ding war,
dass du also plötzlich hast ein IOS-mäßiges, aber im Vision Pro-Universum funktionierendes
Gerät, auf dem du dann arbeitest.
Einziges Problem war, mein MacBook wurde unglaublich heiß, weil er irgendwie diese,
Diesen Simulator, die ganze Grafik, die er da rechnen musste,
das hat ihn glaube ich ein bisschen überlastet.
Aber es blieb flüssig und man konnte, das fand ich das lustigste,
mir ist es gelungen, den Playstation Controller anzuschließen und dann kann
man tatsächlich mit dem Playstation Controller in dem Simulator dann irgendwie
im Raum hin und her und dann ist es so ein bisschen erträglicher mit wo gucke
ich jetzt hin und wie weit bin ich von irgendwas weg.
Aber lasst uns von da doch nochmal kurz zurückgehen, wie denn überhaupt das
Bedienkonzept aussieht, für die, die jetzt noch nicht so genau hingeguckt haben.
Also was die Idee ist, wenn man jetzt das als Standalone-Rechen hat,
also da hast du jetzt gerade, wir hätten gerade, wenn man einen Computerrechner spiegeln will,
dann kann man den Computereingabemethoden weiter benutzen von dem Computer,
aber wenn man es jetzt praktisch als Standalone-Gerät benutzt,
Dann ist die Idee, dass du in deinem normalen Umgebung Fenster oder Volumen
platzierst von den Apps.
Das heißt, das Konzept von einem Fenster bleibt auch wieder ein Konzept von
einem Fenster, aber steht halt dreidimensional im Raum und blendet sich so ein
bisschen eben lichtmäßig an die Stelle.
Du kannst dich das Ding bewegen, indem du drauf guckst.
Dann gibt es so Hoverstates außenrum wie bei den Fenstern. Ansonsten,
so wie wenn du mit der Maus irgendwo am Fenster entlang fährst,
hast du ja die kleinen Pfeile zum Vergrößern und Verkleinern und so weiter.
Und es gibt ein paar Stellen, wo du hingucken kannst an diesen im Raum stehenden Fenstern.
Und dann siehst du da Bedienelemente, die so ein bisschen größer werden und
benutzen kannst. Man kann es im Raum verändern, indem du mit dem Finger pinscht,
praktisch mit irgendwelcher Hand.
Was zusammendrückst, und dann kannst du es wegbewegen, so ganz normal,
wenn du den Arm im Raum bewegst.
Und du kannst es vergrößern und verkleinern. Das heißt, du kannst praktisch
mit den eingebauten Apps dir in dem Raum, in dem du bist, beliebig viele Fenster,
so wie ich es jetzt verstanden habe, auch irgendwo hinstellen.
Da gibt es dann so ein Safari-Fenster, das dann ein bisschen von der Größe her
in den Videos immer so aussieht, als wäre es so ein bisschen mobile.
Ja, also auch wenn der Text alles scharf und toll ist und du vielleicht nicht
so genau gucken kannst, Von dem, was du so an Fensterinhalt siehst,
ist es ungefähr so, weiß ich nicht, halb so groß wie auf einem Laptop,
so ungefähr von der Größe her, iPad-Size, ist so eine ganz gute Ecke.
Das heißt, die normalen Apps, die du da drinnen benutzt, die machen dann ein
Fenster in den Raum auf und dann benutzt du die in dem Fenster in dem Raum,
in dem du guckst und mit deinen Fingern ein bisschen klickst,
mehr oder weniger. Das heißt, die initiale Position hast du immer mit den Augen,
das geht wohl super schnell und macht Spaß.
Und dann klickst du mit deinen Fingern und machst mit den Händen,
interagierst irgendwie und kannst es schieben und pinchen und alles,
was du eh schon so gewohnt bist interaktiv mit viel oder wenig Handbewegung.
Das soll alles angeblich ganz gut funktionieren.
Und wenn du eben so eine App hast, die es schon gibt, dann mach die,
wenn du sie nicht anpasst, mehr oder weniger so eine iPad-App-Fenster auf auch.
Und wenn du es so anpasst, wie du es schon gemacht hast, dann ist es ein bisschen
transparenter und ein bisschen mehr drin.
Ist es dann auch so, dass das Fenster flexibler und resizable ist an der Stelle?
Weil die iPad-Apps sind irgendwie mehr oder weniger iPad-Form,
aber hochkant und quer und so.
Also die App, also die Ladefuchs App war glaube ich nicht resizable,
wenn ich mich recht erinnere. Ich müsste das jetzt, oder warte ich kann das
ja nochmal anwerfen hier.
Also um kurz in die Pause rein zu gerätscheln, was ich mich aber eben bei dieser
Form der Interaktion frage ist, wie macht man dort beispielsweise eine Texteingabe,
weil das Hamse, glaube ich, nicht gezeigt hat.
Und wirklich virtuelle Texttastatur, die du irgendwie mit den Augen und den
Fingern auch klippen kannst, wenn du willst. Und natürlich Siri und Voice kannst
du praktisch machen, indem du aufs Eingabefeld guckst und dann einfach sprichst.
Also das sind so ein paar Interaktionspattern, die würde ich halt gerne live
erleben, auch wie gut die funktionieren.
Dadurch, dass es Apple gemacht hat und es wirklich so von dem im Simulator schon
so aussieht, als könnte das ganz knorkelfunktionieren, freue ich mich drauf.
Aber so bei Facebook hätte ich Angst so ungefähr. Also das ist so,
weil das ist das, was Apple kann.
Und vor allem das Eye-Tracking finde ich super interessant, weil ich hab mal
die Gelegenheit gehabt, so Eye-Tracking Dinge, die jetzt praktisch nur so Third-Party
an einem Rechner waren, auszuprobieren von Leuten, die das ausprobieren.
Und es war immer zu nervig und zu intrusive irgendwie.
Und ich glaube, das haben sie aber gut gemacht, so wie sie es gemacht haben.
Weil diese Kombination aus, du hast mehr so einen Hover-State,
der relativ privat ist auch, also den auch die, zum Beispiel,
Webseiten nicht mitbekommen, weil das wäre auch ein bisschen creepy,
wenn die alle deine Bewegungspattern gleich erkennen wollen würden,
aber die halt das System weiß.
Und dann kann das super schnell reagieren. Und wenn man dann nur ein bisschen
tippen muss und dann wieder mit den Händen die feineren Bewegungen macht,
ich glaube, das könnte super funktionieren. Ich will das so ausprobieren.
Ja, aber ob es beispielsweise eben exakt genug ist, um sagen wir mal jetzt in
einem Fleece-Text einen Cursor zu positionieren mit den Augen.
Du meinst, weil das Bios schon nicht geht?
Weil das ist ja schon so ein Szenario, du hast was rein diktiert und du hast
da jetzt irgendwie zwei Tipps drin und die willst du jetzt korrigieren.
Also dazu habe ich gehört, dass es sehr viel genauer sein soll.
Weil du einfach mit dem Auge, bist du einfach nochmal schärfer,
ich meine du guckst ja irgendwo hin, um dann da deinen Cursor mit der Maus hinzuschieben.
Jetzt guckst du nur noch hin.
Also das ist sozusagen schneller und genauer unter Umständen.
Also so wie ich es gehört habe.
Und das wäre mega.
Ich kann mir das vorstellen, aber das wäre awesome, ja.
Und ich meine, wir sind jetzt in der Größenordnung, wir haben ja den Preis noch
nicht gesagt, oder? Dreieinhalbtausend? So haben sie es so?
Ach, Details.
Und das ist ein interessanter Punkt, weil es ist einerseits arschteuer,
aber für das, was es kann, gerade eigentlich auch günstig, so gefühlt.
Für das, was Apple normalerweise in der Produktkategorie macht,
ist es halt so ein bisschen eine schwierige Geschichte. Ich weiß,
ich würde es gerne haben, ich würde es gerne ausprobieren, weil ich will vielleicht
mal was dafür entwickeln oder so.
Aber für den Normaleinsatz ist es halt eigentlich so eine Preisklasse zu teuer
und es ist das erste Produkt, es ist bestimmt in einem Jahr schon wieder veraltet und so.
Ich weiß nicht, wie sie den Einstieg in den Markt dann schaffen irgendwann mal.
Aber ja, es ist auf alle Fälle...
343 Max der war halt auch bei uns da auf der Couch zur Keynote und wir haben
die Keynote halt auf unserem schönen neuen 77 Zoll LG OLED Display geguckt und dann bei den
3500 ging das große Heulen und Zähne klappern los.
Und dann fragte Max aber so ganz tiefenentspannt du sag mal Ralf was hat nochmal
genau dein Fernseher da vorne eigentlich gekostet? So der hat halt auch zweieinhalb
tausend gekostet so das ist eben nicht mehr Größenordnung davon entfernt und
der kann halt auch nur 4K.
Also das ist natürlich grundsätzlich eine Geschichte, die man so für alleine
für Consumer Elektronik,
muss nur in irgendeinen Mediamarkt oder Saturn gehen,
da ist das ja schon das Mittelfeld, nur was Tim eben sagt mit der Vereinzelungsanlage,
du kannst dann halt nur alleine diesen Film gucken und nicht mit deiner ganzen
Familie und das ist schon noch irgendwie so ein Punkt,
die haben nie gezeigt, dass mehrere Leute gleichzeitig die Teile in einem Raum
anhaben, wie verhält sich das dann eigentlich, was sehe ich von den anderen
da Und so als Familiendevice ist es, außer dass ich dann in 3D die Kindergeburtstag filmen kann.
Wir hatten eine Firmensituation, wo mehrere, in der Keynote oder in dem nachträglich
gebrachten Film, den gibt's ja auch noch.
Aber nicht interagiert haben, also die haben glaube ich keinen virtuellen Spacecraft
in irgendeiner Form, das ist glaube ich nämlich noch ein ganz spannendes Thema,
das ist ja einfach noch nicht gelöst. Das kannst du immer vergessen,
dass das schon geht in guter Art und Weise.
Was ich halt ein bisschen schwieriger finde ist, gut,
ich hab jetzt, da drüber haben sie nicht groß geredet, aber sie nennen es ein
Progerät und dann ist da aber eigentlich ein iOS drauf.
Also weiß ich nicht, ich persönlich bin ja kein großer Fan des Terminals,
aber ein Pro-Gerät muss ein Terminal haben, weil sonst ist kein Pro-Gerät.
Also für mich ist das iPhone Pro kein Pro-Gerät und für mich ist das iPad Pro
auch kein Pro-Gerät, weil es ist einfach als Tool nicht offen genug und ich
kann nicht alles damit machen, was ich mit einem Pro-Gerät machen möchte.
Also wir haben bei der Hardware ja ein bisschen die CPU Geschichten übersprungen.
Also drin steckt eine normale M2 plus ein neu entwickelter R1 Chip,
der für die ganze Kamera Analyse um Berechnung der ganzen visuellen Komponenten
und so weiter zuständig ist,
damit da quasi die M2 nicht noch irgendwie mit seinen GPUs dran muss,
aber das ist quasi normale Number Crunching von ich berechne jetzt irgendwie
eine 3D Fläche und mach ein Lightning drüber.
Und ähnliches. Das passiert auf einem Standard M2, also kein M2 Pro Ultra, sondern Standard M2.
Das haben sie so gesagt, genau.
So und das ist natürlich grundsätzlich ein maximal veritabler Computer.
Ja natürlich. Und ob und wie sie dafür dann irgendwas Konsolenmäßiges machen, who knows.
Ja ja schon, nur meine Argumentation war jetzt wieder an der Stelle,
wenn ich ein Pro-Gerät habe, dann brauche ich dafür Pro-Software.
Und pro Software kann ich nur dann haben, wenn die Leute,
die solche Software machen, auch ein Geschäftsmodell haben, mit dem sie über
einen längeren Planungszeitraum Planungssicherheit haben und wissen,
dass sie damit Geld verdienen können.
Und wenn das im Prinzip auch nur
ein 3D-iOS ist und sie da einen völlig zugerammelten App-Store mitliefern,
dann sehe ich das noch nicht, dass das irgendwie, dass sich da ein Third-Party-Universum erschließt,
wo ich sage, okay, ich kaufe jetzt ein Gerät für dreieinhalbtausend Euro,
um damit was anderes zu tun, als Filme anzugucken.
Und sie haben halt auch sehr wenig echte 3D-Applikationen gezeigt.
Das meiste waren eben eindrucksvoll irgendwo im Raum stehende 2D-Screens am Ende des Tages.
Und auch ihre eigene GUI, die ist so ein bisschen extrudiert,
da hängen die einzelnen Logo-Elemente immer so ein bisschen auf verschiedenen Ebenen.
Aber man hat nicht den Eindruck, dass es, sie kommen ja mit Spatial Computing
jetzt so als neuem Kernbegriff, dass sie schon so eine echte Idee haben,
wie man jetzt diese dritte Dimension auch GUI-technisch wirklich ausspielen will.
Da bin ich einer anderen Meinung. Ich glaube, das ist eine absichtliche Einschränkung der Ebene,
damit man eben so dieses grundsätzliche Bedienparadigma macht,
weil die Apps selber können Volumen machen, können überall was hinmachen,
aber du musst ja vereinfachen, du musst ja in irgendeiner Form ein Bedienschema
überhaupt mal machen, mit dem du in dieser Welt arbeitest.
Und halt Fenster kennen die Leute und ein bisschen vereinfachtere Fenster,
man kann sie wenigstens beliebig positionieren, ist schon mal eine ganz gute
Geschichte und damit kann man anfangen.
Und dann ist die Frage, okay, wenn wir jetzt die freieren Apps machen,
die sie ja vorsehen, technisch auf alle Fälle für die Entwickler,
jetzt auch schon, die man irgendwo im Raum positionieren kann,
die auch irgendwie in ihrem Volumen arbeiten können, dann wird es wieder was anderes.
Aber dass das Hauptbetriebssystem was einfacher hat, eine einfache Metapher,
die ja wieder jeder neue Benutzer und Benutzerin ordentlich verstehen kann schon
am Anfang, finde ich super wichtig und eine sehr, sehr gute Auswahl.
Auch, dass das Window-Chrome ganz wenig ist, weil das Auge ja einen automatischen Hover macht.
Das ist zum ersten Mal, dass es mich nicht nervt, dass Dinge nur erscheinen,
wenn du drüber haberst, Weil für das Auge ist es super, für die Mauszeiger ist
es ein Dreck, aber für das Auge
ist es großartig, wenn die UI erst dann erscheint, wenn ich da hingucke.
Also deswegen, ich glaube, das ist eine bewusste Entscheidung, die sehr, sehr, sehr viel Entwicklungspower schon gebraucht hat und wirklich bewusste Entscheidungen sind in so einer Menge.
Und vor allem das Produkt ist ja noch gar nicht da. Es ist ja jetzt erst mal die Präsentation gewesen für Entwickler und was sie erst mal vermitteln mussten ist quasi ihre Vision, haha, für Vision. Also sie mussten sagen was ist es, wie stellen wir uns vor, wie man es benutzt, wie man damit interagiert, wie man Dinge steuert und dann gehen sie natürlich erst mal von dem aus was da ist.
Gesten hat nie so richtig irgendwie mal so funktioniert, das haben viele probiert.
Das ist jetzt das Ding. Jetzt soll deine Hand in irgendeiner Form hier wirklich alles machen.
Du sollst da zupfen und klicken und so weiter können. Und auch wenn das auf
den ersten Blick so ein bisschen weird aussieht, ist es halt wie dieser Handy in der Straßenbahn.
Ja vor allen Dingen die Augen, also die Hand, also der Gedanke ist eigentlich
eher, deine Hand ist da wo sie gerade ist, entspannt auf der Fuß,
auf der Sessellehne und die Hauptarbeit machen deine Augen.
Und die Hand ist nur der zusätzliche Trigger, statt irgendwie blinzeln,
wäre ja auch irgendwie eine Alternative gewesen, also wir haben halt gesagt,
nee, wir machen quasi eben, die einzige Handgeste die man braucht ist irgendwie
Finger zusammenklappen und das nehmen wir auf und alles andere macht das Auge.
Bewegung dann auch. Also die Hand bewegt schon das Zeug, das macht nicht das
Auge dann. Das Auge wählt aus und dann übernehmen die Hände.
Das ist so, wie ich die Interaktion verstanden habe in dem Video.
Ja und das drag and drop mal richtig.
Ja also und, und, und.
Das ist halt in 3D immer so ein bisschen schwierig, wenn man das in so ein paar
Interfaces schon mal probiert hat, ne?
Also so links, rechts ist schon klar, aber nach hinten, da musst du dann schon
gucken, so wie übersetzt du dann jetzt 10 Zentimeter, die sich deine Hand bewegt,
vor dir der Raum ist aber 10 Meter, wie viel verschiebst du das dann?
Ich glaube, dass sie genau den Teil schon sehr gut im Griff haben.
Ich glaube, das ist nix, wo sie irgendwie noch viel Experimente brauchen grundsätzlich.
Haben da den Basisteil, den haben sie im Griff. Und das ist schon mal die Welt,
finde ich, weil das ist dann ein Bedienparadigma einfach.
Das ist wie beim iPhone, also genau der Teil, den ich geil finde an der neuen
Technologie, wenn sie ein Bedienparadigma gut gemacht haben.
Inertia-Scrolling beim iPhone und direkt Multitouch. Und das hier aber im Raum
mit ohne Controller in gut. Hoffentlich.
Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, was wird jetzt entstehen?
Also ich erinnere mich noch sehr, Dom und da hatten wir ja eine gemeinsame Geschichte,
als das iPhone rauskam und der App Store sich angekündigt hat.
Ihr wart ja damals mit Coding Monkeys auch eine der ersten, die überhaupt schon
eine App gemacht haben und vielleicht kannst du mal in die Zeit kurz zurückkehren,
weil ich weiß noch, dass wir uns darüber unterhalten haben.
Ihr kamt von der WWDC zurück und habt auf dem Flug zurück schon heftig diskutiert,
was ist es eigentlich, wie man mit diesen Telefonen arbeiten will.
Das war ja im Prinzip ein vergleichbarer Moment, wo so ein komplett neues Interaktionsmodell,
Multitouch, das Display, alles nur noch mit den Fingern, keine sonstigen Stifte etc.
Das war ja quasi so die Prämisse und dann habt ihr darüber nachgedacht und was
war das nochmal so eine Verleih, wem hab ich was verliehen App oder sowas.
Ja, so eine Kleinigkeit, die hat auch nicht so gut funktioniert,
aber von der Idee her hat es ganz gut gefallen, weil wir es ausprobieren konnten
da was mitzumachen, also ein Foto von was machen, also man hat halt alle Features
von diesem Gerät so benutzt.
Aber es war wirklich, also der Bereich war halt irgendwie sehr groß,
was man machen hätte können wollen so ungefähr, aber man wusste nicht so genau,
was man jetzt dafür umsetzen würde.
Ich finde, interessanterweise bei der Brille habe ich jetzt weniger,
da habe ich eher so das Gefühl, okay, ich will eine App dafür machen,
also habe ich eine Idee, wie ich es machen würde, glaube ich, ist es nicht?
Da hat das viel weniger als beim Telefon das Problem, überlegen was.
Ich habe ja auch schon zwei Dinge, die ich unbedingt machen wollen würde,
aber man muss halt die Interaktion begreifen, ich kann es halt nicht ins Blaue hinein machen.
Also wirklich eine App zu machen, die in einem Fenster funktioniert,
ohne zu wissen, wie jetzt die coole Interaktion funktioniert,
finde ich da viel schwieriger, als es beim Telefon war.
Ja, also was ich beim Telefon damals, waren die Einschränkungen sehr groß,
das hab ich damals so empfunden, dass du hattest halt kein Background irgendwas,
du hattest irgendwie, die App wurde immer abgeschossen,
wenn sie in den Hintergrund ging und so, also das war schon so ein bisschen
eingeschränkt und letzten Endes hat sich halt auch diese ganz große Klasse an
Apps durchgesetzt, die im Prinzip nichts anderes sind als eine glorifizierte Webseite.
Also du benutzt irgendeinen Dienst in diesem Internet und hast dafür eine schönere
UI, als wenn du es jetzt im Browser machen würdest.
Genau. Das war aber gar nicht so schlecht, weil das war so wirklich so der Gedanke,
okay, dieses Ding hat einen Interaktionsmodus, der ein bisschen anders ist als
so eine Webseite und den unterstützen wir voll und das ist die App fertig.
Mehr braucht es ja nicht für eine Sache. Das war schon eine spannende Geschichte.
Eine ganz andere Zeit als jetzt, wo du schon mit 27.000 Frameworks beballert
wirst und alles mögliche machen kannst.
Ein iPod, ein Handy, ein Internet-Kommunikations-Device, Breakthrough.
Apropos, ist da eine Musik-App?
Also in der Art und Weise, wie sie jetzt einem die Möglichkeiten geben,
in diesem Space zu arbeiten, schränken sie einen ja schon ziemlich ein,
wie der Rotti am Anfang schon gesagt hat, glaube ich, oder Ralf,
dass wenn du ein Fenster irgendwo hinstellst, dann wird es halt beleuchtet von
der Umgebung, weil die Umgebungsein- und Ausschaltnummer ist zentral,
die ist nicht jetzt von der App selber bewusst.
Wenn du die Augen erkennen können willst, kannst du das eigentlich nicht,
außer du hast special permissions an irgendeiner Stelle.
Du musst dich halt ins System einfügen, for better or for worse,
wenn du Beleuchtung haben willst.
So wie ich das verstanden habe ist es sogar so, dass du als App Entwickler die
Kontrolle über das Rendering vollständig abgeben musst. Du kannst das gar nicht mehr beeinflussen.
Du bist sozusagen in dem ganzen wie es letzten Endes aussieht vollständig überlässig
mit dem Betriebssystem. Und das ist natürlich auch eine interessante weitere
Abstraktionsebene die Apple damit erreicht für ihre App Developer.
Man kennt das ja schon, man will ja eigentlich immer konsistente Apps haben
und es ging immer ein Weg drumherum und nirgends wo ist es so krass wie auf
Mac, AppKit, da kannst du halt alles machen, das ist ja auch so ein bisschen Vorteil der Plattform.
Du als User willst konsistente Apps haben.
Die meisten Product Owner sind der Meinung, dass Apple ja gar nicht weiß,
wie es richtig geht und nur sie die Wahrheit verpachtet haben und wollen dann,
dass die Entwickler sonst was bauen und du denkst dir nur so, oh Gott.
Genau, aber jetzt wird die Wahrheit nicht verpachtet, jetzt wird sie sozusagen
einfach nur noch kurzfristig vermietet und die...
Es macht den Eindruck, dass quasi in diesem Environment, wenn man dort programmieren
will, man sich dann wirklich dem User Interface Paradigma komplett ausliefern
muss, weil sonst funktioniert das auch nicht.
Da gehören ja auch noch diese ganzen Sachen dazu,
die wir gar nicht angesprochen haben, wie Privacy, weil wenn alles Eye Tracking ist,
hast du natürlich auf einmal eine ganz andere Informationslage und sie sagen
halt, deine Apps kriegen halt keine Informationen darüber, wo der User hinguckt,
bevor er mit irgendetwas interagiert.
Das ist natürlich auch schade, weil es natürlich eine bestimmte Kategorie,
eine interessante Kategorie von Apps von vornherein erstmal ausschließt,
weil das kann ja sein, dass genau das sozusagen das Interessante ist,
dein Spiel mit dem du wirklich nur durch die Gegend guckst und damit irgendwas
durch die Luft feuerst ohne die ganze Zeit mit den Fingern schnipsen zu müssen,
also aber sie sehen das zumindest sofort, also das Ding ist voll mit Restriktionen,
darauf will ich eigentlich hinaus.
Ja, also momentan sieht es ja noch so aus, dass das, also zumindest dann,
wenn du eine App mit Fenstern hast, dann ist die auch erstmal nicht anders als
das, was auf iOS passiert.
Sieht ein bisschen anders aus, aber die Frameworks sind erstmal die gleichen.
Du machst ein Fenster auf, du machst einen Dialog auf, du, keine Ahnung,
du gehst auf einen Browser und dann öffnet sich der Browser und der Browser
sieht im Prinzip auch nicht viel anders aus als bei iOS.
Interessant wird's natürlich dann, wenn du in diese 3D-Welt kommst,
wo du dreidimensionale Objekte hast. Das hab ich noch nicht so ganz ein Gefühl
dafür, wie das bitte funktionieren soll.
Aber wenn du dir zum Beispiel anguckst, wie die Settings App aussieht,
das sieht halt total aus wie die Settings App auf iOS und inzwischen auch macOS.
Wir haben ja letztes Jahr, letztes Mal gerantet.
Ja also zu Tims Punkt nochmal mit der Privacy zurück.
Ich glaube wo sie wirklich totale Paranoia vorhaben ist, dass sie in irgend
so ein Glasshole Ding wieder reinkommen.
Ja also wir erinnern uns Google Glasses, diese Brille die man halt mit so einem
halbtransparenten Display über einem Auge hatte und wo man also auch diverse
Informationslayer reinblenden konnte und wo aber eben auch eine Kamera verbaut
war und irgendjemand hat dann dieses Wort Glasshole in die Welt geworfen und
von da ab war dieses Produkt komplett tot.
Das heißt also, dass jetzt Apple von Tag 0 an sagt, hier Privacy ganz,
ganz wichtig und alles ist on device und da haben sie ja eine gewisse Street
Credibility, muss man ja mal sagen.
Das glaubt man denen an der Stelle auch. Was ich mich dann aber im Nachhinein
gefragt habe, das eigentliche Glasshole-Problem haben sie aber nicht angesprochen.
Das heißt, sie zeigen ja, wie ich meinen Kindergeburtstag in 3D mit dem Headset filmen
mit allen Details und das dann als super immersive, da denke ich immer an hier
diesen einen Film, na wie heißt das, wo man seine ganzen Erinnerungen speichern
und hinterher wieder, Robin Williams?
Strange Days, ja unbedingt angucken.
Kenn ich gerne, Irrer Film. Oh ja, krasser Science Fiction.
So ein exakt das haben wir jetzt, dass ich jetzt also eben meine Erinnerungen
aufnehmen, speichern und voll immersiv wieder abrufen kann und was genau hindert
mich das jetzt daran, das eben dann in der U-Bahn zu tun mit meiner Umgebung.
Die anderen Menschen.
Wer sehen das ja aber nicht wirklich, ob ich gerade was aufzeichne.
Ich habe da jetzt kein großes Rekordleuchte gesehen.
Ich meine, da gab es was. Ich weiß aber jetzt nicht mehr genau was.
Also das war eins meiner dystopischen Momente in dem Video, vor allem auch wenn
der Vater nämlich in seiner Geburtstagssituation dieses Ding auf hat und nicht
dieses von wegen, Du bist hinter der Kamera und bist nicht Teil des Erlebnisses.
Die Idee von Apple ist, dass du dadurch, dass du die Augen siehst und so,
dass das ja so eine durchlässige Erfahrung ist, aber im Moment ist es noch überhaupt
nicht so mit diesem riesen Ding da dran und ich finde das,
das fand ich echt creepy dann, nur damit du es aufnimmst, bist du dann in dem
Moment, wo die Kerzen ausgepustet wird, mit dem Ding am Start.
Und zwar als dein Hauptgegenüber.
Ja, aber das ist eine reine Gewöhnungssache.
Ja eben, ich will mich daran gewöhnen. Moment,
kurz, nicht im Sinne von gewöhn dich an die Unterjochung,
das meine ich nicht, sondern das ist so ein bisschen vergleichbar mit dem Aufkommen von Videorekordern.
Was waren die ersten Videorekorder? Das waren so riesige, klobige VHS-Kassettenteile,
also bevor es dann auch noch die kleineren Systeme gab, so Hi8 und sowas.
Vorher war glaube ich, also schon immer war eine Kamera, erinnere dich mal,
wie Kameras angefangen haben, das waren sowieso so scheunengroße Kisten,
mit denen du durch die Gegend nicht mal laufen konntest, sondern die so fest
aufgebockt waren und dann sukzessive immer wieder kleiner wurden.
Diese Situation war dann schon immer explizit, jetzt Aufnahme.
Und genau das ist das, was du in der Situation auch hast. Das heißt,
wir haben das so gesehen in dem Film mit, oh die Kinder werden jetzt hier so
von diesen Aliens beobachtet und gleich fressen sie auf.
Nee, das ist sozusagen, die Kinder wissen ganz genau, Papa setzt jetzt die tolle
Kamera auf und dann können wir uns das danach anschauen.
Also das ist wahrscheinlich überhaupt nicht kriegbar. Sondern ganz im Gegenteil,
da stellen sich alle noch extra auf und ziehen sich noch mal ein sauberes Hemd
an, damit irgendwie diese Erinnerung ist und mal ehrlich, wenn du eh weißt,
jetzt passiert gleich was verdammt irre tolles,
Wo es nur einmal ist, weil Taylor Swift Konzerte und alle haben so ein Teil auf, weißt du?
Nee, aber keine Ahnung, Feuerwerk, Silvester und dann schaust du dir das nochmal
so total immersiv wieder an.
Das ist halt auch krass. Also es ist einfach ein krasses Recording,
was du für bestimmte Momente haben möchtest. Ich glaube nicht,
dass das jetzt ein Hauptgrund ist, diese Kamera zu kaufen.
Aber ich glaube, das ist definitiv etwas, was alle sofort mal ausprobieren werden.
Und wenn das nur so halbwegs so gut rüberkommt danach, wie man es so normalerweise
sieht, dann wird es echt interessant.
Vorsicht, Vorsicht, Phones werden nur noch über Kameras verkauft.
Also da mit der Vorhersage wäre ich vorsichtig.
Am Anfang meinte ich.
Also was ich da sagen wollte, es hat sich für mich ein bisschen auch gedreht
im Laufe der Zeit jetzt von seit der Keynote gucken. Also beim Keynote gucken
war das eine meiner dystopischen Geschichten. Der Vater soll das nicht so machen und das ist blöd.
In der Art und Weise, wie es zum Beispiel Craig und wie heißt der andere gleich
nochmal, in der Talkshow dann beschrieben haben, ist es schon ein bisschen weicher geworden.
Weil wenn du so ein bisschen so diese Idee von, das ist halt so ein Family Recording,
so wie du es jetzt auch wieder beschrieben hast, weil sich die Leute schon freuen
drauf und dann hat man halt diese geile Erinnerung, die man gerne hätte,
die man angucken kann, so auch in der Geschichte und dann hat es was, hat es was Positives.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wo ich da lande. Emotional war das auf alle Fälle in dem
Promo-Video ein massiver Downer, wo ich mir gedacht habe, so totale Ablehnung
in mir an der Stelle für diesen Anwendungsfall.
Ich verstehe es, man will es dafür auch hernehmen.
Aber das war trotzdem so die Bauchreaktion, die sich mit der Zeit gewandelt
hat, also, und die sich auch wandeln wird, je weniger creepy diese Dinger sind, so in Summe, ja, also.
Also ich sehe ja noch ein technisches Problem, weil beim Abspielen dann einer
solchen 3D-Immersionserinnerung hast du selber dann ja keine Kontrolle mehr
über die Kamerabewegung,
sondern du sitzt dann ja vermutlich oder stehst und vor dir läuft und bewegst
sich aber gleichzeitig durch so einen 3D-Film durch.
Das heißt, die ganzen Tricks, die ich ihnen abnehme, dass es gut funktioniert,
mit irgendwie alles schnell gerechnet und so weiter, an der Stelle werden sie,
glaube ich, an eine natürliche physikalische Grenze kommen.
Ich vermute, dass sie es so lösen, dass du eben nicht dann ein 180-Grad-Immersions-Video
daraus machst, sondern dass es das vor dir auf so eine 3D-Leinwand projiziert wird.
Das also quasi ist, als ob du den 3D-Film anguckst auf einer Leinwand,
aber nicht, als ob du wirklich nochmal in dem Moment wirklich drinnen bist.
Das haben sie beschrieben, also sie haben es beschrieben und sie haben es beschrieben,
als wäre das so ein bisschen so Harry Potter-Style in das Bild dann eintauchen, ein bisschen.
Aber schon, dass du passiv bist dabei dann. Also du gehst praktisch,
das kommt so, das ist so eine Erinnerung, wie so,
wie so, wie so einen, hast du das bei Harry Potter im Kopf noch,
wie diese Silberfäden so aus dem… Genau, so haben sie es gemacht von der Idee
her auch, haben es beschrieben, wie sie es gemeint haben.
Das heißt, du kommst in so ein Unschärfes und dann bist du da in so einem,
nicht in einer Leinwand, aber ein bisschen in so einem Schaukasten,
aber der trotzdem, du bist trotzdem drin.
Also es ist jetzt nicht einfach nur der 3D-Film, es ist viel mehr als das,
aber es hat irgendwie genug Fuzzy Render oder sowas, dass du weißt, es ist eine Erinnerung.
Also sie haben es Erinnerungen dann auch genannt. Ich bin gespannt wie das aussieht,
ich glaube das muss man erleben, das kriegst du halt nicht in einem Video.
Ja, aber das ist Apples App. Du wirst natürlich voll immersiv aufnehmen können
und voll immersiv abspielen können. Also alles andere wäre ja...
Nee, die Rückseite hast du ja.
Also das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Also du hast da schon Grenzen, die Rückseite hast du ja nicht von der...
Wie die Rückseite?
Du hast die Rückseite von deinem Hint nicht an der Stelle, deshalb kannst du nicht außen rumlaufen.
Rumlaufen.
Tim ich glaube das nicht und sie haben es auch nicht gezeigt.
Ich glaube du hast immer eben so eine Grenze,
die dich selber nochmal in deiner anderen Welt verankert, damit dir nicht schwindelig
wird, weil sonst fangen die Leute wirklich sofort an zu kotzen,
weil das ist das Hauptproblem, dass deine Augen eine ganz andere Lage Informationen
bekommt als dir dein Restkörper vermittelt, vor allem dein Innenohren.
Gut, wir werden es sehen, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass es nicht auch die Möglichkeit gibt, weil soweit ich das verstanden habe,
dieses SDK bietet deiner App ja sowieso so fünf verschiedene Basisbetriebsmodi
an und eine davon ist halt Full Immersion und da kannst du ja alles machen.
Da ist auch meine Frage, wie haben sie das umgesetzt? Wir haben in der letzten
Sendung ja so ein paar Use Cases mal ersponnen, die es haben könnte.
Und eine der Punkte, die ich ja gemacht hatte, war so dieses Sehnsuchtsorte.
Das heißt also ich möchte irgendwo jetzt arbeiten, an einem Ort,
der mir besonders am Herzen liegt und mit dem ich besonders viel verbinde,
was weiß ich, irgendein Rooftop in New York, die Meta-Ebene, whatever, ja.
Aber nur wenn sie aufgeräumt ist.
Und Apple ist jetzt bekanntlich hingegangen und hat eigenes Kamera Equipment
entwickelt, um so eine 360 Grad Immersions Setting filmen und aufnehmen zu können.
Aber so wie ich es verstehe, ist es dann an der Stelle eben auch nur ein Film.
Das heißt also, du sitzt dann zwar irgendwie auf einer Bergkuppe und es ist
alles 3D und es ist alles geil, aber ich kann eben nicht vernünftig einen Meter
nach links gehen und es verschiebt sich.
Sondern du bist halt in einem 3D 360 Grad Film drin.
In einem Panorama. In so einem 3D Panorama, wo ich mich auch frage,
sind sie da auch noch den Schritt weiter gegangen und machen so eine 3D Simulation, zumindest von
5 Quadratmetern am Boden, dass man so ein bisschen nach links und rechts und
alles verschiebt sich perspektivisch exakt, weil sie genug 3D Information haben.
Das wird glaube ich ganz spannend.
Immersion heißt für mich ja nur ohne weiteren Chrome. Das ist das was ich sage.
Also wenn du mit der Kamera etwas aufnimmst, dann kannst du das genauso ohne
dass du irgendeinen Chrome dazu bekommst.
Abspielen.
Das funktioniert gut wenn du beim Film deinen Kopf komplett still hältst.
Das funktioniert nicht, wenn ich beim Kindergeburtstag den Kindern hinterher laufe zum Kuchen.
Es wird eine Menge Content geben, der nicht funktioniert und die Leute werden
Bungee Jumping damit machen und alles mögliche und YouTube wird voll davon sein,
meine neue Vision Pro, hier habe ich mich vom Wolkenkratzer gestürzt,
jetzt fliege ich mal im Jet mit und so weiter, Zugfahrten durch deutschland
mit der vision pro also das werden wir alles sehen und.
Ja aber welches welches Format hat denn das was da da rauskommt was du damit fändest?
Die haben ein eigenes Video Format dafür entwickelt.
Also es ist im Prinzip ein 3D Relief mit Textur.
Unklar. Also ein anderes Szenario was wir besprochen hatten oder was was ich
mir gewünscht hatte war ja live Events.
Damit irgendwie aufzeichnen und erlebbar machen ja also bei union auf der tribüne
sitzen und das haben sie drei sekunden lang gezeigt aber auch nicht länger.
Basketball.
Und dieser basketball geschichte ich hab sie gerade mal in den chat reingeworfen
wo du also jetzt hier so eine replay cam plötzlich hast und die komplette szene
aus der spielsituation bei dir in 3d auf dem tisch projiziert hast und das ist
natürlich fantastisch ja wenn ich mir das so vorstelle jetzt ein fußball länderspiel
und du hast die ganze zeit
Wirklich das ganze Fußballfeld vor dir auf dem Tisch und kannst dir irgendwie
die kleinen Oellikons da rumlaufen,
also das ist natürlich dann wirklich Harry Potter in Reinkultur.
Und sie haben wohl dafür, das hast du glaube ich schon erwähnt,
eine Kameratechnik gebaut und was ich auch nicht wusste letztes Mal,
Apple hat ja in den USA sich die Rechte für die Major League Soccer geholt, für die Fußballliga.
Ja und mit Disney haben sie halt ein Exklusiv-Deal,
die halt auch solcherartigen 3D-Content-Sachen halt irgendwie,
aber sie haben es nur sehr kurz gezeigt, wo ich mir dann auch denke,
vielleicht sind sie noch nicht ganz sicher, ob und wie und in welcher Qualität
sie das dann wiederum hinkriegen.
Davon kann man es sowieso ausgehen.
Das hier ist nämlich auch Replay, wenn man nämlich im Feingedruckten nochmal nachliest,
steht dort nicht, dass das ganze Spiel so übertragen wird,
sondern es ist immer nur so ein Replay Moment, das heißt es kann auch sein,
dass das dann nochmal nachgerendert und nachgeschärft und weiß der Geier was
ist und dass ihre Kameratechnik nicht gut genug ist, um das in Echtzeit quasi
irgendwo von irgendwo live rüber zu bringen, unklar.
Aber das Potential ist da und wenn es die Generation nicht kann,
dann kann es halt die nächste Generation, dann wird alles super.
Also ein Stadionbesuch wird das nach wie vor nicht,
aber es gibt ja mittlerweile,
also es ist ja so super krass, so ist das ja bei den High Value Leaks und so
weiter, mittlerweile so in England wird das gemacht, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz
genau wie verbreitet das ist, aber mittlerweile wird ja mit einer,
Manche Spiele werden mit einer super hohen Anzahl von Kameras gefilmt,
also ohnehin schon für alles mögliche,
man will ja viele Perspektiven haben, aber sie machen ja dann mittlerweile auch
so Bullet-Time-Effekte,
das heißt du hast so Flanke von rechts, Spieler steigt hoch,
köpft und in dem Moment so ratatatatatatat wird dann einfach mal die Perspektive
geändert und dann siehst du das. und...
Könnte schon interessantes futter sein für so eine ausspielung das ist zwar
jetzt in der 2d ausspielung auch schon ganz gut aber wenn du dann eben sozusagen
die möglichkeit hast dann auch diese perspektiven selber.
Du könntest in dem replay könntest du dich selber aufs spielfeld stellen.
Und kannst dich ins tor stellen und gucken wie entwickelt sich die situation gerade um dich herum.
Kannst du nochmal schnell das versteckte faul anbringen ja so das wird glaube
ich kommen das werden wir noch sehen.
Aber letztlich glaube ich rätseln wir schon noch also meine jetzt stellen wir
uns mal vor. Jeder von uns kauft sich so ein teil und ich glaube die wahrscheinlichkeit.
Ist gar nicht so gering. Ich spare schon. Also war ehrlich, also Wotti, sag mal.
Also wie soll ich sagen, zu meiner Verteidigung muss ich sagen,
die keine Verteidigung ist, ich weiß.
Also ich hatte das erste iPhone, ich hatte das erste iPad und ich hatte die erste Apple Watch.
Ja, was will ich eigentlich sagen? So einen Streak kann man einfach nicht unterbrechen.
Da bin ich besser dran, ich hatte nicht das erste iPhone, das habe ich geskippt.
Was einerseits eine gute Idee war, andererseits war es schon sehr cool das erste
iPhone, auch wenn es damals irgendwie ohne Jailbreak und hast du nicht gesehen
und einmal tief in alle Kisten greifen,
Man damit gar nicht telefonieren konnte, was es auch nicht wirklich gut konnte,
aber das ist nur am Rande.
Also vieles hat schon beim ersten iPhone gut funktioniert, aber telefonieren
war… Also was du uns sagen möchtest, du wirst ja eins kaufen.
Sagen wir mal so, ich hab wenig Ausrede.
Ich bin schon auch irgendwie ein pathologischer… Anders gefragt,
abgesehen von der reinen Neugier und Developer Interesse,
hast du ne Anwendung, siehst du ne Anwendung für dich wo du das Ding wirklich meinst,
ob das dann so ist, nochmal ne andere Frage, aber wo du jetzt so dir vorstellen
könntest so, ja damit könnte ich x machen was ich derzeit nicht machen kann
oder damit kann ich x machen was ich derzeit schon tue aber besser oder anders.
Ganz klare Antwort, nein.
Also ich hatte das zweite iPhone, das erste iPad und die erste Watch.
Ich fand schön, was 343max gesagt hat jetzt im WMR Podcast, nämlich er hat sich
das erste iPhone gekauft und die Entscheidung ernährt ihn heute noch.
Also eben ich bin eben auch in einem Job drin irgendwie Bereich Innovationsmanagement
wo es schon dazu gehört sehr früh von sowas einen vernünftigen Eindruck zu haben
und ich habe einen sehr billigen Deal mit meiner Frau Wortkomplex ausgehandelt,
ich muss nur den Wohnzimmerschrank neu organisieren dann könnte ich sie mir vielleicht kaufen.
Ich glaube in der Tat, dass ich auch mehr als genug Anwendungsfälle habe als
jemand, der mittlerweile signifikant im Homeoffice arbeitet.
Ich glaube, dass das also für Arbeitssituation und mein 9 to 5 Job schon mehr
als genug gute Anknüpfungspunkte hat.
Ich habe etwas Angst vor der Vereinzelungsanlage in der Tat,
dass man in eine Situation kommt, wo man eigentlich jetzt den Film gerne darüber gucken möchte,
weil es einfach nochmal viel geiler ist, als auf dem schon tollen,
aber immer noch nicht eben 200 Zoll Screen und Frau auf der Couch guckt aber halt in die Röhre.
Da sehe ich also noch irgendwie so Reibungsfläche was das angeht,
dass es eben doch derzeit mir ein sehr vereinzelndes Gerät erscheint und dass
ich das als Familienmensch eigentlich nicht so cool finde.
Also ich habe den ganz stupiden Displayfall eigentlich, finde ich glaube ich
ganz gut, So, einfach als diese Rechtfertigung, also das müsste funktionieren, wenn es Retina ist.
Ich habe natürlich das Interesse selber, das alles mal zu erleben,
um eben mitzuwissen, wie man so Interaktionen, die über eine Kombination aus
Augen und Gesten funktionieren sollen, wie man die gescheit macht.
Also das will ich von vornherein gleich, da will ich dabei sein.
Und ich will meine, ich mache so eine Farbmusik-Kram, also ich will wissen,
ob man damit zum Beispiel am Klavier Spaß hat.
Was hast du gesagt? Farbmusik-Kram?
Ja, das ist so. Ich bin schon seit Jahren so einem Farbmusiksystem verfallen,
was so ein bisschen funktioniert wie eine Piano-Roll und einem, ähm, also, ja.
Es ist immer schwer zu schreiben, es gibt immer so Einsteigerfarben,
Notationssysteme und ich habe eins,
das finde ich toll, habe ich mir in der App geschrieben, läuft auf iPad,
die würde ich gerne da so schreiben und dann kommen halt die Noten so rausgeflogen
aus dem Klavier oder reingeflogen,
wenn ich sie spielen soll und man legt sich halt dann diese UI so stabil aufs
Klavier, auf die Tasten, damit man, wenn man die Tasten drückt, was soll sich.
Und ich glaube, das könnte gut funktionieren, mit dem,
also mit der Quest funktioniert es nicht, der Einfallswinkel ist zu klein und
das, was die Apps da so gemacht haben bisher, also ich hab mir das immer angeguckt,
das war auch bei einem, sag ich schon, bei einem, sag ich mal,
bei einem Meta-Video, war auch eine App, die sowas gemacht hat.
Und wenn du es da wirklich davor sitzt, dann ist es ganz blöd im Blickwinkel,
dann hast du überhaupt keinen Vorteil dadurch, weil du anstatt,
dass du auf ein schönes DIN A4-Blatt guckst, wo du alles erkennen kannst,
auf die volle Breite vom Klavier siehst und dann siehst du nicht mal die Noten,
die du spielen sollst, wenn die so reinfliegen, das macht alles keinen Sinn.
Aber mein System macht Sinn und das würde ich da gerne auch in der 3D-Welt außenrum
haben und das würde ich gerne ausprobieren. Also das will ich machen.
Benutzen würde ich es auch gerne, wenn es jemand anders schon gemacht hat,
aber ich glaube nicht, dass es jemand anders vorher so macht,
dass ich es benutzen will. Deswegen so ein bisschen in die Reihe.
Und ansonsten brauche ich es nicht, aber ich will dabei sein.
Das ist, glaube ich, meine ehrliche Antwort. Zugegebenermaßen,
das mit dem externen Display, das kann ich mir sogar auch noch vorstellen,
dass man für so eine mobile Anwendung, wenn man seinen Laptop dabei hat und
will ein bisschen mehr Screenspace haben, Dass man das Ding dann noch da einsetzt.
Keine Ahnung. Weiß ich nicht. Müsste man mal ausprobieren, ob das wirklich was
bringt. Im Zweifelsfall oder nicht.
Ansonsten, ganz ehrlich, nee. Also für mich wär's schon einfach herauszufinden, was passiert da.
Was sind da die neuen Möglichkeiten oder wie fühlt sich das an,
einfach damit rumzuspielen, einfach ein Gefühl dafür zu kriegen.
Wie es geht also ich werde es mir nicht ungesehen kaufen sondern ich werde es
dann erst mal bei max oder sonst wo will ich mal einen tag auf herz und nieren
prüfen weil ich bin schon auch picky was so auflösung wird aber schwierig.
Ja weil diese ganze einmessgeschichte.
Geschichte, die kommt da mit rein. Also das ist halt ein Gerät,
das einfach, das kann man eigentlich auch nochmal betonen, das ist wahrscheinlich
das persönlichste Gerät, was Apple je rausgebracht haben wird.
Also bei einer Uhr musst du zwischen groß und klein unterscheiden und dann kannst
du ja noch irgendwie dein Armband aussuchen und das war's dann im Wesentlichen,
aber hier hängt es halt sehr von deinem Körper ab.
Und zwar nicht nur was die Linsen betrifft, sondern ja auch die Gesichtsmuffe,
aber auch das Strapband gibt es ja in verschiedenen Varianten.
Es gibt übrigens auch noch so ein Band optional oben auf dem Kopf.
Das haben sie in ein, zwei Einstellungen mal so kurz nebenbei fallen lassen,
haben aber nicht drüber geredet.
Also von daher, der Bestellprozess wird sicherlich sehr speziell sein und das
Ding wird mehr als 3.500 Euro kosten, das müssen wir uns auch mal klar machen, weil 3.500,
Dollar ist halt jetzt erstmal der US-Preis, dann haben wir nochmal Konvertierung,
dann kommt da Umsatzsteuer dazu, dann musst du noch zwei Linsen kaufen,
die irgendwie irgendeinen dreistelligen Betrag pro Stück wahrscheinlich aufrufen werden.
Also man kann mal locker davon ausgehen, dass man so bei 4, 5 oder sowas landet.
Und ein Netzteil ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht dabei.
Oh stimmt der Akku der kommt auch noch dazu. Man gibt ein 5er aus ne.
Aber das haben wir ja gesehen das geht ja auch für so ein Mac Studio und das
Ding ist ja im Prinzip auch eine Computing Plattform also man kann da eben Software
drauf laufen lassen und ist komplett eigenständig.
Womit es sich ja auch sehr von den anderen Dingern unterscheidet,
ich weiß nicht wie heißt dieser Quest, ist die komplett stand alone?
Ja? Okay gut aber das ist auf jeden Fall wie ein Mac oder wie ein iPad ist es ja.
Irgendwo zwischen iPad Pro und Macbook Air.
Aber es ist genau, mit Betonung auf R. Jetzt muss ich auch nochmal sagen,
würde ich mir eine kaufen.
Also ich bin ehrlich gesagt davon ausgegangen, dass das jetzt so die erste Produktkategorie
ist, die mich nicht sofort erfasst.
Ich meine das erste iPhone habe ich mir zwar nicht gekauft, aber ich war Feuer
und Flamme für das iPhone von Tag eins an. Also als ich diese Keynote gesehen
habe, da wusste ich, das Ding wird die Welt beherrschen und was ist es geworden?
Das erfolgreichste Produkt, was es jemals gab.
Also insofern war mein erster Eindruck hier auch ganz interessant für mich und
der war vor allem erstmal geprägt davon, dass ich recht geschockt war,
wie viele Dinge sie wirklich bedacht haben, die für mich so totale Dealbreaker waren.
Und von daher ist mein Interesse jetzt auf jeden Fall geschärft.
Anwendung für mich sehe ich tatsächlich
lustigerweise in diesem Bildschirm unterwegs in Isolationshaft,
weil das ist in der Tat eine Situation, in der ich mich öfter befinde,
wenn ich auf Podcastreisen bin, dann hänge ich halt in so einem Hotel rum oder
halt in der Bahn und hab dann oft so dieses Ding mit, hab ich jetzt einen Tisch
in der Bahn, wo ich meinen Laptop ordentlich draufstellen kann.
Wie groß ist der Laptop, kann ich da jetzt mal einen Podcast drauf schneiden?
Also wenn man damit einen Podcast schneiden kann,
dann ist das für mich schon wirklich interessant,
weil ich dann auf einmal einen großen Bildschirm, weil das brauchst du für Audio,
brauch ich einfach einen großen Screen, deswegen hab ich hier so Riesenbildschirme
irgendwie, also hier ist er jetzt nicht ganz so groß, aber mein größter ist
halt 38 Zoll und der ist mir eigentlich schon zu klein. Da wollte ich jetzt auf 40 gehen.
Reaper für Vision Pro.
Ja Reaper für Vision Pro und ich meine wenn ich das,
wenn ich also quasi einfach auf mein Macbook schauen kann und dann habe ich
halt irgendwie das Ding, wobei die Frage ist, muss ich den Laptop eigentlich
vor mir stehend aufgeklappt haben um das benutzen zu können oder kann ich den
auch zuklappen wie man das normalerweise beim externen Bildschirm auch macht.
Du kannst die Tastatur nicht mehr benutzen.
Da habe ich keine Tastatur, das stimmt.
Übrigens ein Feature was mir noch so ein bisschen fehlt sind ja Curved Windows.
Also ich hab so ein Curved Screen, so ein Ultra Wide, wie das Ding heißt, irgendwie 3800 auf 44.
Welchen hast du denn, den Dell oder den LG?
Ich glaube es ist ein Dell, ich weiß es nicht genau. Auf jeden Fall das Ding
ist ja für alles was eine Timeline hat, ist das ja super. Ja, absolut.
Und da wäre mir die Auflösung, wenn man die dann irgendwie auf die Vision Pro
machen könnte, dass man halt nicht so viel Höhe aber ganz viel Breite hat,
das wäre natürlich auch cool.
Ich war ein bisschen enttäuscht, als sie gesagt haben man kriegt einen 4K Bildschirm.
Ich will gar keinen 4K Bildschirm.
Ja aber 4K sind ja 8 Millionen Pixel, während Ultra Wide sind nur 5 Millionen Pixel.
Ja gut, das mit den Pixeln, ich glaube das relativiert sich ohnehin,
wo steht das Ding, wie weit ist es weg und wie gehst du da drauf?
Du musst ja in Datenmenge denken, die der Rechner auf die Vision Pro überträgt.
Deswegen geht wahrscheinlich auch nur ein 4K Display und nicht drei.
Achso, ja okay, wenn das jetzt die Limitierung ist, kein Ding.
Davon gehe ich mal aus.
Nee, aber ich hätte gerne diesen Panorama Viewer, den sie da so für ihre Panorama
Fotos gezeigt haben, das als Bildschirm möchte ich ja knaller haben.
Aber mal gucken, wie gesagt, unklar, aber das ist schon so etwas,
wo ich mir dachte, wow, da hätte ich aber jetzt mal wirklich einen Nutzen davon,
weil das Ding relativ kompakt zu tragen ist,
also mitzuführen ist, weil es nimmt ja schon auch noch ein bisschen Raum ein,
es ist ja auch ein klobiges Teil, die Frage, wie kompakt kriegst du das Ganze,
so Einzelteile zerlegen, du musst es auch immer wieder assemblen,
also das ist auch etwas, das war immer alles fertig da.
Aber das Ding hat natürlich auch noch so einen gewissen Handling Faktor,
du musst es mit dir führen in Einzelteilen zusammenbauen.
Also es soll ein bisschen größer sein als die Quest 2 und die Quest 2 kriege ich in so eine,
ich hab so ein Trageteil, da sind noch zwei Controller drin,
das ist nicht viel größer als hier von deinem Biodynamics Kopfhörer,
also es hält sich echt in Grenzen, das kriegst du in jeden Rucksack rein.
Ja, die Größe würde ich auch schätzen.
Genau, also ich denke das geht schon, aber alles was man mitführen muss,
ich meine es kommt ja zusätzlich zu dem Computer was ich bisher habe,
es ist halt nochmal extra was was man dabei haben muss, es ist extra was wo
man was vergessen kann, wo man ein Kabel nicht dabei hat, damit es einen Nutzen
hat muss es halt auch immer alles beisammen sein, das ist ja so das Problem
was man mit bedenken muss.
Man könnte aber argumentieren, es ist handlicher als ein Ultrawide Monitor mit in die Bahn zu nehmen.
Genau, das ist der Punkt an der Stelle, beziehungsweise es ist für mich die
Möglichkeit einen großen Bildschirm dabei zu haben und großer Bildschirm ist
genau das, was mir am meisten fehlt, wenn ich unterwegs bin.
Was ja alle noch rätseln, was auch noch nicht aufgelöst ist,
ist dieses Szenario, ja du kannst dich in der Bahn hinsetzen,
hast aber natürlich eigentlich den Sessel vor dir so ziemlich im Gesicht und
dann projizierst du deinen Monitor genau wohin.
Eigentlich willst du ja einen Meter Abstand haben, da sitzt dann ja aber wer
anders. Das kannst du natürlich alles rausrechnen, aber wie wird das visuell
aufgelöst, dass du also auf der einen Seite noch irgendwie im Zug drin sitzt
und dein Monitor an einer Stelle ist, wo er physikalisch überhaupt nicht sein kann.
Unklar, ob man dann also automatisch in so einen rein virtuellen Modus switchen
muss, einfach an der Stelle.
Es gibt wohl einen Travel Modus, der anders funktioniert, ist so die grundsätzliche
Antwort auf diese Frage gewesen, dass du praktisch in einem,
ich bin jetzt, Es gibt zwei Geschichten, die damit einspielen.
Das eine ist, das Ding funktioniert eh nicht, wenn du dich selbst zu schnell
bewegst, was im Flugzeug auch der Fall ist. Also da gibt es einfach einen anderen
Modus, in dem die ganze Kiste läuft.
Sehr spannend aber. Sehr spannend.
Was man natürlich argumentieren kann, wenn man sich das iPhone anguckt und auch
das iPad anguckt, dass es wahrscheinlich sinnvoll ist auf die zweite Generation zu warten.
Weil wahrscheinlich gerade in der ersten Generation Apple am meisten lernt und
wahrscheinlich auch am meisten Fehlannahmen ausbügelt.
Ja, wobei alle Berichte die ich gehört habe, sehr staunend berichtet haben davon
wie mature das alles rüberkommt. Also dass es genau diese Effekte von den ersten
Generationen, gerade wie bei der Apple Watch und so weiter so überhaupt nicht hätte.
Na gut, ist natürlich gut, dass sie es schon so lange vorher präsentiert haben,
weil sie jetzt nicht mehr einen groß auf Geheimhaltung machen müssen und dann
mit relativ großen Fokusgruppen arbeiten können, die halt die Keynote schon
gesehen haben und jetzt dann und so und so.
Aber ich war noch nicht ganz fertig mit was ich mir für mich jetzt sozusagen
überlegt habe, was eine gute Ausrede sein könnte, um sich so ein Ding zu kaufen.
Wenn du eine Ausrede brauchst, machst du sowieso schon was.
Nein, nein, ich brauche keine Ausrede. Ich sehe das schon so,
es ist eine signifikante Investition, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie 5K raushaue,
das mache ich jetzt auch nicht mal so eben.
Mit dem Macintosh warte ich ja jetzt auch schon seit 10, 12 Jahren.
Nur beim Überlegen was sozusagen Anwendungen sind und zwar sowohl für mich als auch im Allgemeinen,
glaube ich gibt es eine Zielgruppe, die wird Apple sofort vom Tag 1 an die Bude
einrennen, die nicht Developer sind und das ist halt alles was mit Architektur zu tun hat.
Weil so in so hoher Qualität und dann auch sowohl mit dem AR-Aspekt als auch dem VR-Aspekt,
also stell dir mal vor du bist jetzt so Kirchenrestaurator oder sowas ja und du machst den 3D-Plan,
wie das dann in Zukunft mal aussieht und dann läufst du in der Kirche selber
rum und siehst, kannst du sozusagen mit dem Rädchen zwischen alt und neu hin und her schalten.
Also das wäre so ein bisschen mein Tipp für eine der Business-Anwendungen,
die sehr schnell kommen wird.
Also alles, was so mit Architektur draußen, 3D-Modellen zu tun hat,
diese Zusammenführung, da passt das irgendwie wie Arsch auf Eimer.
Und er hat es ja schon mal angedeutet, jetzt ist ja Chaos Communication Camp
in sechs Wochen mittlerweile.
Puh, die Zeit naht.
42 Tage habe ich seitdem auf Maastricht und Gelsen.
Genau, okay. Und ich habe ja wieder ein kleines Projekt zusammen gerufen und
wir machen auf dem Camp eine Lichtinstallation.
Und hatte ich schon mal angedeutet, aber kann ich ja vielleicht mal ein bisschen
erzählen, weil mittlerweile wissen wir auch, dass es funktionieren wird.
Da gibt es nämlich diese ganzen Ziegelei-Gebäude und das eine Ziegelei-Gebäude,
das hat irgendwie zehn Fenster, die vor drei Jahren mit Glasbausteinen nachgerüstet wurden.
Das heißt, da ist dann so eine Pixelmatrix, quasi so eine natürliche und davon
gibt es zehn Fenster, die jeweils acht mal acht Pixel haben.
Also 640 Pixel sollte ja für alle reichen und wir waren jetzt sehr fleißig in
den letzten Wochen und Monaten und haben solche Lichtkästen gebaut,
die wir jetzt quasi hinter die Dinger installiert haben, das steht da schon
und funktioniert auch und machen halt mit LEDs quasi diese Glasbausteine farbig.
Und es ist jetzt gerade der totale Pain, das sozusagen zu visualisieren.
Es gibt zwar einen sehr schönen webbasierten Simulator, der das auch ganz hübsch
macht, aber es ist halt nochmal was komplett anderes, wenn du wirklich diese
Situation jetzt echt mal so richtig dreidimensional immersiv machen könntest.
Also wenn du wirklich sozusagen auf dem Gelände stehst und dann auch die Tageszeit
simulieren kannst, sozusagen die Lichtverhältnisse ändern könntest.
Mit einem anderen Rädchen, das Rädchen selber macht ja sozusagen ARVR,
aber für solche Sachen,
also Kunst, Messebau, alles was in irgendeiner Form so mit der Schaffung von
Werken im öffentlichen Raum zu tun hat,
da ist diese Brille einfach der totale Arsch auf Eimer, also ich glaube da wird
es sehr schnell Bewegung geben in diesem Bereich.
Nimm mal Graffiti Kunst. Du entwirfst zu Hause dein Graffiti Bild,
so wie du es perfekt haben willst, gehst vor Ort, projizierst dir das digital
auf eine Wand und kannst dann quasi malen nach Zahlen.
Ich denke gerade unsere Sprayer Freunde sind da eine gute Zielgruppe für dieses kaum teure Gewalt.
Da musst du aber darauf achten, dass der Wind richtig steht, sonst wird es teuer.
Aber das ist letztendlich ein bisschen das, was auch Dom gerade gesagt hat,
mit seinem quasi Musikinstrument lernen oder unterstützen so.
Ich glaube in dem Bereich ist noch viel zu holen. Wo du also plötzlich mit einem
digital physischen Objekt, mit einem echten realen Objekt interagierst und dort
aber eben nochmal eine digitale Ebene drüber legst, die was auch immer anstellt an der Stelle.
Übrigens, wenn du gucken willst, wie das mit den Beleuchtungsverhältnissen und
so weiter und Tag und Nacht und so ist, dann solltest du vielleicht einen Blick
auf Unreal Engine 5 werfen, weil das hat glaube ich so,
Die bis jetzt beste Beleuchtungsimmersion, die du haben kannst.
Also mit Tagesverlauf und.
Es ist halt schon Arbeit. Also wenn du dann, sagen wir mal, jemanden in Berlin
zeigen willst, so wird's aussehen im Ziegleipark, musst du natürlich dann eben
schon irgendwie ein 3D-Rendering dieser Szene haben, damit jemand darin rumlaufen kann.
Ansonsten hast du immer nur dieses so guckst dir einen 3D-Film an.
Ja, ich meine, war jetzt nicht mein Plan,
sowas zu programmieren, sondern mir ist nur im Kontext der Entwicklung klar
geworden, dass das und dann entsprechende Tools dafür natürlich auch absolut perfekt wären.
Aber das ist ein Anwendungsfall, den man halt nicht gesehen hat,
der aber denke ich mit der Hardware vielleicht möglich ist. Also es gibt ja
für das iPhone schon diverse Apps, wo du das einfach nur nimmst und kreuz und
quer durch den Raum nimmst und danach bekommst du ein hinreichend okayische 3D-Modellierung.
Dieses Raumes. Wenn du da jetzt mit dieser Kamera durchläufst,
die also das x-fache an Auflösung und an Rechenpower hat, werden sie irgendwann
mal einen Modus anbieten, so geh irgendwo hin und virtualisiere quasi diesen
Raum und ab da kannst du den irgendwo anders nutzen, obwohl du gar nicht da bist.
Also das, was ich auch eben gesagt hatte, weg von diesem, ich gucke mir einen
3D-Film an, hin zu einem, ich bin in einer echten 3D-Umgebung,
in der ich mich auch wirklich im Raum vernünftig bewegen kann und bewegt sich vernünftig mit.
Ist aber alles nicht so ganz ganz trivial, weil wenn da ein Tisch ist und in deiner,
also wenn in der aufgezeichneten Realität ein Tisch irgendwo steht und in deiner
Abspiel-Realität kein Tisch ist, oder umgekehrt noch schlimmer,
rennst du halt plötzlich irgendwo gegen, wo du gar keinen Tisch siehst.
Also das hat so seine Issues. Aber grundsätzlich, da wird noch was passieren, glaube ich.
Ja, aber ein schickes 3D-Modell erzeugen ist ja schon mal eine Anwendung an sich, ne? also.
Stell dir mal vor du bist Küchenbauer und du würdest jetzt so einen Auftrag bekommen,
du sollst halt in irgendeiner Wohnung eine Küche bauen und du würdest jetzt
mit diesem Headset da rein latschen und quasi erstmal in so einem AR Modus die
Räumlichkeiten, Aufmaß machen.
Also du nimmst sozusagen den Raum auf und zwar halt mit Video und mit seinen 3D Beschaffenheiten,
dann kannst du in Ruhe deine Küche in dieses selbe Modell rein planen und dann
hättest du die Möglichkeit einem Kunden,
das ist jetzt wieder die Frage, Gästenmodus, hat jemand sowas und so weiter,
aber in irgendeiner Form könntest du eben die, also erstmal kannst du es dir
selber anschauen und damit zufrieden sein Auf welchem Weg auch immer das präsentieren.
Ausdrucken und per Fax. Ausdrucken und per Fax, genau. Schland.
Ich glaub das ist dann vielleicht auch wieder Fax für die das ein Objektdrucker
hat. Apple Fax Pro. 3D Fax. 3D Fax.
Dann ist es dann wieder Fax. So müssen wir es der FDP verkaufen, dann läuft's.
Genau, 3D Fax.
Ja also da ist schon Musik drin,
aber genauso wie man glaube ich bei der Apple Watch am Anfang noch nicht so
richtig sagen konnte welche dieser Pitches die sie da so gegeben haben am Ende
am meisten Pudding an die Wand bringt ist das hier glaube ich auch so.
Aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das Ding nicht zumindest erst mal kräftig
gekauft werden wird und so weit ich gehört habe sind ja auch diese Displays
erst mal gar nicht so hoch verfügbar,
also die werden wahrscheinlich gar nicht beliebig viele davon herstellen können,
es kann gut sein, dass sie einfach alles verkaufen werden, was sie überhaupt
produzieren können im ersten Anlauf.
Also, keine Ahnung, bei der Apple Watch ist das Killer-Feature auf jeden Fall Multiple-Timer.
Hier, supergeiles 3D-Headset, damit kannst du mehrere Timer setzen.
Auf dem iPhone geht das auch.
Auf dem iPhone geht's auch, aber es geht halt jetzt auch auf der Apple Watch.
Jaja, Siri kann das jetzt irgendwie.
Ich muss ja wissen, wann die Waschmaschine fertig ist, aber gleichzeitig will
ich ja trotzdem noch einen Tee machen und wissen, dass der nicht zu stark wird.
Ja, und auch beim Kochen brauchen wir das ein.
Mindestens zwei Timer.
Eine Kleinigkeit, die ich noch
hatte zum Thema, worüber wurde nicht gesprochen, fand ich sehr spannend.
Sie hatten über die, was war die Engine, über die Sie gesprochen hatten?
Unity. Unity, sie hatten über Unity-Engine gesprochen,
sie haben aber nicht über die Unreal-Engine gesprochen, was irgendwie klar ist,
weil sie mit Epic fürchterlich im Clinch liegen und ich finde es wird mal Zeit,
dass Apple und Epic sich irgendwie mal, irgendwie einkriegen und, und.
Sieht aber glaub ich mehr an Epic.
Ja, von einer Firma, die von allem 30 Prozent haben will zu sagen,
dass die anderen sind blöd und riechen nach Lulo finde ich jetzt,
also klar, Eppings sind diejenigen, die gesagt haben.
Wenn die andere anfängt einen ikonischsten Werbespot irgendwie umzudrehen und
da so eine billige Aktion, also egal, können wir später mal drüber reden,
fand ich auf jeden Fall überhaupt nicht cool, dass sie da abgezogen haben.
Du brauchst Unreal, das würde schon eine andere Größenordnung von Qualität da
rein machen, weil Unity ist Kinderkacke.
Ja, weil die Unreal Engine ist momentan halt auch irgendwie,
ich will nicht sagen alternativlos, aber doch zumindest halbwegs konkurrenzlos.
Und Vision Pro ohne Unreal Engine wäre halt schon auch schade.
Ja, aber ich meine Unreal gibt's doch auch noch, oder? Also ich meine Epic als
Firma verkauft Spiele und Unreal Engine ist doch auch, glaube ich,
in der sonstigen Welt getrennt.
Im Prinzip schon, und du kannst die Unreal Engine auch auf dem Mac benutzen,
über diesen Epic Dingstar Launcher.
Es ist nur, wenn, sagen wir mal so, ab einem bestimmten Komplexitätsgrad wäre
es gut, wenn sich Firmen so weit gut verstehen, dass sie halt auch hauptwegs
zusammenarbeiten und nicht gegeneinander.
Und das ist halt etwas, wo die beiden Firmen, bin ich der Meinung,
dann mal irgendwie was klarkriegen müssen.
Ob sich jetzt Apple und Nvidia auf die Dauer irgendwann mal verstehen werden, weiß ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung, das ist vielleicht nicht ganz so wichtig.
Auch wenn Nvidia halt bei dem ganzen Machine Learning den Fuß so unglaublich
in der Tür hat, zumindest behaupten sie es.
Und danach ist der Markt dann auch, hat sie, bewertet sie danach,
weiß ich nicht. Also es gibt halt auch kein Fortnite mehr auf dem Mac.
So viel zum Thema Spielen auf dem Mac. Also gut, ob man jetzt Fortnite gut findet
oder nicht, muss auch jeder selber wissen. Aber, also, keine Ahnung.
Was fehlt uns noch? Fehlt noch irgendwas? Worüber haben wir uns denn noch nicht geredet?
Das war's.
Also das Wort VR ist auch nicht ein einziges Mal gefallen.
Ja, das ist mir auch aufgefallen.
Also wir haben dieses ganze Thema Gaming, Virtual Reality, das war einfach vollständig…
Sie haben es ja XR genannt, oder?
Ja, das ist ja jetzt so… Extended Reality oder? Nee, nicht mehr.
Es hieß noch XA als Codewort innen drin, aber es ist nicht erwähnt worden.
Stimmt, das ist Vision OS.
Ich meine, sie haben VR gezeigt,
weil technisch ist es eine VR Brille, weil sie ja komplett abschließt und sie
haben auch einen Modus, den man eigentlich als VR bezeichnen könnte,
der halt dann Full Immersion heißt.
Aber es geht immer alles von AR aus. Es geht immer davon aus,
dass du in Verbindung bist mit deiner Umgebung.
Und ich glaube das ist ein ganz ganz wichtiger Punkt, den man gar nicht oft
genug betonen kann und deswegen haben die ja auch so drauf eingehämmert mit
all ihren ganzen Demonstrationen.
Einerseits. Andererseits sagt es halt auch aus,
dass Apple offensichtlich in dieser ganzen VR-Geschichte so auch erstmal gar
nicht das Potenzial sieht,
was ich ganz putzig finde, weil über diese Headsets seit ich denken kann,
immer als VR-Device gesprochen wird.
Das hier Jean-Ren Lannier auf der CeBIT schon irgendwie einem links und rechts
um die Ohren geballert hat.
In den 90er Jahren ging das ja schon los, immer da mit ihrer Datenhandschuhe
und Brille und so weiter, VR, Metaverse, ich bin hier irgendwie komplett drin.
Und der Zuckerberg, der hat ja irgendwie die Pille auch gefressen und will ja
auch irgendwie sozusagen seine Vision vollständig in der Virtualität platzieren.
Du bist so rum im abgeschnittenen Tor so, wie so ein alberner Comicfigur.
Nicht mehr, sie haben die Beine nachgerüstet.
Ja hurra, okay dann baumeln noch irgendwas dran, aber du bist trotzdem halt
nur so ein Abklatschdeiner selbst so und sollst dann irgendwie mit allen anderen
rumsocheln und totale Katastrophe.
Und Apple zeigt eigentlich Facebook komplett den Stinkefinger und sagt,
sorry, aber ihr habt das alles komplett falsch verstanden.
Wir gehen mal hier von der echten Interaktion aus.
Der soziale Raum, da nehmen wir doch einfach den, den wir sowieso schon haben
und sorgen dafür, dass diese Technologie denen so wenig wie möglich beschneidet.
Aber auch gleichzeitig diese Integration zu machen. Das ist irgendwie,
denke ich, schon so ein bisschen das Rezept.
AR ist halt auch schwieriger. VR kann jeder, der irgendwie einen Gyro und einen
Accelerometer ordentlich hinkriegt und irgendwo so eine Lightbar irgendwo hinstellt,
dann hast du ein brauchbares VR.
Aber dieses AR, zusammen mit dem ich beleuchte meine Fenster richtig,
bla bla bla, das ist halt nochmal eine Entwicklungsstufe.
Ich glaube, dass da einige auch tief durchgeatmet haben, in anderen Firmen,
die das gesehen haben, weil was Apple da gezeigt hat, das ist technologisch
schon ganz schön abgefahren.
Allerdings.
Also da sind sie wirklich in so vielen Bereichen vorne, dass… Wir haben ein
paar hundert Patente, irgendwo hatte ich die Zahl gelesen, 300 irgendwas oder so mindestens.
Also iPhone hat Google ja dann nach ein paar Jahren dann doch ganz gut nachgebaut bekommen,
aber ich glaube das wird jetzt hier bei dieser Brille ganz schön wenig Player
geben, die da schnell folgen können.
Dauert glaube ich auch zu lange, bis klar ist,
was der eine Anwendungsfall dafür ist, weil es wird, glaube ich,
eine lange Zeit geben, wo das, was die Apple Vision Pro jetzt macht,
so wie sie es macht, genau so wie sie es macht, sinnvoll ist.
Aber kein einzelner Bereich davon wird jetzt einfach auf eine andere Brille
zu übersetzen sein und macht da jetzt, also so wie es beim Telefon war,
alle müssen jetzt Touchscreen haben, naja, glaube ich nicht.
Ich glaube, das passiert bei dem Produkt nicht. Das ist jetzt schon mehr der Mac damals.
Und das andere ist Windows. Und das ist halt anders. Oder DOS noch nach wie vor.
Und das wird jetzt eine Zeit lang so bleiben. Und wenn sich was ganz Klares
herauskristallisiert, so ein Unterbereich daraus, dann wird es auch eine Kopie davon geben.
Aber bis dahin nicht, weil das ist einfach viel zu viel Aufwand und viel zu
teuer, ohne zu wissen, dass es erfolgreich ist.
Das trauen sich die anderen nicht nachzuziehen bevor sie es nicht wissen.
Aber ich glaube du hast jetzt eine neue Plattform,
also da ist ein Betriebssystem und da hast du Anwendungen drauf und es ist eigentlich
eine neue Plattform und ich denke es wird einen zweiten Spieler geben in dem
Bereich der das gleiche tun wird,
erst mal nicht so gut und und und hakelig und weiß ich nicht was und wahrscheinlich
dann auch nicht so einfach dafür software zu schreiben aber es wird den zweiten
spieler geben das wird das sein bleibt doch nur microsoft also die quest 3 probiert
ja schon genau das jetzt also die haben dann ja quasi am tag nach der keynote ein irres.
Propagandafeuerwerk abgefeuert ihr müsst gar nicht warten bis ihr das kommt
sondern hier für 400 euro kriegt ihr das alles schon im herbst,
weil die ja dann eben auch diesen pass-through-modus jetzt in farbe machen und
angeblich höher aufgelöst und so weiter und sagen so ist eigentlich alles genauso gut.
Also Facebook ist da schon dran so an der Idee.
Ich weiß nicht ob es Facebook sein wird oder ob es Google sein wird oder ob
es Microsoft sein wird oder ein Player den wir alle noch nicht auf dem Plan haben,
den dann einer von den großen kaufen wird, so wie Android ja auch nur von Google
gekauft wurde, ich meine das haben sie ja nicht selber entwickelt.
Keine Ahnung das wird man sehen.
Google kauft Meta.
Google kauft Meta und ja, da hat man sich die richtigen Ziele.
Peter wird kurz vor der Pleite stehen und dann ...
Lecker lecker kauf ja oder ilan kauft
meta da finden sich die richtigen da können sie sich dann wirklich was interessant
wird ist ob der druck jetzt auf den auf so technischen specks wie auflösung
und blickwinkel jetzt so hoch wird dass er auch die normalen vr headsets jetzt unter druck bringt.
Ob man jetzt sagt so okay es darf einfach nirgendwo mehr ein pixel zu sehen
sein und ich möchte keine leihrende mehr sehen und keine taura brille nur wenn
es erfolgreich ist und das wissen sie erst zu spät also das die auslösung.
Nee das glaube ich nicht. Das glaube ich nicht also also die entwicklung dass
man keine pixel mehr sieht ist glaube ich eine total logische.
Die anderen Hersteller, wenn sie es raushauen könnten, würden sie es tun,
da bin ich mir hundertprozentig sicher.
Also ob du jetzt das Video, das du jetzt in der AR-Brille von Apple so da rein
präselst auf einer Retina-Art und Weise oder ob du eine komplett virtuelle Welt
generieren musst, die so funktioniert mit dem Headset und dem anderen,
also du hast eine andere Ausgangsposition.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, dass sich da viel befruchtet, außer dass es ein bisschen
die Leute, die es schon gibt, die machen halt Konkurrenz und die sagen halt,
wir können das schon lange und das ist alles goodie, aber die können halt nicht
das, was Apple daraus gemacht hat. Also das, ich weiß nicht.
Das sag ich ja auch nicht. Ich glaube aber, dass es Follower geben wird.
Also ob die jetzt fast oder eher slow sind, das wird man sehen.
Also es wird auf jeden Fall Firmen geben, die werden versuchen so etwas ähnliches zu machen.
Und dann gibt's ein bisschen Hauen und Stechen und dann wird sich einer durchsetzen,
der halt dann hinterher läuft.
Und ich meine Android hat gezeigt, sie sind lange hinterher gelaufen,
bis sie irgendwann den Punkt erreicht haben, wo man sagen kann,
Okay, das nimmt sich jetzt nicht mehr so viel, ob man jetzt Apple-Fan oder Android-Fan ist.
Ich glaube, man kann schon sagen, dass das so halbwegs auf dem gleichen Level ist.
Aber das hat ja jetzt dann auch fast 15 Jahre gedauert.
Und das kann durchaus sein, dass es bei den Brillen genauso ist,
dass das dann 10 Jahre dauert, bis der beste Follower irgendwie auf dem gleichen
Stand ist. Aber ich denke, das wird passieren.
So, ist jetzt erstmal alles gesagt zur Vision Pro?
Ja, vielleicht noch nicht von allen, aber...
Von uns zumindest jetzt erstmal.
Von uns? Ja, ich hoffe.
Ja wir sind jetzt schon bei gut viereinhalb Stunden.
Kann man lassen.
Möchte irgendjemand seinen Klangkram Rest noch hinten ran werfen?
Von der Dynamik der Sendung her sind wir jetzt eigentlich durch.
Über Reddit sollten wir nächstes mal reden, das machen wir jetzt sicher nicht mehr.
Ja ich denke auch wir machen jetzt kein großes Thema mehr auf und eigentlich auch kein kleines mehr.
Insofern könnten wir das Ende
einleiten. Dom du hast aber noch so eine Kleinigkeit. Ich weiß ja nicht.
Welche Kleinigkeit meinst du denn?
Mit deinem Playdate aber.
Mit meinem Playdate ja das habe ich jetzt gerade erst heute bekommen deswegen.
Es war sehr eine sehr schöne Experience aber das muss man jetzt auch nicht hinterherwerfen.
Ich versuche das mal mit der Kamera irgendwie auf die Kette zu kriegen,
dass wir dich hier mal richtig eingebunden bekommen, das nervt mich jetzt mega.
Ja ja, wäre schon besser gewesen. Also die GoPro geht zurück und ich erwarte
von unserem erlauchten Hörerkreis tolle Ideen,
wie ich hier die perfekte Kamera reinkriegen kann.
Vielleicht muss ich auch hier so eine richtige Kamera, DLSR,
irgendwas kaufen, ist mir egal, kann ja Dual Use haben, dann ist es super,
aber ich brauche hier irgendwas, was einfach mindestens 120 Grad,
idealerweise sogar 150 Grad ist.
Und auch in dunkler Nacht noch ordentliche Bilder macht und korrekt als Webcam
erkannt wird und zwar nicht hier so eine Scheiße wie das GoPro macht,
das ist mir nämlich jetzt eben erst klar geworden, nachdem ich mir das nochmal angeschaut habe,
diese dusselige App macht gar nicht eine richtige Webcam als Device ins System,
sondern nudelt das irgendwie nur auf so eine Art und Weise, dass es dann in
Zoom irgendwie erscheint, aber in Facetime halt nicht, was ist denn das bitte
für ein Kack-GoPro geht weg ey. Das war's.
Ich hatte meine GoPro mal irgendwie über dieses Streamer Ding,
dieses Studio Streamer Ding,
OBS, genau, ich hatte meine GoPro mal über OBS eingebunden und dann hatte ich
halt die eingebaute Cam und die GoPro in OBS zum Umschalten und so weiter.
Ja aber dann musst du dann wieder irgendwo hin streamen, das würde jetzt für
meine Anwendung auch nicht gut gehen.
Nee du kannst dann bei OBS kannst du da eine virtuelle Kamera erstellen,
die dann wiederum in Zoom auftaucht.
Piss die Wand an ey, so einen Scheiß mach ich erst gar nicht,
ich will was ordentliches haben.
Das hat aber gut funktioniert, ich hab damit einen Vortrag gemacht.
Ja aber ich meine das ist auch so elend, du musst dir sogar noch dieses Batteriefach
aufmachen, damit du da überhaupt ein USB-C Kabel reinstecken kannst.
Ja aber es gibt auch den extra Zusatz Batteriefach Klappdingsi um dauerhaftes USB Kabel anzubringen.
Ja hab ich bei meiner dabei.
Dann ist sie aber nicht mehr wasserdicht.
Wir können das nochmal mit dem iPhone in Ruhe probieren mit dem Follow Mode.
Ist mir auch zu fummelig. Ich will was haben, was ich da...
Ich bin offen für eure Empfehlungen, außerdem für Spenden, weil ich muss mir
unbedingt eine Vision Pro kaufen, ich hab jetzt die ersten Ausreden schon parat.
Und außerdem muss ja hier auch die Pizzaversorgung sichergestellt werden.
Vision Pro Spenden immer gerne gesehen, auch mehrere Vince.
Genau für einen bedürftigen Podcaster.
Und ja dann probieren wir das auf jeden Fall nochmal Dom mit dir.
Das funktioniert nämlich eigentlich ganz gut hier mit dem Beamer.
Oder ich kauf noch einen Bildschirm. Oder überhaupt. Ich brauch ganz viel Geld
damit wir hier Dom ordentlich eingebunden bekommen.
Sonst noch was?
Viele Themen, die wir wieder aufs nächste Mal verschieben müssen.
Wir sind noch lange nicht fertig.
Insofern können wir glaube ich jetzt hier mal das Ende einleiten.
Oder habt ihr noch letzte Worte? Nein, war Schluss, ich muss aufs Klo.
Das hast du so schön gesagt. Da musst du einfach nur dein Immerset-Prat abdrehen.
Okay Leute, das war's. Freakshow 267 vom irgendeinem Datum.
5.7. ist jetzt mittlerweile und dann kriegt ihr das wahrscheinlich auch zum
Download runter. Wir sagen tschüss, bis bald.
Servus. Macht's gut.
Der Missil weiß, wo er ist, in allen Zeiten. Er weiß dies, weil er weiß, wo er nicht ist.
Aber das bedeutet nicht, dass der Missil sich in Verlust ansieht.
Ein Missil muss ludikrische Wege fahren, um sein Ziel zu erreichen.
Das Ziel oft sind Meilen entfernt. Ein Speck. Ein Traum.
Seine Chancen, sein Ziel zu erreichen, sind am meisten schlimm,
besonders wenn es unvorbereitet, unvorbereitet ist, und seit Jahren in Storage gerottet ist.
Und das Ziel bewegt sich. Bei solchen Geschwindigkeiten ist es unvorstellbar
für den menschlichen Geist. Aber trotz alldem sagt das Missile nicht,
dass es nicht weiß, wo es ist. Es sagt nur, wo es hingehen sollte.
Die Macht im Missile liegt darin, seine Fähigkeit zu wissen,
wo es enden wird, und mit kleinen, zahlreichen Veränderungen,
jeden Sekunden, jeden Tag und jeden Jahr.
Das Missile nimmt seine tiefsten und mindestens schreckenden Kursveränderungen
und Verschleißungen und macht etwas bemerkenswertes.
Es dreht seine Verschleißungen in Lektionen, um sie auf dem richtigen Weg zu
leiten. Seine Verschleißer sind nicht nur unvermöglich, sondern auch notwendig,
um die Missile den richtigen Weg zu finden.
Die Missile fliegt, wenn sie es braucht. Sie brennt nicht all ihr Fuer in einem
bescheidenen Zustand, um die Erleuchtung zu erreichen.
Die Missile kennt ihren Ziel, aber will Fuer retten, bis die richtige Zeit kommt,
wenn sie streikt und ihren Zweck erfüllt.
Die Missile nimmt den Weg von Selbstvertrauen und steilem Aufwachsen,
bis ihre Zeit kommt. Und wenn diese Zeit kommt, wird sie mehr Freude erleben,
als sie sich vorgestellt hätten.
Die Missile wird Freude nehmen, dass sie gegen das Sterben der Lichtung schreit,
und sie verweigert sich, ruhig in diese gute Nacht zu gehen.
Aber alles begann mit der ersten Schritt der Missile. Sonst wäre sie noch in
ihrer Container-Unit, und fragt sich, was passiert ist.
Die Missile weiß, dass ihre größten Lektionen darin liegen, ihre eigene Angst.
Also sollte sie sie umbringen, und sie formen, bis sie nichts zu befreien hat,
sogar das Größte der Herausforderungen zu begrüßen, der für Erfahrung leidend ist.
Für die Missile wird ihre größte Angst nicht das, was passieren wird,
sondern das, was passieren wird, wenn sie ihre eigene Angst nicht herausfordern.
Keine von ihnen wäre sogar möglich ohne Ziel, eine vorbestimmte Zielstelle,
eine hartgewirbte Maschine, die die Instruktionen tief in den kühlen Gründen
des Missilienbelehrungssystems schreibt.
Ohne das Ziel würde die Missile unzumutbar wandern, bis sie ein Orphanage oder
ein anderes katastrophales Ziel befindet, das nie erwartet wurde.
Die Missile sucht nicht, den Wind oder die Turbulenz für ihre Verschleierungen
zu schulden. Der Missile ist das unnötige und ein Wasten von Zeit.
Die Missile sucht nicht, die Opfer der Umstände zu werden. Sie will in Kontrolle
sein und Verantwortung tragen.
Sie will so sicher und so stabil sein, wie sie sagt, dass sie ist.
Sie muss sich gegen die Kräfte schützen, die sie begegnen muss.
Du bist, was du sagst, du bist. Bist du verloren oder bist du nur auf dem Weg zu etwas Großem?
You are the master of your destiny, just as the missile is.